[Musique]
Messieurs, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Serview. Nous
sommes en direct. Alain Grèche, Ren
Broman. Alain Grèche, est-ce que vous
pouvez vous présenter succintement ? Bon
euh je suis né en en Égypte en 1948 dans
une famille égyptienne mais dont ma mère
était juive d'origine russe. Euh j'ai
grandi un moment très important dans
l'histoire de l'Égypte puisque c'est le
moment où le le roi est tombé, les
officiers libres et Kamal Abd Nasser ont
pris le pouvoir. C'était la
nationalisation du canal de Suèze, il y
a eu la guerre. Donc on a vécu comme
enfant la guerre et on peut dire que on
a été politisé, mon frère et moi, très
jeune par le contexte. En 62, on a
quitté l'Égypte, on s'est installé en
France, j'ai fait des études de
mathématiques et puis bon, j'étais
plutôt intéressé à la fois par la
région, le proche-Orient et par la
politique. Et donc, j'ai abandonné ça et
je me j'ai fait une thèse sur l'histoire
des Palestiniens et puis j'ai travaillé
pendant 30 ans au monde diplomatique et
puis maintenant, je dirige un journal en
ligne qui s'appelle Orient 21 qui suit
l'actualité du du monde arabe et
musulman. Et j'ai écrit une dizaine de
livres dont l'essentiel sur le conflit
palestinien et dont le dernier porte
sur ce qui s'est passé après Gaza et qui
s'appelle Palestine, un peuple qui ne
veut pas mourir.
Ta mam.
Reny Broman.
Mais moi pour suivre un peu le le
l'itinéraire qui a donné Ain Grèche, je
suis né en 1950
à Jérusalem
de parents qui avaient émigré en Israël
en 48. mon père pour y faire la guerre
de 48, c'était un activiste sioniste, un
instructeur militaire et un militant
sioniste depuis avant la guerre
d'ailleurs.
Mais apparemment la vie en Israël ne
leur a pas convenu autant que il
l'attendait. Et je suis venu en France à
l'âge de 4 ans et demi en l'hiver 54 et
j'ai grandi en France et j'ai fait des
études que je rêvais de faire à savoir
la médecine. Je suis donc médecin de
formation.
J'ai exercé surtout dans les conditions
une conditions particulières disons de
médecine humanitaire. J'ai rejoint
médecin sans frontière très vite dans
les années 70
pour une période brève et puis 45 ans
plus tard j'y suis toujours. Je suis
toujours membre de Médecin Sventier dont
j'ai été pendant 12 ans le président
entre 82 et 94
et je me suis intéressé au conflit
israélo-palestinien à partir des années
en réalité parce que les questions de
mémoire
m'intéressai les rapports entre mémoire
politique instrumentalisation de la
mémoire au service d'un pouvoir ça ça
m'a intéressé dans diverses
circonstances ce qui s'appelle la
Bosnie, le Rwanda et d'autres et
d'autres situations de crise majeure. Et
j'en suis venu à m'intéresser également
à la mémoire juive, c'est-à-dire la
mémoire de la de la Choa. J'ai contribué
un film sur Aichman à partir des
archives du process de ce criminel nazi.
Et c'est un peu comme ça dans les une je
fais écrit un un livre avec Eal Sivan,
le réalisateur du film et qui a été
aussi le mon co-auteur pour ce livre et
nous sommes trouvés l'un et l'autre
projeté sur la scène publique à la
sortie de ce film et donc impliqué dans
la les réactions publiques sur le
conflit israélo-palsien au début des
années 2000 en pleine 2e intifad lorsque
des esprits se sont embrasés et lorsque
finalement avec le recul, on voit que on
assistait un tournant avec qui qui a
débouché sur une polarisation extrême
des positions sur ce conflit
polarisation dont on est évidemment pas
sorti, qui n'a fait que s'approfondir,
qui n'a fait que s'aiguiser
un peu plus et à laquelle ben je
continue de contribuer. Donc, on a
décidé de vous faire venir pour parler
géopolitique, conflit israélopalestinien
et tout un tas de sujets inhérents euh
et connectés à ce sujet. On va parler
avant 7 octobre, 7 octobre après 7
octobre. Euh, première question, vous
choisissez qui est-ce qui va y répondre
et qui va rebondir ensuite. Comment on
en est arrivé à avoir un 7 octobre avec
une attaque massive coordonnée
en Israël ? Pourquoi ? Comment c'est
arrivé ? Il y a il y a deux éléments. Il
y a le caractère surprenant de l'attaque
euh qui a été extrêmement bien organisée
avec
réellement pensé et avec un effondrement
de la défense israélienne auquelle
personne ne s'attendait. Mais en même
temps, il faut dire que il y avait que
les dirigeants occidentaux pour penser
que la situation était calme. Vous
savez,
un mois avant l'attaque du 7 octobre, le
secrétaire américain, le le M le
président du Conseil national de
sécurité américaine qui est le principal
conseiller de Biden, a écrit un texte
pour dire jamais depuis 20 ans le proch
stable. C'est-à-dire, il y avait une
totale
euh
méconnaissance de l'importance de la
question palestinienne pour les
Palestiniens eux-mêmes et pour toute la
région. Et ça, c'est quelque chose qui
m'a toujours frappé moi justement du
fait que je viens que je suis né dans le
monde arabe. La question palestinienne a
toujours été très importante et quand
j'arrive en France, je me rends compte
queelle est vue de manière très
différente, ce qui est normal en partie.
C'est elle est vue à travers le prisme
de la choa de de la réussite d'Israël et
cetera. Mais ça a amené toujours à
sous-estimer le euh la revendication
palestinienne et cette la force de cette
revendication palestinienne. Et ce que
le 7 octobre a exprimé, c'est que tant
qu'il n'y aura pas solution de cette
question palestinienne, on ira vers des
crises. Alors, personne n'avait prévu le
7 octobre, mais on a
les Égyptiens ont pas fait remonter de
l'information.
Je crois pas que ce soit enfin disons
vous savez le la question de des
informations que les dirigeants
politiques reçoivent est toujours très
compliqué.
dans la guerre d'octobre 1973 quand les
Égyptiens ont attaqué Israël, c'était
donc 6 6 ans après la guerre de de juin
67 où l'Égypte avait vu le Sinaï occupé,
Israël avait occupé la Sodani et Gaza.
Les services politi les dirigeants
politiques israéliens avaient toutes les
informations sur l'attaque mais il
pouvaient pas y croire parce que ça
n'entrait pas dans leur cadre
conceptuel. leur cadre conceptuel, c'est
on a donné une raclé aux Arabes et ils
vont ils sont pas capables de faire des
choses comme ça. Et je dirais ce qui
s'est passé le 7 octobre pour moi c'est
pas le fait enfin c'est c'est le fait
que ils n'ont pas pris au sérieux la
menace palestinienne parce que ils ont
enfin il y a quelque part un profond
mépris pour les Palestiniens et les
Arabes en général et que donc l'idée qui
pouvait s'organiser qui pouvait faire
quelque chose et cetera et même l'idée
qui pouvait résister il c'est d'ailleurs
assez surprenant parce que ça fait 20 ou
30 ans qu'il y a des des euh des
déclarations des dirigeants israéliens
disant "Nous avons gagné
mais il faut que les Palestiniens
acceptent qu'ils ont perdu." Et en fait
les le problème c'est qu'ils
n'accepteront jamais parce que un peuple
qui qui vit s occupation n'accepte
jamais cette situation parce que on peut
discuter des des occupations. Il y a
jamais de bonne occupation. elle est
toujours euh elle est toujours
problématique. Et bon, moi j'aime citer
le général de Gaulle qui est en juin 60
en novembre 67 donc quelques quelques
mois après l'occupation
dit dans une conférence de presse
Issraël organise l'occupation qui ne
peut pas aller sans répression qui
provoque la résistance qu'Israël appelle
le terrorisme. Il avait résumé de
manière prémonitoire les 50 années
suivantes.
RI :
Oui, je me reconnais tout à fait dans ce
que vient de dire Alain et je pense que
ce qui est important, c'est
la manière dont vous avez posé la
question euh est très juste, c'est de
voir que le 7 octobre n'est pas le début
de toute une histoire. Le 7 octobre, les
attentats, les atrocités commises par le
Ramas s'inscrivent dans une longue
histoire.
qu'on peut alors là il y a toute une
discussion. Moi, je dirais que c'est
d'une certaine manière la guerre de 100
ans d'aujourd'hui. Le le conflit
israélo-palestinien, on peut dire qu'il
commence vraiment dans les années 20
avec la création de la militionniste, la
la Gana et qu'il est que cette histoire
est rythmée.
Je peux vous couper la guerre de 100 ans
dans quel sens ? Le côté religieux ou
côté commercial ? Non, non, une guerre.
une guerre, c'est-à-dire l'arrivée de
de contingents de personnes qui ont
l'ambition pour une partie d'entre eux,
pas forcément pour tous, de créer un
état lequel le
ce projet de l'État, lui, il remonte à
plus loin, il remonte au 19e siècle et
on pourra sans doute y revenir se
rappelant que au départ le sionisme,
enfin l'idée que les juifs doivent
construire leur foyer, doivent se
rassembler en Palestine est une idée
chrétienne. C'est une idée que les
évangéliques portent depuis longtemps et
d'ailleurs
euh enfin je diverge un peu mais le
ministre des affaires étrangères
britannique qui en 1917 a promis au
baron de Rothchield la branche anglaise
de la famille Rothchield que les
britanniques favoriseraient l'existence
d'un foyer juif en Palestine.
C'est sourcé. Il y a des déclarations de
tout ça ? Ah oui oui bien sûr. Oui oui
on retrouve d'ailleurs c'est une
déclaration très courte qu'on retrouve
c'est une déclaration de de 15 lignes.
Enfin c'est un courrier très clair qui
est disponible sur internet. Il y a un
nom qui est important, il faut rappeler,
c'est c'est la on les arabes appellent
ça la promesse Balfour ou la déclaration
de Balfour du don du ministre
britannique qui fait cette qui fait
cette promesse et et juste pour rajouter
sur la guerre de Santement, on peut dire
c'est ce le jour-là 2 novembre 17 où il
signe cette déclaration que commence le
conflit et donc dans ce sens-là on est
100 ans et même maintenant on a dépassé
les 100 ans. Rie, si tu m'autorises, si
on peut se tutoyer,
bien sûr.
Euh euh j'ai j'ai discuté avec des
copains sionistes et des copains
musulmans et des copains pro et anti en
préparant cette interview.
Du côté israélien protionniste, il me
parle de l'histoire euh de 125 après
Jésus-Christ
qu'on a appelé la Palestine parce que ça
veut dire traître ou envahisseur
et que machin. Vous avez des entendu
parler de ça ? l'étymologie de
Palestine. Non, je ne sais pas de quoi
philistin. C'est donc c'est une une Non
mais le problème de la il y a deux
problèmes sur la question de la
Si Rony t'autorise de prendre la parole.
Bon, excuse-moi.
Roni, tu l'autorises ?
Oui, oui, je l'autorise. Bien sûr. Il y
a il y a il y a deux problèmes. Il y a
la question des juifs à travers le
monde. Est-ce qu'il forment un peuple ?
Est-ce que ce peuple a le droit de créer
un état ? On peut discuter de cette
question. Moi
selon la loi juive, je suis juif puisque
j'ai dit ma mère est juive, j'ai je n'ai
pas besoin d'état et je ne veux pas un
état. Et il y a beaucoup de de juifs qui
pensent la même chose. Mais c'est un
débat. Le problème c'est pas ça. C'est
le problème c'est où on crée cet état.
C'est ça la la vraie question.
un moment le mouvement sioniste avait
pensé il le créer en Argentine créer
l'État en Argentine ou au Congo.
Jérusalem c'est quand même plus la
classe.
Oui. Oui. C'est plus la classe. C'est
plus Mais il y a eu un débat dans le
mouvement sioniste parce qu'il y a des
gens qui pensaient que ça serait pas
possible et ça n'aurait pas été possible
s'ils avaient pas eu l'appui britannique
dont Reny a a parlé. Et donc le problème
c'est pas tellement qu'il crée un état,
même si bon je pense que comment dire ce
que le judaïsme a apporté au monde et il
a apporté énormément à la culture
mondiale, c'est lié aussi au fait il y
avait pas d'état. C'est c'était pas un
nationalisme étroit avec une armée, une
idéologie nationaliste. Il y avait un
aspect internationaliste qui était
important. Mais laissons c'est cette
question. La question c'est est-ce
qu'ils ont droit de créer cet état là où
il y a déjà une autre population ?
Voilà, c'était ça le le à mon avis le
problème
et ils l'ont créé au terme d'une série
de mesures où on crée une université, on
crée une milice, on crée un syndicat, on
crée on crée une sorte de société dans
la la société. Et dans les termes
d'aujourd'hui, euh tu m'avais dit que il
s'agit pas de faire de la polémique,
mais je pense que c'est pas vraiment de
la de la polémique. C'est au sens
strict, un peu comme des conquêtes
coloniales dans d'autres endroits. C'est
un grand remplacement qui est à l'œuvre
depuis les années 20 30 et qui se
manifeste de manière lourde et violente
par la déclaration d'indépendance en 47
et par la guerre qui s'en suit.
guerre qui elle-même prolonge un état de
violence depuis les années 20 30 avec
des le grand pogrome d'Hébron en 1929
quand des juifs ont été massacrés par
des nationalistes palestiniens ou des
nationalistes arabes pour ne pas faire
d'accronisme de de l'époque et dans
laquelle il faut le il faut absolument
le souligner parce que ça ouvre à la
complexité de ce conflit. Certes, il y a
eu combien combien de morts ? Il y a eu
90 morts, je crois dans lors de ce
pogrome, mais plusieurs centaines de
juifs d'Hébron sauvés par les
Palestiniens d'ébrons, par les Arabes
desbons qui les ont protégé, qui ne
voyent aucune raison pour les tuer. Mais
disons que ça manifeste déjà une
violence réactionnelle par rapport à
quelque chose qui est vraiment de
l'ordre du projet étatique du de créer
une entité qui vient se plaquer sur une
société déjà existante et dont
évidemment le propos est d'effacer la
société préexistante pour lui substituer
celle-ci. Donc c'est évidemment dans ce
cadre d'emblé violent que se situent euh
les événements dont nous parlons euh
aujourd'hui. En 1936, une grande une
grande un soulèvement arabe se euh
produit donc euh dans la Palestine
mandataire, celle qui était sous
contrôle britannique, écrasée très
violemment par les troupes britanniques.
He je rappelle que dans les guerres
coloniales, les trous britanniques ne
faisaient pas de quartier. D'ailleurs,
les troupes françaises non plus. En
général, dans les guerres coloniales, on
ne fait pas de quartier. Ce qui nous
éclaire aussi une partie de la réalité
d'aujourd'hui qui est de l'ordre
également, me semble-t-il, d'une guerre
coloniale. Et cette révolte arabe a été
écrasée avec l'aide de la milice
sioniste, donc la la Gana à l'époque,
laquelle s'est ensuite retournée contre
la domination britannique. Si bien que
d'ailleurs, je le cite de d'emblé, le le
sionisme a ceci de particulier qu'il se
présente à la fois et de façon
simultanée et indissociable comme un
mouvement d'émancipation nationale.
Alors émancipation, on vient s'émanciper
sur une terre que oncule pas. Le le
sionisme au 19e siècle, il est pas en
Palestine, il est en Europe. Les juifs
de Palestine ne sont pas sionistes. Ce
sont les juifs européens qui arrivent en
Palestine et qui veulent créer euh
Il y a une blague d'ailleurs pour ça.
Non, vous connaissez pas la blague ? Je
suis pas sûr. Non,
je vous donnerai la blague plus tard.
D'accord. Donc, un mouvement
d'émancipation nationale et un mouvement
colonial. Ça à ma connaissance
singularité qui caractérise le mouvement
sioniste. bien qu'aujourd'hui des gens
comme Abid Meyer ou bon je cite Habid
Meyer parce que c'est le plus brillant
le plus bruyant pas le plus brillant le
plus bruyant et le plus énervé mais qui
veut dire et je pense en le pensant
défend il défend son point de vue
en le il défend sincèrement son point de
vue en disant qu'il ne saurait y avoir
de colons juifs en Palestine parce qu'en
fait nous avons émancipé cette terre,
nous avons chassé les squatters euh et
nous nous sommes réinstallés Donc le le
sionisme est la seule entreprise disons
d'ordre colonial dans laquelle les
colons se se considèrent comme les
véritables indigènes et tiennent les
autochtones pour de pur squatter qu'il
faut c'est parfois fait dans des
conditions qu'on peut regretter mais
qu'il faut expulser parce qu'on vient
récupérer notre maison ancestrale
abandonnée il y a 2000 ans ce qui est
d'ailleurs enfin une fabrication expost
naturellement mais enfin
On vient récupérer.
C'est pas ce que disent les autres hein.
Non non mais c'est ce que dit
l'histoire. C'est ce que dit la disons
la la science historique. C'est pas là
c'est pas une question d'opinion, c'est
une question factuelle. Il y a il y a
pas eu d'exode des Juifs de Palestine
après la désurrection du duè homme. Il y
a une un certain exode des élites
selon pharaon et l'époque de pharaon
parce qu'on est remonté avec mes amis
jusqu'à pharaon et même avant pharaon.
Oui mais pareil il y avait pas
d'esclavage en Égypte. Enfin
et même l'affaire de Pharaon, elle est
pas elle est pas prouvée. Enfin, je veux
dire, c'est le le départ d'Égypte.
Non. Et même, il y a des des des
archéologues israéliens dans mon nom
Mchap, deux archéologues israéliens qui
se sont employés à euh étudier les sites
qui sont évoqués dans la Bible pour
voir quelle était leur correspondance
avec la réalité historique. Et grosso
modo, d'ailleurs pas grosso modo, ils
n'en ont trouvé aucun. La Bible est un
récit mythologique qui sert à structurer
le réel, qui sert à plein de choses à la
et à faire peur aux gens
éventuellement mais certainement pas
doit ce doit certainement pas être
utilisé comme un livre d'histoire ou
comme un cadastre à force parce que
c'est ça aussi le le le propos sioniste
d'en faire un un cadastre.
Donc
mouvement anti britannique finalement
qui permet de se poser comme un
mouvement
anticolonial. Et puis ensuite, du fait
de la catastrophe juive de l'Europe donc
pendant la deuxème guerre mondiale, la
la Choa, l'Europe d'une certaine manière
paye une dette envers les juifs, les
juifs européens sur le dos des
Palestiniens. Enfin, en gros, avec le
portefeuille des Palestiniens. Oui. En
plus, c'est important de souligner que
le mouvement sioniste a été très
longtemps très minoritaire parmi les
juifs. C'est-à-dire au moment où il se
crée, c'està-dire la fin du 19e siècle,
début du 20e, enfin au moment où il se
développe. Alors, il se développe parce
qu'il y a des grands pôomes en Russie
tiste à partir de 1881 82. Il y a
vraiment des des attaques terribles et
ça qui amènent une immigration. Il y a
entre 1880 et 1925 environ. Je peux te
couper euh
juste avant c'est à chaque fois les les
attaques contre les juifs, c'est
toujours le le même type d'attaque,
c'estàd c'est les gens plat du front qui
cherchent des coupable par tous les
moyens.
Oui, il y a il y a c'est vraiment il y a
un antisémitisme à l'époque, il est en
en Russie, il est il est très religieux.
Il est aussi il s'attaque à des gens qui
sont censés manipuler l'argent, qui sont
censés être riches alors que la grande
majorité est très est très très pauvre.
Mais c'est aussi le moment où se
développe l'antisémitisme racial qui est
nouveau. C'est-à-dire l'antisémitisme
chrétien va
s'ajouter quelque chose qui est c'est la
théorie des races d'ailleurs qui ne
touche pas que les juifs. C'est les on
classifie les noirs, les jaunes, les
blancs et en et en France ça ça joue un
rôle très important. C'està-dire que
l'attaque contre les juifs, elle a un
aspect catholique disons anti antiuif,
mais elle a surtout un un aspir racial.
c'est dire ils sont racialement
différents de nous, on mesure les crânes
et cetera et cetera. Mais je reviens
là-dessus parce important le fait que la
majorité donc de dans cette période de
de Pogrome, il y a 2 millions et demi de
juifs qui quittent l'Europe de l'Est.
Ils vont où ? Ils vont aux États-Unis.
la terre promise, la vraie terre
promise. Et ce qu'on oublie aujourd'hui
de dire, c'est que si à partir de 1925,
il y a eu beaucoup de gens, en plus de
gens qui ont été en Palestine, c'est
parce que les États-Unis ont fermé la
frontière. On oublie de dire ça,
c'estàdire que de 1925 à aux années 60,
le nombre de de d'immigrés était
extrêmement limité et c'est et ça visait
essentiellement les migrations juives
qui étaient considérer comme on
considère aujourd'hui les migrations
musulmanes en Europe. Donc ça ça a joué
un rôle important. Donc ils ont voté
avec leurs pieds. La majorité des juifs,
ils voulaient pas un état juif, ils
voulaient pas aller faire fleurir le
déguève. il voulit trouver un un endroit
l'endroit sûr. Et puis il y a tous les
autres, c'est-à-dire les juifs qui se
sont engagés dans le mouvement
révolutionnaire, qui soi socialiste ou
ou communiste. Il y a ceux qui se
considéraient comme des citoyens
français qui v qui avaient même qui ne
voulaient pas un autre état et qui
avaient même peur que ça crée une un
problème de double loyauté. Euh
c'est-à-dire
qu'on considère que à partir du moment
où il y a un état juif, il on on mettra
en doute la loyauté à l'état à l'égard
de la France et du Royaume-Uni. Il a
fallu donc vraiment le génocide des
juifs, la fermeture encore une fois de
de des frontières européennes et euh
américaine à l'immigration juive pour
que l'immigration juive en Palestine
devienne réellement importante avec
évidemment je veux dire l'avèement de
Hitler au pouvoir a joué un rôle tout à
fait important à partir de 1933. Voilà.
Donc c'est pour dire qu'il y avait une
très grande diversité des opinions sur
les juifs. Et selon un livre qui vient
de sortir qui s'appelle l'antisionisme,
une histoire juive, les premiers, les
plus virulents des antisionistes étaient
des juifs parce que c'était eux qui
étaient considérés les les goils ou les
non juifs. Qu'est-ce qu'ils avaient à
faire de sionisme ? C'est un problème de
juifs et effectivement dans dans parmi
les intellectuels juifs, parmi les
forces politiques et cetera, il y a des
gens qui disaient "On ne veut pas du
tout ça."
Oui, mais ça je pense que c'est un point
important dans le contexte actuel que
vient d'évoquer Alain Lisdé que donc
l'antisionisme ça n'est pas du tout ça
ne procède pas du tout d'une pensée
hostile aux juifs. procède d'une pensée
politique, d'une position politique et
l'antitionnisme était d'abord une
affaire juive parce que en effet tout le
reste des gens s'en s'en moquaient, ça
n'était pas leur leur histoire. Et dans
les dans les milieux juifs européens,
ces activistes là qui rêvaient d'un d'un
foyer juif voire d'un d'un état
apparaissaient comme des urluberlus ou
des gens finalement assez peu enfin des
utopistes au mieux. ou des emmerdeurs
euh éventuellement du fait que en effet
des des conflits de de loyauté, des
soupçons de double allégance pouvaient
émerger de cette idée de créer un état
alors qu'on est déjà citoyen d'un état.
Et d'ailleurs, dès la, je parlais de la
déclaration Balfour tout à l'heure, dès
la déclaration Balfour, on voit cette
idée se surgir puisque Balfour qui était
un évangélique qui ne cachait qu'à
peine, comme on le faisait à l'époque,
ses idées, ses préjugés disons
anti-juifs, antisémitees, l'argent,
l'influence, le pouvoir de l'ombre et
cetera. Enfin, il était tout à fait euh
euh là là-dedans, mais en tant
qu'évangélique, il estimait il enfin ça
c'est une croyance assez largement
partagée parmi les évangélistes pour qui
la Bible et le livre de référence. Et
certains passages de la Bible laissent
entendre que non seulement Dieu a promis
aux juifs cette terre, mais que le
rassemblement des juifs sur cette terre
est le prélude au second avènement du
Messie. D'où l'importance de du sionisme
en tant que perspective messianique
soutenue par les évangéliques.
Puisqu'on a un petit peu de temps, il
faut aussi préciser ce qui est censé se
produire une fois que le Messie revient.
Elvis Elvis va revenir même pas. Non
mince,
ça je ne le garantirai pas. Ce serait
sans doute préférara.
peut-être bien mais en tout cas euh
lorsque le Messie reviendra, c'est le
jour donc c'est le jugement dernier et
ce jour-là ceux qui ne reconnaîtront pas
le caractère divin du Christ et ne
rejoindront pas donc la vraie foi sont
condamnés à disparaître.
Vous êtes croyant tous les deux ?
Non non pas du tout. Non
pas du tout. J'ai jamais été effleuré
même je dois dire par vous
avez pas d'amis imaginaire.
Vous attendez Paris Kazar. Non non non
non. Désolé
ça m'étonne de toi quand même. Tu as
l'air quand même d'être grand fan de
Rikazar. Non
mais je voudrais je voudrais je voudrais
il a que moi qui est fan de Rikazar.
Oui je pense. Oui oui moi non plus.
Et donc Balfour
inspiré par cette croyance et par l'idée
que les juifs
influençaiit à la fois Washington et
Moscou hein euh donc soucieux de garder
les alliances russes et américaines dans
le contexte de la Première Guerre
mondiale a fait aussi cette ce cadeau
aux juifs. cadeau, il y a pas un cadeau
plus empoisonné que celui-ci, mais enfin
a fait ce cadeau aux juifs dans l'idée
de de s'attirer leur bonne grâce. Dans
le même gouvernement, il y avait un
ministre, je ne sais plus quel était sa
son domaine, Lord Montegu, qui était
juif et qui lui a protesté contre cette
donc ce qui confirme ce que disait Alain
au nom précisément du soupçon de double
allégance, de conflit de loyauté qui
pouvait émerger. lui était citoyen de la
couronne britannique et n'avait aucune
intention d'être citoyen d'un autre
pays. Donc déjà vraiment au moment de la
déclaration Balcour se cristallise des
enjeux en jeu colonial impérial parce
que quand même Balfour il donne à un
peuple qui n'y réside pas une terre
qu'il ne possède pas. C'est ça la
déclaration de Balfour. C'est pour des
juifs européens qui sont pas en
Palestine du tout pour l'essentiel pour
des juifs européens. une terre sur
laquelle euh les Britanniques n'ont sont
censés euh devoir exercer euh un mandat,
mais c'est un mandat colonial,
c'est-à-dire un mandat de rapt euh euh
si l'on veut euh rien de rien de plus.
Voilà. Donc c'est euh ça je pense que
c'est vraiment très important de l'avir
à l'esprit à un moment où antisioniste
est considéré par les plus hautes
autorités étatiers qui font là
simplement euh la preuve de leur
ignorance totale de cette histoire. Ils
peuvent pas tout connaître bien entendu.
Ma fois il pourrait se renseigner, ce
serait quand même
ils arrivent même pas à faire un budget.
Alors bon
mais à une époque où président après
président parce que Macron n'est pas le
premier avant lui, il y a eu Holand et
Sarkozy qui ont été exactement sur la
même sur la même ligne qui dresse par
de l'équipe des budgets là. Non non non
pas du tout pas du tout. Ça c'est pas du
tout mon domaine de compétence. Moi, je
parle d'Israël et du sionisme.
Et donc, l'antisionisme est l'équivalent
moderne de l'antisémitisme. Chacun l'a
dit à sa manière, mais enfin
l'équivalence entre les deux est
absolument signé. Or, cet homme aussi
ignoré et avec Balfour, on le voit que
les antisémites sont protionnistes dans
une bonne partie de leur il y a il y a
que les antisémites disons rabiques, les
fous furieux, les nazis qui sont une
toute petite partie des antisémites.
C'est dire quoi ? J'ai pas compris ta
phrase. Les antisémites, je continue ta
phrase.
Antisémite rabiisi par une horage
antisémite.
Le euh cela effectivement déteste
tellement les juifs que tout ce qui est
accollé au non juifs leur fait
absolument horreur et ils le veulent le
détruire. Donc ça il y a des
antisionistes qui sont qui le qui le
sont par haine des juifs. Ça ça existe.
Il faut pas les ignorer. Il faut les
combattre non pas pour leur
antisionnisme mais pour leur
antisémitisme. Ça c'est tout à fait
clair. dans leur grande majorité et on
le voit avec les extrêmes droites
européennes notamment l'extrême droite
française
qui a pour qui l'antisémitisme était
même un fond idéologique indéfiniment
renouvelable dans lequel on puisait
constamment
par allusion ou par rarement directement
depuis disons euh les années 50 mais
tout de même façon répétée et bien euh
ceux-là sont toutes à la défense
d'Israël Je vous rappelle que Le Pen
dans les années 50 quand
Le Pen père Oui, Jean-Marie Le Pen, oui,
la fille était je crois était pas encore
née s'engage enfin a voulu s'engager
lors de l'expédition de Suèse en en 56
et se déclarait proisraélien,
proioniste, tout en étant négationiste,
en dénonçant le complot juif et et les
bases œuvres des juifs. Donc il y a une
adéquation entre antisémitisme et
sionisme puisque les uns et les autres
veulent regrouper les juifs dans une
espèce de ghetto là-bas au Proche-Orient
et débarrasser l'Europe de ces juifs.
Donc il y a il y a il y a une sorte de
projet commun. Ce sont des ennemis
complémentaires si l'on veut.
Pas que ce sont des amis mais des
ennemis complémentaires. Est-ce que vous
avez essayé de vous mettre à la place
des sionistes et des gens qui étaient en
faveur de la création d'un état après
s'être fait persécuter d'abord dans les
camps ? J'envens de siè euh est-ce que
vous avez essayé de comprendre en fait
pourquoi ils essayaient de faire un
repli stratégique entre eux pour assurer
leur propre défense ? Alain
non mais attends, il y a deux choses.
C'estàd euh la j'ai expliqué
l'immigration juive en Palestine, il
faut rappeler, je répète qu'elle est d
au fait que l'Europe et les États-Unis
ferment la frontière. Donc c'est pas un
choix euh politique. Euh une fois qu'ils
sont installés là-bas, c'est-à-dire
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale, euh il
représente un/3 de la population et on
est dans une impasse qui qui demande une
solution. Le problème c'est que la
solution militaire qui va être
finalement adoptée, elle est elle est
impasse elle est une impasse jusqu'à
aujourd'hui parce que un des aspects
très particulier de cette situation de
colonisation si vous voulez dans
l'histoire des colonisations de
peuplement, c'est-à-dire des
colonisations où on envoie des colons
européens euh sur différents continents.
Il y a deux cas de figure. Le premier
c'est que les colons exterminent les
indigènes. c'est l'Amérique du Nord,
c'est l'Australie, la Nouvelle-Zéléande
extermine pas forcément 100 % mais bon,
il y a pas de retour en en arrière. Le
deuxième cas, c'est le cas où les colons
sont très minoritaires et ils vont se
faire dans la période de de
décolonisation, ils vont se faire
expulser. Euh c'est le cas de l'Algérie,
c'est le cas de la euh c'est le cas de
de l'Afrique portugaise. Bon le
l'Afrique australe c'est un peu
différent mais il y a quand même euh du
fait de du fait qu'il y a 10 noirs pour
un blanc euh il va y avoir la fin de la
partaille. Et le seul exemple où on a
sur le territoire historique de la
Palestine, vous avez aujourd'hui 7
millions et demi d'Arabes Palestiniens,
7 millions et demi de Palestiniens, 7
millions et demi de juifs plus ou moins
à 500000 près. Et c'est une impasse,
c'est-à-dire il n'y a pas de solution
sans prendre en compte cette réalité.
Moi, je suis convaincu qu'il faut la
prendre en compte même si elle est le
résultat d'une injustice. Je veux dire
l'injustice de toute façon, bon mais
comment on fait ? La question c'est
est-ce qu'il y a une solution militaire
à ça ? C'estàdire à part l'extermination
d'un des deux peuples, ce qui me semble
pas possible encore que avec ce que se
passe à Gaza, on se demande vraiment si
c'est totalement impossible. Je veux
dire, il faut une entente politique et
l'entente politique, elle ne peut avoir
que un principe, c'est l'égalité des
gens qui vivent là-bas. Et c'est ça qui
qui est pour le sionisme infranchissable
parce que ils viennent Israël a adopté
l'état
une nouvelle loi sur Israël, l'état
nation du peuple juif qui en fait prive
ses propres citoyens puisqu'il y a 2
millions de Palestiniens qui ont la
nationalité israélienne.
C'était en 2018 he préciser. Donc on est
dans une contradiction. On peut pas être
un état démocratique avec une partie des
citoyens qui ne qui ne représentent pas
enfin qui
ils ont le droit de vote. Oui. Non non
mais il ils sont soumis si vous voulez
ils sont discriminés de différentes
manières. C'est on peut rentrer dans le
détail mais si vous voulez c'est le fait
de pas faire de service militaire ils ne
le font pas. C'est ça peut paraître
positif mais il y a toute une série de
droits qu'on a en Israël si on fait le
service militaire et qu'on a pas si on
ne fait pas le service militaire. Il y a
aussi des postes qui peuvent pas
occuper, ils sont sous un contrôle
permanent et surtout après le 7 octobre,
ils sont avec une vraie répression. Donc
ils ont ça veut pas dire qu'ils n'ont
pas un certain nombre de droits et c'est
pas forcément la même situation que les
noirs euh que les noirs en Afrique du
Sud, mais c'est une situation que toutes
les organisations internationales
appellent l'appartide.
Je voudrais faire une remarque parce que
à propos de ce que tu disais les
organisations appellent ça d'appartide
Amnesty Internationale, Human Rights
Watch, Betelem qui est une la grande
organisation de défense des droits de de
l'homme. C'est une remarque par rapport
à au télé aux spectateurs de ça. C'est
une guerre de 100 ans. C'est très long,
c'est très difficile à comprendre. C'est
une guerre qui a commencé, enfin c'est
un affrontement qui a commencé avant la
la Première Guerre mondiale, qui a
continué dans l'entre de guerre, qui
s'est poursuivi pendant la guerre froide
avec des tas de protagonistes différents
et cetera. Et une des difficultés
euh c'est de prendre en compte cette
réalité, la complexité de cette réalité,
mais sans renvoyer dos à dos les les
deux parties. C'est-à-dire que une des
choses qui me frappe, bon dans la
couverture médiatique, c'est que
globalement elle prend position en
faveur d'Israël mais en gommant toute
une série de réalités qu'il faut
connaître et j'ai et je dire j'appelle
pas les spectateurs à croire forcément
ce que je dis mais ce que je dis c'est
que j'aimerais qu'on ait des fois un
débat où il y ait un vrai pluralisme et
pas forcément polémique c'està-dire il y
a des choses qu'on peut
il y a des événements historiques qu'on
qu'on peut expliquer. expliquer le fait
par exemple qu'en 489, il y a eu 2/3 de
la population palestinienne qui a été
expulsé B military dans ce qu'on
appelait pas encore mais qui était un
nettoyage ethnique. Tout ça pèse et on
peut pas faire comme si tout ça
n'existait pas. Et je veux dire cette
complexité ça demande ça demanderait je
dirais un travail des médias qui qui
malheureusement
n'est pas n'est pas fait.
Ren tu vas ajouter quelque chose ? Je te
renvoie une question. Non, je voulais
juste ajouter un petit complément à ce
que disait Alain sur le fait que ce sont
les fermetures de frontières qui ont
amené les Juifs d'Europe à aller
massivement en Palestine. Je ne conteste
pas du tout le fait mais je pense qu'il
faut rajouter qu'il y avait je je dis ça
parce que c'est mon histoire personnelle
également et c'est mon histoire
personnelle au sens c'est l'histoire de
ma famille des gens qui ont émigré en
Palestine ou en Israël par conviction
sioniste dans le but de construire
un un état et disons mon père par
exemple qui était vraiment un militant
d'avant-guerre dès les années 30 même
enfin il était tout jeune, il était
adolescent, il allait dans les au aux
éclaireurs israélites de France et tout
et je une fois il me racontait que en
rentrant d'un weekend où ils avaient
joué disons au scoot, au pionniers, que
sais-je, euh il raconte à sa mère ce que
ils ont entendu, ce qu'ils ont fait, ce
dont ils ont discuté pendant le weekend
parce qu'il y a évidemment toute une
formation idéologique et sa mère s'est
fâché, la l'a engueulé parce que il a
commencé à proférer des insanités
antisémite
et euh le
il il m'a racconsé parce qu'il ça
l'avait quand même beaucoup frappé, ça
n'a pas fait changer d'avis. Mais si je
cite cette anecdote, c'est parce qu'elle
vient à la rencontre de ce que de ce
qu'ét
juifs par les sionistes.
C'est pas très clair si tu pense. Enfin,
je je pense que tu devrais préciser ça.
C'est tout à fait juste mais moi je sais
mais je pense que euh il y a
si tu veux l'aider, vas-y.
Non non non mais je pense qu'il peut le
faire. Ouioui.
Ce que euh ce que je veux dire par là,
c'est que euh sa mère qui venait d'une
grande ville industrielle de Pologne, la
ville de Lodge Woodch en prononciation
euh polonaise, enfin c'est ses deux
parents venaient de là. C'était des
gens, c'était des des urbains de de
conditions très modestes, mais enfin
c'était disons des ouvriers euh qui
étaient des ouvriers de modernisés quoi,
qui vivaient dans la société qui avaient
connu la société moderne. Et les
sionistes décrivaient les juifs d'Europe
comme étant des petits êtres chétifs,
malingres, toujours plongés dans leur
dans leur bouquin où il répétait la la
même chose, un peu voleur, crasseux,
pouilleux et il y avait toute une une
imagerie juive des véhiculé par les
sionistes qui opposaient à cette à cet
être chétif. Le juif sportif, musculeux,
conquérant, pionnier, dont les premiers
temps d'Israël ont été vraiment une
manifestation éclatante. On viait des
gars vraiment au gros
façon soviétique quoi.
Voilà. Exactement. C'était une représ
C'est ça. C'était l'imagerie du du
temps. Exaltation de la jeunesse, de la
vigueur, de la force, de l'énergie. euh
des belles femmes à la poitrine
plantureuse qui cueillaient des oranges
dans les vergers euh euh dans dans le
dans le parfum des des des orangerai et
cetera. Donc tout ça s'était euh
construit par opposition à une image euh
absolument péjorative euh méprisante euh
des euh des juifs
et euh euh voilà. Donc ce qui ce dont il
s'agissait de s'affranchir, c'était
précisément de cette imagerie du juif
courbé. Et ce qu'il s'agissait de
construire, c'était le juif droit, celui
qui était
costaud et et le ce qui tenait lieu de
non pas de slogan mais un peu de cadre
imaginaire, c'était le fait notamment
après la guerre, j'ai souvent entendu
cette phrase dans ma famille et je l'ai
entendu dans d'autres cercles. On aime
les juifs quand ils sont en pyjama
rayés, quand ils sont victimes, parce
qu'on les plaint, parce qu'on est on a
de la compassion pour eux. Et ben
maintenant, il va falloir nous aimer en
uniforme avec un flingue et en tant que
cogneur parce que çaen est terminé de
cette période où on se laissait battre.
Enfin, c'est dire le le mépris que les
sionistes ont pour l'histoire juive
européenne qu'il ramène à une histoire
de l'humiliation de du de la de la
soumission à une autorité arbitraire et
hostile sans aucune révolte, sans aucune
manifestation
humaine, quoi.
Voilà, tu veux
donc c'est ça qui de s'affranchir. Je
répondais à ta question concernant ce
qui motivait les gens. Pour d'autres, il
y avait un un certain sionisme
religieux, mais ça c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué. Peut-être qu'il faut faudra
aussi en parler parce qu'il est beaucoup
plus ambigu. Il y a eu euh une manière
de dont le sionisme a reconstruit
l'histoire des juifs à travers le monde.
Et moi, je pense puis j'ai grandi là et
puis il y avait une communauté juive en
Égypte et avait dans le le monde arabe
et si vous voulez il y a l'idée que les
juifs dans le monde arabe étaient
persécutés, que
euh ils n'ont pas pu vivre et que c'est
grâce à Israël qu'ils ont été sauvés.
Alors que en fait jusqu'à la naissance
enfin l'installation du mouvement
sioniste et des années 30 où le conflit
autour de la Palestine a impliqué les
pays arabes, les juifs n'avaient pas de
problème dans le monde arabe. Il y avait
bon je dis pas qu'il y avait aucun
antisémitisme, il y en avait en Europe.
Je veux dire, je vois pas comment il y
en aurait pas eu dans le mond, mais les
gens vivaient très bien. Et
aujourd'hui,
j'ai j'ai rencontré un un type qui est
un américain qui a travaillé sur les
Juifs iraniens. Il raconte comment en
fait les juifs iraniens ont été très
longtemps
ils avaient une position contradictoire
à l'égard du sionisme. D'un côté, ils
étaient contents de voir Israël créer
parce qu'ils avaient l'impression que
les que les juifs du monde se réf
allaient pouvoir se les juifs européens.
Mais eux, ils avaient pas la moindre
intention d'y aller. Et d'ailleurs,
pendant très longtemps jusqu'à la enfin
jusqu'à la révolution iranienne, ils n'y
ont pas été et il y avait une histoire
juive qui était très compliquée avec une
très importante influence du parti Todd
qui était le parti communiste, avec une
participation en lutte sociale et
cetera. Et là aujourd'hui,
que ce soit en Iran ou dans le monde
arabe, l'histoire des juifs du monde
arabe a été complètement réduite à une
histoire d'oppression. Et on a
complètement oublié l'apport de cette de
ces de ces communautés à l'histoire.
C'est en Irak par exemple les où il y
avait une communauté juive très très
organisée aussi très influencée par le
le parti communiste. Je dis ils ont joué
un grand rôle dans la chanson arabe que
quand on dit la chanson iakienne.
beaucoup de beaucoup étaient des des
juifs et et toute cette histoire a été
oubliée au profit d'une espèce de
parce que c'est ce qui fait vivre le le
sionisme, c'est le sionisme vit parce
que il y a l'idée d'un antisémitisme
éternel qui a toujours existé et qui ne
disparaîtra jamais
qui s'intensifie quand même beaucoup en
ce moment.
Non, je pense que ce qui s'incentifie,
c'est que aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas une
manifestation de critique d'Israël qui
n'est pas réduite à l'antisémitisme. Je
ce qui fait parler des manifestations
étudiantes aux États-Unis ou en France,
c'est de dire c'est l'antisémitisme.
Alors que ce qui est caractéristique de
ces manifestations, c'est la
participation des juifs, notamment aux
États-Unis. C'est impressionnant le
nombre de jeunes juifs aujourd'hui qui
se mobilisent autour de Gaza. Alors des
fois ils sont antisonistes, des fois
non. Mais c'est cette et c'est ça qu'on
qu'on on veut réduire à l'antisémitisme.
Le problème c'est que quand l' quand
vous accusez d'antisémitisme, les
Nations- Unies,
Amnestie Internationale, la Cour
internationale de justice et le monde
entier, finalement ça a plus aucun sens
l'antisémitisme, je veux dire c'est
c'estd on a l'idée d'un dans monde
antisém en France si vous voulez quand
vous regardez les sondages, les préjugés
anti-juifs, ils existent évidemment, ils
existent encore plus, il y a des
préjugés anti-arabes et cetera mais en
France, vous pouvez avoir un prés un
premier ministre, un président de la
République et cetera, juif, ça pose pas
de problème et l'État français protège
les juifs et tant mieux. Et il y a pas
de grand parti qui se qui se déclare
antisémite. Donc l'idée qu'on vit une
une espèce de
C'est un délit de toute façon.
Oui, c'est c'est un délit mais pourrait
avoir un délit et avoir des des
manifestations
concrètes et cetera.
On dit qu' on dit je pense qu'il y a une
augmentation des des actes antijuifs. Le
le problème c'est que le ministère de
l'intérieur refuse de dire quels sont ce
type d'acte. C'estàd est-ce que dire
Palestine vaincra c'est un acte est-ce
que c'est un acte antisémite ? Je pense
que la plupart des enfin les juifs
organisés pensent que c'est un acte
antisémite. Moi je pense pas que c'est
un acte antisémite. Ça c'est une
déclaration politique. La destruction de
l'État d'Israël c'est quand même
compliqué. Alors ça c'est une question
intéressante c'està dire
parce que les autres n'étaient pas C'est
ça.
Non non non c'est
attention à
Non le le problème le
il y a il y a de il y a des courants
différents dans la solidarité avec la
Palestine. Il y a ceux qui prôent deux
États al déjà un état si Jordanier et
Gaza.
Il faut ceux qui qui prennent la
destruction de
Oui, il y a il y a il y a ça simplement
on peut dire que cette solution qui qui
est prené par toute la communa fait
l'unanimité y compris des États-Unis en
principe elle se traduit par aucune
avancée pour les Palestiniens. Il y a
aucune pression sur Israël qui est quand
même la partie qui refuse la création de
cet palestinien et qui intensifie la
colonisation. Donc dire juste je dire
pour apparaître comme un interlocuteur
décent, raisonnable, sage,
il faut il faut professer son
attachement à la solution à deux états.
Ensuite, on a payé son ticket d'entrée.
On peut dire n'importe quoi, mais c'està
dire queon a affaire à une guerre de
civilisation, qu'il y a d'un côté les
barbares, de l'autre côté la lumière et
cetera. Mais une mais on a payé son
déco. Je suis pour la solution des
États. D'ailleurs, il faut généralement
ajouter d'ailleurs je l'ai toujours été.
Je n'ai jamais varié sur ce point et
cetera. Pardon de
Mais donc ça c'est et puis il y a une
partie du mouvement antisé qui prône un
état de ses citoyens, un état où juifs,
musulmans, chrétiens athés vivent de
manière égale. Je veux dire
laïque,
pardon laïque, je veux dire c'est
l'exemple sud-africain d'une certaine
manière. C'est comme si on avait dit le
le mouvement euh antiappartaide, il veut
la destruction de l'Afrique du Sud. Non,
il voulait pas la chose de l'Afrique du
Sud. il veut une autre manière de vivre
et c'est ce qu'ils ont obtenu. Alors
c'est pas la même situation, je je veux
dire c'est pas comparable mais les gens
qui prennent le un état démocratique de
la Palestine, on peut pas les qualifier
de de d'antisémite. Ça veut pas dire que
dans le mouvement de solidarité avec les
Palestiniens, il y a aucun antisémite.
Et comme Ren l'a dit aujourd'hui, les
grands mouvements qui à mon avis restent
antisémit qui sont les mouvements
d'extrême droite européen et américain
parce que les évangéliques qui sont
l'aile essentielle du lobby proélien aux
États-Unis, c'est des antisémites.
C'estàdire ce que ils disent "Nous
voulons que le Messie arrive comme ça on
on soit on exterminera les Juifs, soit
ils se convertiront." C'est quand même
pas une et on sait que dans l'entourage
de Rigan de je dis toujours Rigan de de
de non de Trump, il y avait beaucoup de
gens comme ça. Donc c'est ça le vrai
antisémitisme. Après euh je dire
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est grave
c'estàdire
en
identifiant n'importe quoi à
l'antisémitisme on le banalise.
C'estàdire ça a plus aucun sens. C'est
plus les les c'est n'importe quoi
devient de l'antisémitisme et donc on se
on discrédite une lutte qui est
nécessaire parce que il y a des préjugés
qui sont inscrits dans l'histoire et en
France à mon avis il y a un
antisémitisme de droite réelle et je
pense que les partis d'extrême droite
restent antisémites simplement ils
pensent que les musulmans aujourd'hui
c'est plus dangereux que les chrétiens
que les que les juifs et que quand on
aura fini avec les musulmans, on
s'occupera des juifs quoi. Voilà. Là,
dans les parties d'extrême droite, en
tous les cas, en France, il y a pas
d'antisémites euh
dans
dans l'entourage de de Le Pen, oui, il y
a des gens qui qui ont fait des
déclarations antisémites. Il y a des
gens du G du groupe Union de droit qui
simplement ils sont aujourd'hui plus
prudents parce que c'est pas c'est pas
l'ennemi principal, mais euh
il faut toujours des ennemis de toute
façon.
Oui, il faut toujours des ennemis. Mais
bon, la grande changement depuis par
rapport aux AD30, c'est que en fait les
musulmans ont remplacé les Juifs
simplement. C'està dire, on les
considère comme la la menace avec
d'ailleurs c'est moi ça me frappe. Il y
a il y a un livre très intéressant qui a
été publié là-dessus sur le le parallèle
entre les le juifs dans les années 30 et
les musulmans aujourd'hui avec cette
même idée de complot. C'est qu'il y a un
complot juif, un complot musulman pour
mettre àas les les principes de la
République pour s'attaquer à laïcité. On
on alors que quand on fréquente, moi je
le fais, des organisations musulmanes
qui travaillent en France, je peux vous
dire que
je veux dire il y a aucun complot et ils
ont il aucune capacité je il y a c'est
dire il y a pas comment dire il y a pas
une organisation importante, il y a pas
euh il y a pas une présence importante
financière ou politique et cetera et
cetera. Donc on dit ils sont ils sont
partout en fait. C'est pas vrai, mais on
on développe une rhtorique et une
rhtorique anti antiusulmane et on fait
des musulmans une race comme les les
juifs. C'est on sait pas définir les
juifs parce que qu'est-ce que c'est être
juif ? Est-ce que c'est être croyant ou
pas croyant ? Est-ce que sa mère est
juif ou l'arrière grand-père ? Et
aujourd'hui, le fait de vous appeler
Mohamed ou Fatima vous êtes considéré
comme musulman et a priori suspect. Et
si euh chaque fois qu'il va y avoir un
attentat, on va dire "Ah toi, qu'est-ce
que tu en penses ? Parce que toi, en
tant que musulman, tu dois penser
quelque chose de spécial. Ou est-ce que
si tu veux pas boire du vin, est-ce que
c'est euh parce que tu es un intégriste
camouflé ?" Enfin voilà. Donc donc on
est vraiment dans un euh dans un
discours, je dis je suis frappé. C'est
il y a eu en France une grande
manifestation sur contre
l'antisémitisme. Il faut quand même
rappeler que elle a été possible,
c'està-dire
volontairement on n' pas
associé la lutte contre l'antisémitisme
et la lutte contre le racisme. C'est sil
avaient mis les deux présidents de
l'Assemblée nationale et du sd le
Rassemblement national n'auraient pas
participé et en fait on voulait que le
Rassemblement national participe. Et
c'est ça qui est extraordinaire, c'est
sur la lutte contre l'antisémitisme que
le Rassemblement national a été adoubé
par les médias, la classe politique en
France.
On a
l'islamogauchiste a pris la suite du
judéobolchévisme
d'une certaine manière. C'est ces termes
politiques composés destinés à
stigmatiser un groupe, à le vouer aux
gémonies. il se retrouve sous cette
forme là, l'islam gauchisme
d'aujourd'hui.
On arrive au 7 octobre, une opération du
Hamas, une boucherie du Hamas sur des
gamins qui écoutaient de la musique ou
des mecs qui se baladaient pour aller
faire leur courses ou des familles qui
demandaient rien à personne.
Des otages qui sont pris, une réaction
d'Israël,
comment vous qualifiez cette réaction ?
Comment vous voyez cette stratégie ? Où
est-ce que cette stratégie nous emmène ?
Qui veut commencer ? Je suis pas sûr que
euh
une stratégie, c'est ça.
Non non non, je crois que contrairement
à ce qu'on dit, le 7 octobre pour Hamas,
il y a une stratégie, c'est pas de tuer
les gens. Ça c'est vraiment l'idée qui
non mais attendez attendez att
la stratégie elle était
pas qu' un peu he
non non ils ont
alors le bilan c'est 1200 morts dont 500
400 500 militaires et choses bon c'est
c'est beaucoup et c'est des crimes de
guerre he c'est pas ça mais ils ont un
objectif politique. L'objectif c'est de
casser militairement
la la division Gaza qui entoure Gaza qui
est qui met le blocus sur sur Gaza. Ils
ont réussi militairement et ils ont
porté un coup à Israël. Deuxièmement, il
voulit
arrêter la normalisation entre Israël et
les pays arabes, notamment l'Arabie
Saoudite
et ils ont réussi. Et troisièmement, ils
voulaient remettre la question
palestinienne au centre du débat. Ils
ont réussi. Ils l'ont fait avec des
crimes horribles. C'est pas le le
problème. Mais on peut pas le réduire
avec l'idée. Non, c'est bon, d'abord, je
connais pas de guerre où il y a pas de
crime de guerre, mais je dire euh
comment dire, c'est comme disait Ren
tout à l'heure, ça n'a pas commencé le 7
octobre. C'està dire c'est pas que
brusque le je dis est-ce que le 6
octobre on était prêt à une solution ?
N'oublions pas les milliers de morts et
les dizaines de milliers de blessés à
Gaza même qui sont le résultat des
incursions antérieures d'Israël.
Ouais. Donc il y a il y a il y a cette
situation où de blocage total où une
population de 2 millions et demi vit
sous blocus dans des conditions
épouvantables.
Et
c'est quoi les conditions épouvantables
pour ceux qui ne savent pas ?
C'est-à-dire que pratiquement rien ne
peut rentrer, pas pratiquement rien ne
rentre sans autorisation d'Israël. Donc
la pauvreté est très importante, les les
possibilités d'exporter leur leur
production ne n'existe pas. Et puis il y
a des incursions sans arrêt. Les
pêcheurs n'ont pas le droit de pêcher
au-delà de 2 km. qu'enfin il y a toute
une série de de
mesures prises contre les et puis
juste juste j'ajoute que dans les pour
les Israéliens c'était explicite les
premier ministres ou les conseillers de
premier ministres l'ont dit de façon
enfin sans aucun détour. Il s'agit de
les maintenir au bord de l'abîme. Il
s'agit de maintenir les palestiniens au
bord du précipice. On va pas il y aura
pas de famine mais ils auront un peu
faim, ils vont maigrir. Voilà le voilà
le truc. Et ça se traduit par un
contingentement d'à peu près tout, y
compris des mesures absolument mesquines
de d'humiliation du genre il y aura pas
de chocolat qui rentrera à Gaza par
exemple. Pourquoi du chocolat ? Quel est
l'usage terroriste possible du chocolat
? Mais ça c'est une mesure psychologique
destinée à montrer qui est le maître et
qui est le qui est soumis.
Et ça c'est euh c'est la la règle la la
politique israélienne à Gazin. Alors
et puis le fait que vous savez enfin je
veux dire ça fait 20 ans qu'ils sont
sous sous pas tout à fait 20 ans de sous
blocus. Un jeune qui grandit à Gaza, il
n'a aucune perspective.
Moi ça m'étonne pas qu'il aille se dire
"Ma vie ne vaut rien. Je suis prêt à à
faire un attentat suicide et cetera et
cetera. On peut pas.
Je je raconte
une anecdote qui me semble très
importante pour aussi comprendre le le
contexte parce que c'est on a
l'impression que on a d'un côté des
Israéliens pacifiques et de l'autre des
gens qui qui cherchent à se venger. En
1956, Gaza a été sous contrôle égyptien
et
dans un incident de frontière, puisque à
Gaza, il y a beaucoup de réfugiés, il y
a un jeune d'quibut qui est pris enlevé
par des Palestiniens et qui est
massacré, vraiment torturé et tué. Et
Moché Dayan qui est chef d'état-major de
l'armée et un des principaux
responsables militaires israéliens, pas
du tout un esprit pacifique, il est
appelé à faire le l'éloge de ce jeune et
et il s'adresse à ses aux Israéliens
enfin aux gens d'équipous en disant il
faut que vous compreniez ces gens qui
sont de l'autre côté de la frontière,
nous les avons expulsés en 48 49
occupons leur terre et il nous
et ils sont dans des corps et cetera. Il
faut enfin il justifie évidemment pas le
ça justifie rien mais là encore une fois
c'est pas on n'est pas simplement dans
un point de vue moral on est dans un
point de vue oui il y a une rage du côté
palestinien c'estàdire encore une fois
quelqu'un qui a grandi 20 ans dans 5 ans
avec en plus la mémoire parce que une
des forces de la des Palestiniens c'est
qu'il la mémoire se transmet vraiment
c'estàdire que l'idée que
c'est pour un certain nombre des jeunes
qui qui ont attaqué les kibuts C'était
leur terre. C'est bon. Voilà. Donc ça
crée une condition. Encore une fois, il
y a pas de il y a pas de de de solution
facile mais je veux dire on n'est pas
face à c'est comme j'ai j'ai dit tout à
l'heure, il y a 7 millions et demi et 7
millions et demi et qu'il faut une
solution et j'en suis vraiment
convaincu. En même temps, on n'est pas
dans une situation d'égalité. C'est il y
a il y a un peuple qui vit sous
occupation et l'autre qui est occupant.
On peut pas faire comme si c'était deux
deux personnes de bonne volonté qu'il
faut appeler à discuter. Il y a des il y
a un contentieux, il faut aussi qu'on
soit capable de de d'examiner ce
contentieux.
Oui, moi je suis absolument d'accord
sans aucune réserve avec ce que vient de
pro palestinien tous les deux.
Non,
moi j'ai
moi je me définis pas comme pro
palestinien. Moi je
je suis partisan de la justice en
Palestine.
Et moi j'ai dit je suis pour le droit
international.
Mais ce que je voulais juste
rajouter, je trouve que l'anecdote
concernant Moched Dian est très
explicite. me rappelle aussi une autre
un autre moment de l'histoire lorsque
Ben Gourion donc le premier premier
ministre d'Israël, le père fondateur
d'Israël discute avec son ami Naou
Goldman, président du Congrès sioniste
mondial et ils sont c'est dans les
années 50 et Ben Gourion fait preuve
d'un pessimisme terrible dans sa
discussion avec Goldman en disant "En
gros euh moi euh si j'étais un arabe,
jamais je ne signerai la paix. Pourquoi
est-ce qu'il signerait la paix ? Euh la
Bible, nous on pense que la Bible nous a
octroyé ce cette terme. Enfin c'est il y
a que nous qu'il y a que les Juifs pour
penser ça. Il il savait il avait oublié
les les évangéliques en l'occurrence
mais en tout cas certainement pas
d'autres d'autres croyances catholiques.
Il y a eu certes la choa mais ils n'y
sont pour rien. Pourquoi est-ce qu'
Pourquoi est-ce qu'il donc il y a pas de
raison qui ils nous vourront une une
hostilité
éternelle et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous devons vivre par les
armes. C'est la la conclusion qu'il en
tire et Naun Goldban lui objecte que il
est il se demande comment il peut dormir
la nuit avec ça et Ben Gour lui dit
"Mais qui te dit que je dors la nuit ?"
Voilà le le l'anecdote dans son
ensemble. Elle elle recoupe tout à fait
ce qui était le ce que disait Mosché
Dayan et elle montre que d'une certaine
manière les pères fondateurs étaient
plus lucide quant aux enjeux, aux
contradictions aux tensions qu'il que
crée Israël en train de se mettre en
place. Aujourd'hui, on enfin à entendre
certains y compris leurs homologues
français au gouvernement ou les supposés
défenseurs d'Israël ou amis d'Israël.
J'y suis posé amis d'Israël parce que
pour moi les les gens qui soutiennent
Israël dans cette politique que je
considère comme suicidaire, ils œuvrent
à d'une certaine manière à la
destruction de tout ce qui pouvait euh
ramener faire d'Israël un pays décent et
euh et vivable. Donc c'est un peu les
comme le dealer et l'ami de du drogué
quoi. S'il lui file sa daupe et puis
tout le monde semble content, bah là on
entretient Israël dans l'idée que ils
ont raison, que c'est un état
démocratique. Quel état qui pratique la
détention arbitraire, l'apartaille,
l'occupation illégale qui viole le droit
international et le droit des droits de
l'homme constamment par les États-Unis
là, je non
serait qualifié de non, il y a pas de il
y a disons il y a des inégalités
sociales et raciales aux États-Unis
certes, mais il y a pas
Oui. Le droit international, ils ont un
peu rien à Non,
non, le droit international là. Oui.
Oui. De toute façon, peu de gens en ont
en ont à faire. Là, je parle de
l'organisation de la société euh euh
interne. Euh sur les quelques 15
millions qui vivent euh entre le fleuve
Jourdain et euh et la mer, vous avez
quatre ou cinq régimes juridiques
différents, y compris des gens qui ont
tous les droits, y compris celui de de
tuer en toute impunité sous la
protection de l'armée et ceux qui n'en
ont aucun juste le droit de se faire
rouler dessus ou de se faire déposséder
sans qu'il y ait de aucune conséquence.
Donc ce que je voulais dire c'est que
aujourd'hui
les dirigeants israéliens et ceux qui
les soutiennent semblent avoir tout
oublié de ces contradictions, de ces
tensions auxquelles les les les les
fondateurs et puis les les la première
génération politique d'Israël était tout
de même sensible. Et ça nous éclaire
aussi sur cette histoire, disons qui
après tout on est parti de la question
d'où vient ce cet octobre. Et bien ils
viennent là peut-être je veux
j'ajouterai encore quelque chose qui est
une sur une expérience enfin une
expérience euh un moment personnel que
j'ai vu qui m'avait beaucoup touché,
beaucoup ému. J'étais en visite pour
médecin sans frontière en en 6 Jordanie
et puis je discutais avec nos nos
équipes palestiniennes.
J'avais envie de d'aller un peu dans
leur famille, voir leurs copains, enfin
bref, de de discuter, de m'immerger un
peu. Et je euh on en vient à
on on déboule chez une une assez grande
famille assez aisée euh qui était une
famille très militante, très activiste.
Et au détour d'une
d'un d'une phrase comme ça, je leur je
leur précise parce que je voulais pas
que ils apprennent ça autrement que
moi-même j'étais natif de Jérusalem,
d'origine israélienne, juif et que et
quand je leur ai dit ça, loin de se
crisper, de se rédire, ils se sont et
surtout les les les les plus jeunes, ils
se sont comme éclairés. D'un seul coup,
il voyait un juif qui n'était pas vêtu
de ce casque là avec le camouflage, avec
leur mitrailleuse, leur mitraillette
galile et leur leur tenue de combat en
train de balancer des grenades et de de
de forcer les portes à 3h du matin pour
expulser des gens. Ils avaient quelqu'un
qui venait boire le thé avec eux et
discuter et qui en plus s'intéressait à
leur à leur situation. Et bien on peut
faire le parallèle avec les jeunes de
Gazin, ceux qui notamment s'en sont pris
à ces jeunes fétard de la de la rêve qui
qui ont été tués par dizaines ou par
centaines, je ne sais plus. Je
ça a été un massacre. On a eu on a vu
les vidéos, c'est c'était absolument
dramatique. N'oublie pas que pour aucun
de ces jeunes, un Israélien n'a un autre
visage que celui d'un drone, d'un
hélicoptère d'attaque, d'un tank, de
force spéciale, bref d'une menace
mortelle qui pèse sur lui à tout moment.
Oui, aucun jeune de Gaza n'a d'autres
représentations possible de l'Israélien
que ça. Donc, il y a pas lieu de cette
année. On peut s'en indigner, on peut se
révolter. Et Dieu sait que enfin
personnellement, j'étais catastrophé
quand j'ai appris jusqu'où allaient les
les horreurs. Ensuite, il y a quelques
horreurs qui ont été quand même retirées
parce qu'elles avaient été fabriquées.
Mais tout de même les horreurs qui se
sont réellement produites sont
suffisantes pour avoir le cœur soulevé
par ça. Mais c
sommeil brisé aussi,
pardon.
Le sommeil brisé aussi.
En effet, tout.
Il en reste pas moins que avant de
porter un jugement définitif. Il faut
aussi arriver à comprendre dans quelles
circonstances
cela c'est s'est produit. Et dans et les
circonstances sont que
on est dans une prison, hein, un camp,
certains l'appellent un camp de
concentration. Là, je pense que c'est
peut-être excessif dans la dans la
polémique. En tout cas, c'est un camp
dans lequel les gens les gens sont
enfermés sans aucune raison et ils
voient à travers le grillage, ils
manquent, ils boivent de l'eau pourrie,
boueux, salé et cetera. Ils ont pas
assez à manger ou tout juste. Ils ont
comme périmètre quelques kilomètres
autour d'eux de toute éternité, enfin de
toute éternité de leur de leur
existence. Et il voit de l'autre côté du
grillage car c'est une clôture
grillagée, des kyots dans lesquels les
arrosages automatiques fonctionnent de
jour et nuit où il y a de belles
pelouses, de belles allées où les gens
vont, viennent, euh sortent de leur
voiture, partent en weekend et cetera.
Comment imagine-t-on que cela ne peut
pas produire des faits et susciter une
haine affreuse ? Moi, je tiens la haine
pour une passion noire, pour une passion
triste. Ce n'est pas quelque chose qu'il
faut susciter ou soutenir. Mais on ne
peut pas non plus se priver de
comprendre comment ces gens qui sont a
priori enfin moi j'ai beaucoup voyagé
dans le monde arabe j'ai j'ai surtout
vécu des situations d'accueil
d'hospitalité
entreé
et que d'un seul coup ces gens se
transforment en en tueur enragé et c'est
pas une transformation d'un seul coup et
ça n'est certainement pas la haine des
juifs d'autant plus qu'il y a plusieurs
dizaines de bédoins arabes qui ont été
tués ou capturés également des
travailleurs
philippin thaïlandais et tout au visage
à l'allure générale on reconnaissait le
ch donc c'était on on tuait on
s'emparait de tout ce qui était en
Israël dans une espèce de de rage
vengeresse
frénésie
en effet d'une frénésie vengeresse et
tout mais si on ne comprend pas d'où
vient cela, ça veut dire qu'on a rien
compris à ce qui'est le conflit
israélo-palestinien
la stratégie d'Israël à l'heure actuelle
Alain c'est une stratégie à court moyen
long terme. C'est une stratégie de œil
pour œil, dents pour dents, on va se
venger. C'est une stratégie qui a infiné
une solution pacifique. C'est une
stratégie qui a infiner une autre
solution. Comment tu juges le la
stratégie d'Israël ?
D'abord, on pourrait dire c'est la la
loi du talion, mais la loi du talon,
c'est œil pour œil, d pour dent, main
pour main, pied pour pied. Là, on est un
mort israélien pour 25 ou 30 morts
palestiniens. On n'est pas tout à fait
selon Netou, on est un terroriste du
Hamas pour un civil palestinien.
Oui, mais ça c'est bon.
Non non non mais tu tu as raison. Il
faut dire on a beaucoup de mal. Il y a
il y a pas de contestation sur le nombre
de morts.
Si si il y a des contestations le
contestation sur les la proportion de
femmes, d'enfants et de civils. Ça mais
une des raisons pour lesquelles il y a
ces contestations, c'est que il faut
rappeler qu'Israël interdit aux
journalistes d'aller sur place. C'estàd
c'est quoi ton boulot toi déjà ?
journaliste.
Et il y a effectivement un problème,
c'est-à-dire que et les journalistes
basé à Jérusalem ont fait une pétition
auprès de la cour suprême israélienne.
Elle a été rejetée. C'est la cour
suprême qui est présentée comme le
garant des libertés et cetera. Donc on n
pas, c'est vrai qu'il y a pas
d'information. Il y a des informations,
c'està dire horribles sur des massacres,
sur des fausses communes et cetera.
Euh bon, je la on peut dire le
hamassement et je le haassement comme le
gouvernement israélien ment, je veux
dire c'est pas mais il y a très beaucoup
de difficultés d'avoir des des
confirmations indépendantes mais enfin
on sait quand même je dire les paysages
de les paysages de Gazab mais c'est
c'est pas DR en 39 en DR c'est 43 ou je
crois c'est c'est pire je veux dire il y
a vraiment et puis il y a une volonté
c'està dire que de de détruire
systématiquement. C'estàd qu'une fois
qu'ils ont conquis les les choses, il y
a les bulles de qui arrivent. Donc on
est en train de rendre la la bande
invivable. Je pense que l'objectif
central de Netaniaou depuis le 8
octobre, c'est d'expulser la population,
de rendre le territoire
invivable et d'expulser la population.
Le problème s'expulser pour aller où ?
Bah lui, il pensait l'Égypte. Il y a eu
des négociations dans les premières
semaines en Égypte avec l'Égypte et les
États-Unis. On a probié à l'Égypte de
l'argent si accepter les Palestiniens
dans le Sinaï. Le problème c'est que le
Sinaï est déjà une zone extrêmement
instable avec l'État islamique qui est
et que si s'il y a des centaines de
milliers de Palestiniens en plus qui ont
vécu ça qui s'y installent, c'est la
fin. À quoi le d'ailleurs le maréchal le
président Sishi pour lequel je n'ai
aucune sympathie, je le je le précise, a
répondu aux Israéliens, "Vous voulez les
mettre quelque part, mettez-les dans le
des dans le désert du Neguève." C'est
bon. Voilà. Mais ça c'est la Mais moi je
pense que une des forces du mouvement
sioniste
dans ses dans ses pensées les plus
radicales c'estàdire l'ex en fait
l'expulsion de tous les Palestiniens,
c'est que ils s'adaptent aux situations.
C'est c'est ils avaient pas prévu le 7
octobre et cetera, mais ils s'adaptent
et ils profitent de chaque situation
comme ils ont profité de 48 49 ou de la
guerre de 67 pour expulser des centaines
de milliers de de palissiens. La
question c'est que pour les expulser à
grande échelle de manière à casser ce
cet équilibre démographique,
c'est je ne dis je ne dis pas que c'est
impossible, mais c'est quand même
difficile aujourd'hui avec y compris
quand même un certain nombre de pression
américaine, occidentale et cetera mais
ça reste quand même
un objectif. Maintenant, Netaniaou lui,
il est dans une je pense qu'il veut
poursuivre la guerre. C'estàdire, on le
voit bien, c'est il veut pas arrêter les
combats, je crois. Il n'a rien à faire
des otages. Ça c'est c'estd si les
questions des otages euh étaient
importantes, ils auraient négocié, ils
auraient il ne veut pas, il veut
pourtant il dit tous les jours qu'il
veut il veut les ages à la maison. Oui,
il veut les non, il dit pas ça.
D'ailleurs, les familles d'otage qui se
mobilisent le le considèrent comme le
principal responsable de l'échec des des
En plus, je plus on bombarde, enfin plus
les Israéliens bombardent, plus ils
tuent des otages, hein. Je veux dire là
le Habas a fait une déclaration pour
dire qu'ils ont
j'ai il y a une centaine ou 130, on ne
sais pas parce que on ne sait pas qui
combien restent vivant d'otage qui
restent au main du pas seulement du
Hamas parce que une des choses alors je
vais vous raconter l'anecdote qui est
qui est intéressante. J'ai un ami
égyptien qui est marié à une
palestinienne de Gaza et il était le 7
octobre là-bas.
Il est humoriste ?
Non, il est pas humoriste.
D'accord.
il est euh et donc il a vu les choses se
passer. Comment ça s'est passé ? Et
c'est pour ça aussi que euh la véritable
histoire du 7 octobre, on la connaîtra
plus tard. Il y a eu le meilleur
documentaire qui a été fait, c'est
Jazira en anglais qui a fait vraiment un
très bon documentaire. Il ne ni pas du
tout les massacres et cetera. Il raconte
comment ça s'est passé. Mais il y a eu
deux vagues d'attaque. La première
vague, c'était des des militants avec
les caméras euh les pas les caméras, les
moto et cetera et cetera. Et puis la
population a appris que c'était la
population de Gaza a appris que les
frontières s'étaient effondrées et ils
ont été là-bas. Ils ont été là-bas avec
y compris des gens qui ont alors qui ont
commis des crimes et des viols qui ont
pris des otages eux-mêmes parce que eux
ont des familles en 6 Jordanie qui sont
en prison en disant on va les échanger
parce que ça ça a toujours marché comme
ça avec Israël. C'est-à-dire que il y a
quand même, il faut rappeler aujourd'hui
je mais à à à il doit y avoir 10000 près
de 10000 prisonniers palestiniens en
Israël. Je dis et ça c'est et c'est et
une partie d'entre eux c'est vous savez
on appelle ça les détenus
administratifs. C'est-à-dire que vous
êtes pas jugé et tous les 6 mois c'est
on on renouvelle votre internement et ça
peut durer à vitam
et donc les gens veulent libérer leur
famille. Donc il ils prennent des
otages. Donc une partie des otages est
au main du Habas, une partie est au main
du djihad, une partie est au main de de
particulier. Et réellement, on sait que
le Habas ne voulait pas ton ootage parce
que il savait qu'il allait avoir une
riposte et puis gérer le comment dire
gérer les otages, c'est très compliqué.
Et aujourd'hui, je pense qu'une partie
personne ne sait ce qu'une partie des
otages est devenu et qui les a pris et
cetera. Donc je crois pas que le il y a
on était quand même très proche d'un
accord. le Habas avait donné son accord
et c'est euh pour la libération des
otages pour une période assez longue de
cesser le feu, il veut il veut pas pour
beaucoup de raisons. D'abord parce que
le jour où les combats s'arrêtent, il va
il va avoir quand même des comptes à
rendre sur le 7 octobre et ça je pense
que ça quand même la
comptes pour le renseignement, des
comptes pour tout ça.
Oui. Oui. Puis pour les qui a qui a
enfin c'est dire il y a quand même
Oui. Voilà. J'ai pas voulu employer le
mot mais c'était c'était ça. Puis je
pense qu'il y a quand même peut-être
chez lui l'idée que bon aujourd'hui il y
a des tensions avec les États-Unis, ça
le gêne ça ça gène Israël dépend des
États-Unis. Euh il faut pas se raconter
l'histoire. Si si les États-Unis
décident demain d'arrêter toute
exportation d'armes, l'arrê la la guerre
s'arrête en 12h. C'est pas vrai que
Israël peut continuer tout seul, mais il
y a des tensions et ça et ça l'inquiète.
Et donc il y a des élections américaines
en novembre. C'est pas si loin novembre.
Si on tient jusqu'en novembre, peut-être
qu'on aura Trump. Alors Trump a un peu
critiqué Netaniaou mais bon Trump change
d'avis et puis il est il il arrête pas
de dire il faut soutenir Israël
inconditionnellement. Donc il y a plein
de choses tactiques. C'est pas forcément
ce qui est frappant, c'est qu'il n'y a
pas de vision stratégique du point de
vue israélien parce que une vision
stratégique ça veut dire trouver une
solution avec les Palestiniens et il ils
n'en veulent pas en fait. Et aujourd'hui
on a enfin c'est pas seulement Etiaou,
il faut dire c'est une grande partie de
l'opposition qui est contre l'État
palestinien. Donc il y a pas de de
solution et que même si on arrive à une
même si euh on va aller demain 2 ans 3
ans et ça va il y a un moment où ça va
éclater comment ? comme ça éclaté le 7
octobre ou peut-être pas parce qu'il le
Habas aura pris des coups importants, il
y aura une nouvelle pouire parce que je
dire vraiment
imaginons ce que devienne cette
génération de jeunes qui a vécu enfin
qui a survécu à Gaza.
L'épigénétique de de la jeunesse qui a
survécu à Gaza. C'est ça
le
l'épigénétique.
Oui, si on peut mais c'està dire
effectivement
la seule possibilité c'est la haine.
C'estàd quand on vit ça et
on va s'attarder aux répercussions de
l'épigénétique du stress et de la
génération de futurs terroristes que ça
peut générer. Rony, qu'est-ce comment tu
vois la stratégie d'Israël toi en tant
que TBIB TBIB de guerre en tant que
médecin de terrain ? Quand tu peux voir
les vidéos avec des gamins en morceaux,
quand tu peux voir des brûlures avec tel
type de phosphore ou quand tu peux voir
tel type de de décombre,
comment tu analyses la stratégie
d'Israël ? Quelles sont les
répercussions sur la population ?
Quelles sont les répercussions sur les
pathologies ? Quelles sont les
répercussions ? Vas-y, je te donne la
parole. Ben d'abord euh il faut s'il
faut recontextualiser le type de conflit
que tu as pu faire avant pour pouvoir
comparer. Tu peux hein
euh bah oui oui effectivement c'est
peut-être pas c'est peut-être pas
inutile de voir ce que cette affaire-là
a de singulier par rapport à à d'autres
conflits au Yémen en Éthiopie euh en
Syrie, au Congo et cetera. La la
singularité de ce conflit, on l'a déjà
évoqué mais peut-être de façon un peu
latérale, je la reprends de façon
frontale, c'est queon a 2ion300000
personnes, enfin maintenant 2200000
euh personnes qui sont bouclées dans un
territoire extrêmement exigu exigu qui
ont donc qui offrent donc une population
extrêmement dense. Les zones d'habitat
sont très peuplées là qui sont dans leur
capacité de sortir et qui font face à un
bombardement d'une intensité
pratiquement sans précédent dans toutes
les guerres que j'ai évoqué et dans bien
d'autres si on en croit les généraux de
plateau qui commentent quotidiennement
cette cette guerre. Donc
un comment dire un bouclage d'une
population très dense, un bombardement
extrêmement intense et c'est à mon avis
la serise sur le gâteau en tout cas ce
qui vient couronner le tout. Le soutien
pratiquement indéfectible avec certes
des propos embarrassés avec des réserves
qui heureusement commencent à gagner en
force enfin qui soit qui reste très
timide parce qu'on parle de très bas.
Donc avec le soutien quasiment
indéfective de la partie du monde qui ne
cesse de se réclamer du droit
international, des droits de l'homme,
des liberté, de la du respect de la vie
et cetera.
Ça s'appelle se draper dans l'étendard
de la vertu.
Voilà par exemple et tout. Mais là c'est
c'est surtout c'est prendre une pose de
tartufe parce que ça ne ça ne tient plus
effectivement. Mais en tout cas, cette
extrême violence sur une population
extrêmement concentrée euh exercée avec
euh l'assentiment et le même le soutien
de tous, hein. Je rappelle que quand
même notre principal partenaire,
l'Allemagne qui prouve qui pourvoit
environ 20 % des équipements militaires
ou en tout cas des équipements en
munition euh de euh d'Israël, considère,
je cite, la sécurité d'Israël comme une
raison d'État allemande. Stat raison,
c'est une une raison d'état. les
Allemands n'en finissent pas de se
battre la coulpe, si j'ose dire, mais
euh leur coulpe c'est celle des
Palestinien en fait. C'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure, ils payent leur
dette mais avec le fric des
Palestiniens. C'est une
c'est une interprétation.
C'est une Non, non, non, c'est factuel
ça. Non, vraiment c'est factuel. S'il
voulait pas être leur coulpe réellement,
ils auraient dit ben le nazisme c'est
grosso modo parti de Bavière. Allez, on
vire les bavarois et on met les juifs à
leur place. Voilà, là on paye notre
dette. C'est nous, c'est notre histoire,
c'est notre
peut-être commencer par l'Autriche parce
que la Bavière
enfin bon mais de toute façon là on peut
on peut partir là. Non non, je je
maintiens que c'est pas une opinion là.
Là, on est dans l'ordre du fait durci,
quoi.
Donc voilà ce qui ce qui caractérise la
chose et qui rend, je pense, cette
situation particulièrement radioactive,
particulièrement mobilisatrice. Et si
dans le monde entier des jeunes se
mobilisent, enfin en l'occurrence
surtout à l'Ouest pour ce qui est des
jeunes, mais dans le monde entier pour
ce qui est des sociétés, c'est aussi à
cause de à cause de cela. En plus le du
fait que c'est une guerre de 100 ans
comme on a dit au début, que c'est la
dernière guerre coloniale, quoi qu'on
disent les amis ou les amis supposés
d'Israël, c'est une réalité et en plus
une guerre soutenue par les États-Unis,
une guerre qui serait impossible à mener
comme le rappelait Alain sans le les
livres le pont aérien quoi de de
ravitaillement là-bas. Maintenant, pour
ce qui est des faits eux-mêmes, je
reviens en deux mots sur la la manière
dont ça se passe, Gaza est quasiment
totalement aplati. Enfin, il reste des
zones encore avec du bâti intact mais
ultra minoritaire. Donc à Gaza, on
détruit tout, les habitations
individuelles, les immeubles
d'administration, les écoles, les
hôpitaux, je les les hôpitaux et un par
un. Et euh on réduit chaque jour la
capacité hospitale. Il y avait 36
hôpitaux à à Gaza. Il y en a
pratiquement plus que deux ou trois qui
ont une capacité opératoire, une
capacité fonctionnelle.
Je me fais l'avocat du diable.
Les mecs se planquent dans les hôpitaux.
Les terroristes se planquent dans les
hôpitaux. Les terroristes se planquent
dans les administrations. Les
terroristes font des tunnels partout.
Euh ils se cachent un peu comme les
Vietk Kong de l'époque à faire des
tunnels partout.
Pour répondre à
je fais exprès,
je cite dans le livre Ouia Avneri qui
est un qui a été un militant pour la p
c'est un type qui s'est battu pour
l'indépendance d'Israël. C'est un juif
qui a émigré en Is en Palestine pour se
battre et cetera et est devenu après
comme beaucoup enfin beaucoup comme un
certain combattant de la paix. Et en
2014, je crois ou 2009, dans une des
opérations euh israéliennes contre Gaza
où il y avait cet argument de le de ils
se servent des des de
se cache partout,
il se cache partout, il dit il fait un
communiqué communiqué de l'armée
allemande devant Leningrad en 1943.
dans le Alleningrad, c'est euh c'est
infiltré, enfin c'est installé parmi la
population une dangereuse organisation
terroriste qui s'appelle l'armée rouge
et il nous oblige à bombarder toute la
ville et c'est eux les criminels. Voilà,
c'est à peu près la même chose. Les
guerres urbaines, je sais pas où les
guerres urbaines se sont le ghetto de
Varsovie ou je veux dire où où ils sont
censés se cacher les combattants. C'est
pas là aussi ça met en lumière, c'est
pas deux armées qui se battent et on est
en terrain neutre, c'est on est on est
dans des dans
une guerre asymétrique. Et puis je veux
dire le le autorités israéliennes
considèrent c'est quand on parle du
Hamas, on sait pas très bien de qui il
parle parce que bon il y a les militants
ou des brigades des Édines Inassa mais
le policier qui fait la circulation il
le considère aussi comme toute
l'administration était ils étaient pas
tous Habas mais c'était dirigé par le
Hamas. Donc Israël les considère tous
comme Hamas et comme tout le monde a une
famille
à Gaza de 50 100 150 personnes, il
considère que tous les tous ces gens
sont des gens suspects. Donc c'est pas
un argument vraiment très convaincant,
je crois. Pardon.
Mais bon, en somme donc les Israéliens
attendraient que les gens du Ramas
viennent aimablement offrir leur
poitrine nu aux balles des Israéliens.
Enfin, c'est cette espèce de vie. Le
ministère de la défense israélien, il
est pas en plein désert, éventuellement
ciblable par une un missile étranger. Il
est en pleine ville comme l' d'ailleurs
le ministère de la défense euh français.
C'est c'est il y a il ministère de la
défense en France. faut
m'apprenez quelque chose les gars.
Il n'y a que ministère de l'économie
aussi. Dites donc,
il n'y a que dans cette situation
particulière que l'on parle du de cette
population qui servirait de bouclier
humain au ramass c'est quand même le
cas.
Mais non, c'est pas le cas. C'est la
réalité sociale, politique, matérielle,
urbaine de la bande de Gaza qui veut qui
veut cela. les c'est ça c'est la
propagande israélienne qui nous dit euh
il y a une formule pour ça parce que ils
sont ils sont très bons. Qui nous dit
euh en Israël il y a une armée qui
protège la population euh en Palestine
enfin dans dans Gaza, il y a une
population qui protège une armée. Voilà.
Mais qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que cela
euh une
armée terroriste ? Oui.
Oui. Non mais terroriste. Oui. Oui. Dans
dans les termes bien entendu. Enfin si
le terrorisme c'est vouloir terrifier
les gens par des actes violents.
C'est ça le terrorisme.
Ouais c'est ça hein. En gros on peut on
peut on peut dire c'est
la définition du terrorisme. Moi je dis
que ça existe pas. À ce moment-là,
l'armée israélienne est une armée
terroriste parce que si ça s'il y a s'il
y a une entité aujourd'hui qui terrorise
et qui tue en masse et de façon
indiscriminée, c'est quand même bien
l'armée israélienne. À une échelle, je
vous rappelle que quand on je te
rappelle
que lorsque le attentat de du 7 octobre
se sont produits, on a trouvé judicieux
de proposer un équivalent en victime
pour la France. C'est grosso modo,
c'était 10000 morts. Euh la France et
d'ailleurs Jacques Atali interviewé peu
de temps après sur TV5 Monde expliquait
au journalistes que
tu es sur ta source, tu es sur ton coup
là. Oui oui oui oui oui était il
expliquait aux journalistes que sur
c'est c'est retrouvable sur YouTube
que si le supposons que le Luxembourg
soit le siège d'un coup d'état
totalitaire et qu'à la suite de ce coup
d'état le Luxembourg arrose de bombe et
de missile
la France et que cela provoque 10000
morts. Que ferait la France ? Elle
répliquerait immédiatement par un déluge
de de bombe sur le Luxembourg. C'est
vrai.
Oui, sauf que
on aurait peut-être envoyé les Belges
avant, les Belges nous auraient défendu.
Non, mais c'est c'est quand même
l'énormité de la comparaison là que je
veux que je voulais mettre en avant.
Comparer la relation entre Israël et
Gaza. Je rappelle que Gaza, on l'a pas
dit tout à fait explicitement jusqu'à
présent, Gaza est un territoire occupé.
Il y a pas de discussion làdessus. C'est
pas une opinion là non plus. C'est un
fait, c'est un fait juridique, c'est un
fait politique, c'est un fait matériel.
C'est pas simplement du droit. C'està
dire qu'il y a pas une transaction
qu'elle soit une communication, une un
mouvement financier, un mouvement de
personne entre Israël et Gaza qui ne
soit sous le contrôle des Israéliens.
Donc c'est bien un territoire occupé,
même s'il est occupé de l'extérieur.
Quoique, parce que le sous-sol est pompé
par les Israéliens qui qui bouffent la
nave fréatique. L'air est occupée par
les drones de surveillance. Le littoral,
Alain l'a rappelé tout à l'heure, il est
contrôlé par la marine israélienne qui
tire sur des pêcheurs lorsque il se
noit. Et de l'autre côté, on a le
grillage et cetera.
Tu as les hydrocarbures en face de Gaza.
Oui. Bah bon, ça c'est encore ça c'est
disons c'est prospectif donc on y est
pas encore euh tout à fait. Mais voilà,
donc je je voulais dire que la
l'écrasement de Gaza euh c'est euh se se
produit dans le but de rendre Gazin
inhabitable. Si demain la guerre
s'arrêtait pour une raison, pour une
autre, on serait tous contents parce que
au moins il y aurait ce soulagement de
voir les atrocités s'interromper.
Mais qu'est-ce deviendrait ? Comment
comment vivent les comment vous vivez
dans un tas de dans un tas de décombes ?
Les Nations- Unies ont chiffré à une
quinzaine d'années la le temps
nécessaire pour assurer la
reconstruction de Gaza. Et ça, je
suppose que c'est enfin j'ai pas j'ai
pas revu vu le calcul, j'ai pas les
moyens disons de de vérifier. Enfin, ça
suppose que une ville c'est pas
simplement du bâti posé, c'est pas du
Lego quoi qui est posé un côté de
l'autre. C'est tout, c'est une histoire.
Ce sont ce sont des russes, ce sont des
passages, ce sont des quartiers avec
Gazin est devenu définitivement
invivable, enfin pour une période qui
est au moins une génération,
c'est-à-dire à notre échelle euh
définitivement.
Donc qu'est-ce qui va se passer ? En
fait, la réalité c'est qu'on en sait
rien. Euh évidemment le propos,
l'idée c'est qu'il fuyait c'était de les
faire fuir vers Gaza. On a parlé de de
transfert volontaire, de mesures
humanitaires. Le vocabulaire horswélien
déployé par les dirigeants israéliens et
fait frémir enfin ça dresse le le le
poil sur la tête.
Donc l'idée c'est de les expulser
vers l'Égypte, vers d'autres pays
d'Afrique. Éventuellement nous des
ministres l'ont dit dans ces termes,
l'Europe après tout, si on aime tant les
Palestiniens, ben on a qu'à les recevoir
chez nous, hein. Ça ça rappelle Guel 138
disant "Si vous aimez tant les juifs,
prenez-les". lors de la conférence
desviant, c'est vraiment passé
absolument abjecte. Euh donc, on voit
quelles sont les intentions. Se
débarrasser de la population
palestinienne de Gaza ou en tout cas la
réduire à son strict minimum selon les
termes du Premier ministre. C'est
Nethaniaou qui a utilisé cette formule.
La réduire à son strict minimum.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ? Ben Smotrich l'a
dit. Donc le ministre des finances SMR,
je j'ai toujours du mal à les à les
situer parce qu'ils s'occupent si peu de
leur portefeuille et et tellement
d'idéologie qu'on a du mal à les à se
souvenir de leur fonction. Mais en tout
cas euh ce mot disant il y a pas de il y
a pas de place pour les Palestiniens
sous le sous le soleil, il faut tous le
il faut tous les tuer. Donc Netaniavou
apparaît comme un modéré hein. C'est le
principe de la la fenêtre de Vernon
d'Overton. vous si vous tenez un propos
extrémiste et derrière la personne qui
arrive dit "Non, non, quand même pas,
pas tout ça, on va pas tous le tuer, on
va en garder 100000."
Euh voilà le le donc il y a il y a une
perspective génocidaire
qui me semble réelle qui a été mise en
avant par la Cour internationale de
justice qui choque énormément un certain
nombre de gens parce que Israël se
présente
avec quelques titres mais enfin de façon
quand même aussi assez largement abusive
parce que la plupart des survivants de
la Choa, ils sont partis ailleurs qu'en
Israël comme le rappelait comme le
rappelé Ain tout à l'heure. Mais bon,
que le pays qui se présente comme le
celui des survivants de la Choa puisse
être accusé, puisse voir la charge des
génocides lui être adressé. Ça quelque
chose en effet d'assez bouleversant.
Enfin, on est cul par-dessus tête là.
Mais bon, c'est une réalité. endroit. Il
y a quelque chose qui s'appelle un
risque plausible de génocide souligné
par la Cour internationale de justice et
l'aplatissement de Gaza, le la la
le bombardement continuel où on se on on
comment dire on
le système de ciblage
des du Ramas puisque c'est théoriquement
une guerre contre le Hamas. Moi je pense
que c'est une guerre contre les
Palestiniens et pas une guerre contre le
Ramas. C'est ce que tu penses.
C'est ce que je pense bien sûr. Oui.
Non, ça c'est de l'ordre d'une opinion,
je le concède tout à fait.
Mais dans cette guerre, on s'autorise et
c'est explicite 10 à 20 morts
collatéraux, c'est-à-dire des innocents
pour un petit poisson du Ramas et 100 à
200 voire plus, on l'a vu à Djabalia
pour un gros poisson du ramass. Donc
quand Netaniaou dit un ramasse pour une
victime civile, c'est-à-dire une
performance qu'aucune armée au monde
lancée dans une guerre comme celle-ci
n'a pu atteindre, c'est ça fait aussi
partie de la propagande israélienne. Non
seulement on tue pas les civilis, non
seulement on fait pas de génocide alors
qu'on pourrait le faire mais on ne le
fait pas. Ça, ils aiment bien le
rappeler qu'il pourraient le faire mais
que précisément la charge est est
injuste parce que ils ne le font pas et
qu'au contraire en gros c'est un pour un
ou un pour deux hein les des gens plus
plus modérés mais là on voit que c'est
un pour 10, un pour 20, un pour 100, un
pour 200. Je je vais je vais je vais les
défendre un peu. Ils balancent des
tractes avant de bombarder. Ils envoient
des SMS avant de bombarder.
Oui.
Donc vous bombardez une prison et puis
vous envoyez aux prisonniers le la vie
queils vont être bombardés et qu'ils
peuvent partir. C'est un peu ça.
Ils nulle part où aller. C'est ça le
problème. C'est que dans les endroits où
ils disent qu'il faut aller, il y a des
bombardements aussi. C'està dire
aujourd'hui il y a pas d'endroit qui
n'est pas bombardé. C'est ça la réalité
de de de de Gaza.
Mais je peux continuer d'essayer de les
défendre. Oui, oui, oui, tout à fait,
tout à fait, tout à fait.
Et euh il y a eu combien de morts selon
tel ou tel ? Ça va de 15000 à 40000. Ça
va là le chiffre sur lequel on s'est
arrêté, c'est 35000.
Le problème, c'est voir combien de si
combien de membres du Hamas il y a.
C'est ça le
bon, on va dire 14000 membres du HAS,
disons
à la louche
H.
Avec le nombre de tonnes de bombes
qu'ils ont envoyé, ça fait quand même
pas beaucoup de morts parce que je crois
qu'ils ont envoyé la première semaine au
ton de bombe que les Russes ont envoyé
sur toute l'Ukraine en une année. C'est
ça ?
Oui, c'est les chiffres demander fa
checker ou
donc ils essayent de faire ça, je me
fais l'avantcade du diable encore mais
ils essayent de faire ça proprement.
Non,
proprement c'est 35000 morts et des
dizaines de milliers de blessés. Je ne
sais pas combien ou mais vous comprenez
pas ? Nous on chasse le terroriste à la
banque qui fait une tonne. Donc c'est
compliqué de
C'est ça.
Voilà. C'est ça. C'est c'est d'une tonne
ou d'une demi et
pourquoi pourquoi ils envoient pas des
soldats sur le terrain directement au
lieu d'envoyer des des tonnes de bombes
et les chars derrière ? Ils ont perd des
répercussions politiques.
H
parce qu'il faut une guerre à
l'américaine.
Ouais. C'està dire c'est les guerres
zéro mort enfin zéro mort ils en ont
plus que zéro mais
c'est guerre où les de toute façon les
occidentaux en général les armées
occidentales n'acceptent pas beaucoup de
morts c'est la réalité de toutes les
guerres qui sont vené je voulais je
voulais terminer sur le côté un peu un
peu médical aussi vraiment très très
rapidement il y a plusieurs probablement
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
blessés c'est très difficile
à savoir parce qu'autant les morts font
l'objet d'un recensement sérieux par le
ministère de de la santé de
tenu par le Hamas,
tenu par le Ramas aussi par le Fatar. Le
Ramas ne règne pas entre exclusif et
absolu sur le ministère de la santé.
Il se trouve que dans une vie
antérieure,
j'ai été épidémiologiste. C'està dire
que j'aime savoir combien il y a de
malade, combien d'où ça vient, combien
il y a de morts et cetera. Je me suis
toujours intéressé au chiffres. Pardon.
Tu as dû te faire plaisir avec le Covid.
Non. Oui oui oui oui. Non,
tu il y a le coléra qui revient à
Mayotte, tu vas pouvoir
Non mais le coléra il revient il revient
partout hein. C'est
désolé de t'avoir coupé.
Et donc je je me suis beaucoup intéressé
au chiffres des conflits. Certains très
exagérés, d'autres très minorés et
cetera. Par exemple, le conflit de RDC
dont on parle maintenant de 8 millions
de morts, c'est probablement 10 fois
moins. C'est déjà beaucoup euh mais
c'est probablement 10 fois. Le ce qui
est ce qui est terrible d'ailleurs avec
ça, c'est qu'on dit il y a que 800000
morts. On a l'impression d'être presque
un négationniste quoi. Que 800000 morts.
On imagine la montagne de cadavre et
l'océan de souffrance que ça représente.
Mais non, 8 millions, c'est quand même
mieux que 800000.
Je ferme la parenthèse. J'ai été frappé
à au vu du des bilans donnés par les
autorité de de Gaza. Donc le ramasse
disons euh au fil des conflits
successives euh l'exactitude du bilan
toujours finalement corroborée par les
Israéliens
ensuite et confirmé par divers instituts
qui s'intéressent à aux décantes des
morts. Quand on parle de 250 morts, il y
en a 240 ou 260. Mais c'est c'est cela
quand on parle de 2000 et là je parle de
bilan, c'est 2014 2018 et cetera. Quand
on parle de de 2000, c'est ça. Là où
c'est beaucoup plus difficile, c'est sur
les blessés parce que les blessés sont
mal recensés. Et là par exemple,
les effondrements d'immeuble ressemblent
un petit peu à ce qui se passe lors d'un
tremblement de terre. Et dans un
tremblement de terre, il y a assez il y
a peu de blessés par rapport aux morts.
Dans une guerre, il y a plus de il y a
trois fois plus de blessés. que de mort
là. Euh est-ce que on se rapproche d'un
tremblement de terre ? Par exemple, les
équipes chirurgicales de médecins sans
vantières ou d'ailleurs des équipe
médical de palestinienne disait euh de
façon continue enfin répétée que il ne
soignait pas des gens qui souffraient de
mort par qui souffraient de blessures
par balle ou par éclat. Il il soignait
des plai par écrasement pour
l'essentiel. Donc des trucs qui
ressemblent à des PL par tremblement de
terre, même si ça se ressemble beaucoup
du point de vue graphique, c'est très
différent du point de vue médical, ce
queon voit en guerre et en matière de de
catastrophe naturelle. Donc voilà, en
tout cas des milliers, des dizaines de
milliers de de blessés dont l'essentiel
reste sans soi. Plus les maladies plus
les maladies épidémie quand vous vivez
dans des conditions de promiscuité tell
avec en gros une latrine pour 150 ou une
latrine bouchée en plus pour 150 ou 200
habitants, représentons-nous sans aller
trop dans le détail mais simplement
faisant l'effort d'imagination. dire,
ces gens ne peuvent pas faire leurs
besoins de façon décente. Ils sont en
permanence dans la foule, dans le euh il
mange très très mal. Il mangent mais il
mangent mal, déséquilibré.
Euh
c'est l'hiver, il fait froid, ça
favorise les infections. Donc infection
digestive, infection respiratoire,
infection cutanée, prolifère. Donc on a
des épidémies et ce cela sur fond de
stress intense jamais affaibli jour et
nuit. Vous vivez dans l'angoisse de
recevoir une bombe sur la tête, de voir
vos enfants ne parvenir et cetera. Donc
ce stress là, il faut savoir que il a
une il a aussi des conséquences
immunitaires. Ce stress prolongé, ça
diminue les défenses contre les
agressions bactériennes et virales. Donc
ça amplifie encore les conséquences de
la promiscuité et du de l'absence totale
d'hygiène. Voilà les les et et tout ça
dans un océan de ruine. Voilà la
situation
actuelle à à Gaza. Une question avant de
revenir sur la stratégie israélienne.
Euh euh
les blocs opératoires euh ils sont euh
fourni en anesthésiant, pas en
anesthésiant ? Est-ce qu'il y a des
médicaments sur place qui permettent de
de traiter les gens ? Comment ça se
passe pour les gens qui ont une maladie
chronique ? Genre le diabète, comment
ils font pour avoir l'insuline ? Comment
les médecins on ont du curar pour faire
des anesthésies ? Comment ça se passe ?
J'ai entendu, j'ai vu des choses comme
quoi les Tobib étaient obligés de faire
des amputations à vif sur des pauvres
gamins. C'est vrai, c'est pas vrai.
Comment la communauté internationale
réagit par rapport à ça ? avec la
privation d'alim la privation d'aliment
avec le le déplacement de population
avec le fait qu'il y ait rien pour
soigner les gens alors que le qu'il y a
des colons qui chopent l'aide
humanitaire ou qui saccage l'aide
humanitaire ou que le Hamas privatise
l'aide humanitaire.
Comment on fait pour sauver du civil que
ce soit du civil israélien ou du civil
palestinien Aucune sympathie
politique pour le ramasse, mais l'idée
que le ramas privat l'aide humanitaire,
comme tu l'as dit, me semble hors hors
de propos. Enfin,
on a on a vu des vidéos de camion d'aide
humanitaire avec des gars du Hamas en
train de dire à tout le monde "Vous
touchez pas, c'est pour nous".
D'accord. Alors bon, je ne peux pas me
prononcer. J'ai j'ai pas vu donc
peut-être
autant pour moi, mais enfin ça
demanderait quand même à être vérifié
parce que je suis pas sûr qu'ils ai
beaucoup de capacité dans ce domaine et
qu'ils aient envie de se mettre la
population à dos. Mais enfin euh le
la population, ils vont l'avoir à dos
là. une une partie qui apparaît hein, je
veux dire il faut faire attention parce
que on verra après parce que bon j'ai là
tout le monde est sous c'est c'est tout
le monde est à la fois sous le choc à
Gaza mais aussi il y a un esprit de
résistance et on ne considère pas les
Hamas comme responsable peut-être qu'une
fois que la paix sera sera
accomplie en fonction du du résultat
mais la popularité du Hamas en si
Jordanie notamment où il y a des
sondages qui sont assez bien faits mais
même Gaza où il y a il y a des gens qui
ont enfin qui ont un certain nombre de
contacts et dans le monde arabe n'a
jamais été aussi importante. C'est ça
aussi le problème, c'est que euh cette
action brutale israélienne favorise les
éléments extrémistes. Elle ne elle ne
elle ne contribue pas à les à les
battre. Et je dis il faut bien
comprendre, le Hamas a gagné en 2007 les
élections législatives euh démocratiques
qu'il y a eu entre Jadien et Gaza. Ils
ont représenté ils ont eu 46 % des
suffrages de Fatar 43 ou quelque chose
comme ça. Pourquoi ? Parce que on avait
le Fatar avec Arafat qui avait fait les
accords d'Oslo qui avait dit "On aura un
état palestinien dans 5 ans, on sera
indépendant et cetera." Le résultat
c'est nul. et le Hamas qui était dans
l'opposition en disant tout ça ça va pas
marcher. Bah les gens ont voté pour le
parti de l'opposition pas forcé pas par
sympathie pour l'aspect euh
il y a il y a une partie de la
population qui est très religieuse et
plus enfin plus importante à mon avis à
Gazak qu'en Jordanie. Mais voilà, donc
les les gens ont voté pour le parti
d'opposition qui avait et puis bon, on a
on a empêché si vous voulez, il y a eu
un gouvernement d'union nationale
pendant quelques mois, les les
occidentaux, les Israéliens ont ont
poussé pour euh que ça éclate. et Israël
a poussé, il faut rappeler, ça a été
bien dit que pendant cette période après
la prise du pouvoir par le Habas à Gaza,
Netaniaou a dit clairement et la presse
Israël publié, nous avons besoin de
maintenir Gaza sous le contrôle du Hamas
parce que comme ça, il y a deux
interlocuteurs palestiniens
et personne ne va nous demander de
négocier avec eux. Donc il il a dit sous
cette forme, "Ceux qui sont contre un
état palestinien doivent nous permettre
d'aider financièrement le Hamas".
C'est-à-dire de permettre à l'argent qui
venait du Qatar d'arriver euh d'arriver
à à Gaza. Une partie de cet argent était
euh servait simplement à maintenir le la
population à flot. Puis une partie
évidemment a été utilisée aussi pour des
raisons militaires. Mais le c'est c'est
c'est
l'histoire est
intéressante. Le Hamas est l'héritira
conquière Gaza, il y a deux forces à à
Gaza. Les frères musulmans et le euh le
Fatar, enfin l'OLP, disons. Les services
de renseignement israéliens vont aider
le les frères musulmans. Je dis c'est
les frères musulmans ne sont pas une
création des services de renseignement.
Pourquoi ? Parce que le moi je les ai
rencontré à l'époque les dirigeants du
des frères musulmans jusqu'en 87, il
disait si on a perdu, c'est qu'on est
des mauvais musulmans. Donc notre
problème c'est pas l'occupation
israélienne, c'est de redevenir des bons
musulmans. C'est un discours qui
convenait tout à fait aux Israéliens. Et
donc ils ont ils ont favorisé ce
mouvement contre le contre l'OLP. Je
veux dire et cette politique cynique
aussi qui est une politique de gestion
coloniale quoi. C'està dire on essaie de
jouer les uns contre les autres mais
parce qu'on on le problème c'est que
Israël n'a pas de solution. C'est c'est
ça qui ne c'est c'est en sens que on est
dans une situation absurde. Non. Tu es
pas d'accord ? Vas-y, vas-y, vas-y.
C'est bien de
si si je je pense que Israël a a une
solution qui est la solution la pire,
celle que théoriquement personne ne veut
mais que Israël entend mener à son
terme, c'est-à-dire la récupération de
l'intégralité de la Palestine mandataire
qui était donc le la la Palestine entre
la Méditerranée et le Jourdain pour
prendre son cette dimension là.
Ils n'ont pas tout à fait. Ils reste des
intrus. Oui, ce moment c'estul.
Voilà, c'est ça. C'est non mais c'était
un peu ironique mon opposition. C'est ça
que je c'est ça que je je voulais dire.
Et d'ailleurs Nethanahou l'a très bien
montré quand il a aux Nations- Unies peu
de temps avant, je crois que c'était en
en septembre au moment de l'assemblée
générale annuelle donc
des des Nations unies. Nou a cru bon de
s'exhiber. Bon, en montrant toujours
pour expliquer que la question
palestinienne est résolue depuis
longtemps, que ça c'est ça n'intéresse
plus que quelques intellectuels dans
leur coin, mais que
on est passé à autre chose. Et il montre
une carte dans laquelle il y a
absolument aucune trace de la Palestine
Israël est homogène entre le Liban,
l'Égypte, la Jordanie et la
Méditerranée.
De l'autre côté, ils font la même chose,
hein.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Enfin, c'est que ça il y
a qui ont le pouvoir et les autres qui
ont pas c'est toute la différence. Ils
ont le pouvoir et ils le montrent aux
Nations- Unies. C'est pas c'est pas des
gens et et en plus pour disons la
plupart des mouvants palestiniens, il y
a quand même la prise en compte de la
réalité et des frontières issues de la
guerre de 67 ou même de 48 mais ils ont
plutôt plutôt de 67. Donc même ça ça
n'est pas euh ça n'est pas tout à fait
clair. Non, ceux qui revendiquent le
grand Israël aujourd'hui, c'est la
droite et l'extrême droite euh
israélienne. Et donc avec euh
messianique. Naganiaou n'est pas
vraiment messianique, il fait alliance
avec les messianiques. Mais
il est opportuniste.
Voilà, c'est ça. Il est il est
opportuniste.
Il est euh
Oui, enfin il est quand même à un degré
un niveau qu'il porte particulièrement
haut. Mais donc je je pense que
non non, il est particulièrement
brillant comme dirigeant politique. Je
veux dire en la manière dont il gère la
situation interne en Israël, il fait les
alliances et cetera, il se sort, tout le
monde dit il va être inculpé, il va être
battu et cetera et il survit depuis 15
ans. Je veux dire c'est il a c'est un
bon politique mais c'est pas forcément
un compliment.
Toi tu n'as pas étudié la Libye, c'est
pour ça on a les mêmes aussi nous.
C'est vrai,
mais je je voulais je voulais terminer
sur la stratégie. Donc je je remarque
que un terme un terme arabe qui était
banni du vocabulaire politique israélien
qui est la la Nagba, non la Nagba,
l'expulsion de la catastrophe
euh qui désigne donc l'expulsion de de
48 était considéré comme un propos
antisioniste hostile à l'état juif.
Pourquoi pas ? qu'il fallait pas s'en
occuper. Maintenant, ce propos est
repris positivement par la droite et
l'extrême droite israélienne comme le
nom le le nom le nom de col si vous
voulez du de la mission à accomplir
aujourd'hui, c'est-à-dire du boulot
qu'il faut terminer. En 48, Ben Gourion
a eu le tort, je c'est pas moi qui parle
là, c'est par exemple Benny Maurice ou
l'historien Benny Maurice, mais beaucoup
de gens disons à droite et à l'extrême
droite a eu le tort de laisser subsister
200000 Palestiniens sur le il en a
expulsé 800000 et 200000 sont restés sur
les territoires israéliens. Et bien ces
200000 ils ont proliféré, il s'agit de
se défaire
d'eux et de donc de conquérir
C'est ce qu'il a dit, c'est quand même
horrible au vocabulaire, on les a laissé
proliférer. C'est moi, c'est c'est moi
c'est pas
je Mais d'une certaine manière, il y a
il y a ce côté grouillant, vermineux qui
est qui fait partie du du vocabulaire
colonial. cette masse informe.
D'ailleurs, la manière dont on
représente la Palestine, la plupart du
temps à l'image, c'est ça. Ce sont des
foules anonymes, ce sont des
silhouettes, ce sont pas des visages,
des histoires. Regardez comment euh on
traite euh les familles d'otage euh
israéliennes avec un nom, un visage, des
photos, une histoire, une une humanité
qui pénètre, qui sort par chaque port de
la peau. Et pour les autres, c'est des
c'est des gens indistins, dont on
déplore le sort assez triste et la main
sur le cœur, on est contre la mort des
enfants de Gaza, toute vie vaut toute
vie et cetera. Enfin, il y a tous les
les mots codés sont prêts à l'emploi
pour pour ça, mais on s'en fiche
royalement. Et donc pour revenir au
propos, il y a je pense une stratégie,
je ne sais pas du tout si elle est je
crois même pas qu'elle soit vraiment
réaliste. Enfin, on on sait pas, il
faut se retrouver coincé là. Mais c'est
que c'est c'est de c'est de vider la la
Palestine des Palestiniens et de la
récupérer pour
ça c'est une stratégie qui a commencé en
en 1920 et qui continue jusqu'à
aujourd'hui les institutions
internationales. Excuse-moi, il suffit
de regarder les cartes pour voir que les
zones de peuplement palestinien se
réduisent toujours plus et le le
harcèlement qui est à l'œuvre
actuellement si Jordanie à l'occasion du
fait que la tension est attirée vers
Gazain euh ce ce harcèlement c'estd
meurtres, des possessions, des incendies
de récolte, des incendies de maison, des
checkpoints tout le temps, des
lynchages, des caillassages, des
attaques à coup de gourdin et à coup de
tout ça sous la protection visible euh
de l'armée. Euh qu'est-ce que c'est
sinon euh le le le signe que vous n'avez
plus rien à faire ici et si vous voulez
vivre et ben vous traversez le fleuve et
vous allez en Jordanie. La solution
jordanienne c'est l'obsession des de la
plupart des courantnistes. Pas seulement
à droite et à l'extrême droite. Moi,
j'ai aussi entendu ça toute mon enfance.
Euh mais les Palestiniens, ils ont des
dans mon enfance, on parlait pas de
Palestiniens, les Arabes parce que les
Palestiniens, c'est une invention
propagandiste. Maintenant, depuis Oslo,
on parle des Palestiniens, on les on les
reconnaît. Mais avant non, c'était une
prise de position politique déjà très
discutable que de parler de Palestinien.
Mais moi, je j'entendais autour de moi
les gens, mais la Jordanie, elle est là
pour il y a la 6 Jordanie, la
Transjordanie. C'est bien la preuve que
c'est la même chose d'une certaine
manière et donc qu'ils aillent là-bas,
c'est leur leur pays. Mais il faut bien
dire, il faut ajouter à cela que Israël
aurait tort de gêner d'une certaine
manière puisque toutes les exactions que
je parle du point de vue du droit
international, c'estàdire occupation qui
n'est pas une violation du droit
international mais occupation continue
et ensuite implantation de population
civile sur dans les territoires conquis
militairement et exploitation de ces
territoires. C'est ça les crimes de
guerre. C'est pas le fait de conquérir
d'occuper un territoire. Mais ça n'a ça
n'a jamais cessé les expulsions, les
implantations et cetera. Il y a pas
besoin de refaire le film, ça tout le
monde l'a en tête, je suppose. N'ont
jamais été sanctionnés de la moindre
manière que ce soit, si ce n'est par
quelques froncements de sourcils, par
quelques propos un peu là, c'est ça.
Oui, quand même. Vous pourriez éviter de
nous compliquer la tâche comme ça. C'est
plutôt de ça que les gens que les les
chancelleries se se plaignent. Donc
Israël a été récompensé pour toutes les
exactions euh commis
selon toi.
Non non non, ça c'est objectif. Ça c'est
objectif. Les crédits militaires, le
crédit diplomatique, le crédit
symbolique, hein, le fait de répéter
avec insistance qu'on défend, on se bat
au côté de la seule démocratie
du du proche- Orient,
de la région
et que nous sommes démocratie à côté de
démocratie. notre place notre place nous
français par exemple et nous européens
plus général notre place naturelle est
au côté d'Israël dans le combat engagé
contre la barbarie obscurantiste ou la
la barbarie islamiste. Ça c'est pas un
crédit que je désigne comme factuel, un
élément qui va au-delà de mon opinion
mais qui est factuel. Alors je sais pas
ce qui est un crédit. les crédits euh
commercials. Israël a un accès au marché
européen par le l'accord d'association
qui lit Israël euh alors que
théoriquement il est prévu que aucun
produit euh issu des colonies ne puisse
entrer en Europe. Mais chacun sait que
quelques petits tours de pass-pentrer
tout ce qu'on veut en Europe via
Jérusalem, c'est au Portugal
via Israël. C'est ça.
Voilà. C'est ça. Voilà. Donc
on on d'une certaine manière, il y a une
rationnalité profonde. Là où ça devient
irrationnel, c'est dans le c'est dans
l'UBrice, c'est la démesure de leur de
leur projet. Mais leur projet initial,
rationnel qui est de euh récupérer pour
l'essentiel toute la 6 Jordanie qui leur
convient, c'est-à-dire la six-jordanie
rurale, la 6 Jordanie de l'eau et des
cultures,
la vallée du Jourdain. Euh ça euh
d'ailleurs, ils l'ont, ils les ont déjà
et ils sont contents avec ça. comme
aucune sanction ne leur a jamais été
imposée et que bien au contraire ils
n'ont vu que leur crédit se réhaussait
d'année en année ou de décennies en
décennie, pourquoi ferait-il autrement ?
Si je dis tout cela avec avec tant de
mots, c'est parce que je pense que sans
une implication internationale décisive,
c'estd sans des sanctions sévères,
suspension de l'accord d'association,
arrêt des livraisons d'armes, suspension
de de la des Jeux Olympiques parce que
le sport, moi j'ai un peu connu
l'Afrique du Sud du temps de
l'apartaille et après
et élection soviétique aussi non ?
Élection union soviétique aussi. Oui oui
oui oui qui a été qui été qui a été
boycotté et aujourd'hui la Russie qui
est interdite de jeu et cetera et quand
on va voir le drapeau israélien défilé
dans les rues de Paris ou dans les
grands stades et tout mais ça va être
enfin le drapeau d'un état accusé de
façon consistante par des experts, pas
par des militants de génocide ou de
plausible génocide
accusation intenable
ça a pas été jugé. Euh euh bon alors la
question quand Gaza va se réouvrir, si
on trouve des choses encore plus sales
que prévu,
comment ça va se passer en terme de
justice internationale ? Va y avoir un
crime de guerre, pas de crime de guerre,
une cour internationale de justice, pas
de cour internationale de justice la
Courciale de justice, c'est loin.
Le les États qui ont fourni de
l'armement, est-ce qu'ils vont être
coaccusés
de
C'est pour ça que à mon avis ce qui se
joue à Gaza euh au-delà du sort de la
population palestinienne qui est quand
même l'essentiel, c'est l'avenir des
pour moi c'est l'avenir des relations
internationales. C'est-à-dire avec Gaza,
l'Occident a fait la preuve que euh les
valeurs dont il se réclama, il ne les
applique pas. Mais ça ça a une
conséquence parce que là bon on dit
simplement bon c'est un double langage
et ça mais de alors c'est demain qui va
pouvoir condamner un état qui commet des
les mêmes crimes euh que ce soit la
Chine que ce soit le Brésil ou que ce
soit le au Congo et cetera. C'estàdire
il y a l'idée que le droit international
la plus important. C'estàd et c'est pour
ça que moi je je disais tout à l'heure,
je le terrorisme pour moi c'est c'est
une espèce de de comment dire
d'épouvantail. La guerre contre le
terrorisme, ça nous engage dans une
espèce de guerre entre le bien et le
mal.
Sans fin.
C'est une sans fin. Et on peut pas
gagner la guerre contre le mal. À moins
de d'être dans une utopie quand le quand
le Messie reviendra peut-être. Mais en
attendant, c'est
quand Alice Sapric reviendra. Voilà, je
vois que
c'était pas Rikazaray que je cherchais,
c'était Alice Sapric.
Donc il y a il y a quand même là quelque
chose et puis ça a une autre conséquence
pour nous la France, c'est que c'est
entre la France vient de se faire
expulser de du Sahel, on va se faire
demain expulser du Maghreb. C'est au
Maghreb l'unanimité de la population,
toute tendance confondue. Les
islamistes, les salafistes, les
démocrates, les communistes, aujourd'hui
vomissent la France parce que en plus il
ils voi ce qui se passe sur leur sur les
télévisions françaises et disent si
c'est ça la démocratie, on nen veut pas.
Et nous affaiblissons nos propres amis.
C'est tous les gens qui se sont battus
pour les libertés au moment des
printemps arabes et cetera. Tous les
autres leur disent "Mais attendez, c'est
ça le modèle que vous voulez ?" Donc là,
il y a quelque chose vraiment de d'qu
pour moi qui est inquiétant parce que
c'est enfin c'est inquiétant encore une
fois, c'est avant tout pour la
population de Gaza, mais c'est
inquiétant sur euh en fait de ça a
commencé le 11 septembre quoi.
C'est-à-dire que petit à petit avec le
11 septembre, on a justifié les guerres
euh non provoquées, on a on a justifié
les tortures et cetera. Juste un mot sur
la torture, je veux dire, il y a des
informations dans la presse Israël. Il y
a des centres de torture où on torture
régulièrement les Palestiniens
capturés. La
torture est légale en Israël depuis 92.
Oui. Enfin, il type de torture, vous
parlez de quoi là ?
Ce que on appelle en Israël d'un terme
euphémisé parce qu'on parle jamais de
torture. On ne légalise pas la torture,
on légalise les pressions physiques
modérées. C'est sous ce terme-là que ça
apparaît.
Mais là, c'est ça va au-delà des
pressions physiques parce qu'il y a eu
beaucoup de morts et il y a eu vraiment
des témoignages physé. Ça veut dire oui.
Non non mais mais là je dire visiblement
ils se sont lâchés. C'est il y a aussi
l'idée que bon euh après ce qui s'est
passé 7 octobre, tout est permis. Mais
ça on peut pas enfin on peut même en
acceptant toute cette il y a pas de
comment dire il y a pas d'équivalence
aucune
comment dire c'est pas parce qu'il y a
eu des crimes comis que vous avez le
droit de tuer des gens. C'està dire
c'est c'est
quand quand on entend à la télé voilà
bah pour récupérer Saint-Malot on a rasé
Saint-Malot. Il y avait des civils, on a
été obligé.
Oui, mais je le le droit international,
les conventions de Genève et cetera,
c'est après la Seconde Guerre mondiale
et c'est en partie le résultat de la
Seconde Guerre mondiale. C'estàdire,
c'est des choses qu'on enfin la
convention sur le génocide, c'est 48.
Euh les conventions de Genève sur le
droit de la guerre et cetera et cetera.
Donc c'était justement en fonction de ça
et il y a eu toute une série de débats,
c'està dire est-ce que est-ce que le
aujourd'hui les bombardements massifs
des villes allemandes qui en plus était
pas justifié militairement enfin
aujourd'hui les les bon est-ce que
est-ce que ça ne relèverait pas
aujourd'hui de crime de guerre mais bon
on refait pas l'histoire je dis mais
aujourd'hui l'idée c'est qu'en 45 on
s'est quand même réclamé d'un ordre
international nouveau et en partie
c'était vrai c'est c'était
Bien sûr, il y avait encore le
colonialisme, il y avait des choses,
c'était aussi la loi du plus fort, mais
il y avait quand même une forme
d'équilibre et j'ai l'impression que
depuis le 11 enfin ça a pu changer le 11
septembre 2001 a marqué un tournant et
cette idée de la guerre contre le
terrorisme c'est l'idée que le
une partie de droit international ne
s'applique pas quand il s'agit des
sauvages. Et c'est quand il s'agit des
sauvages
des sauvages pour eux pour nous pour
pour c'estàdire que il y a
ceux appelés sauvages par le fond. Je
cite dans le livre le un expert
géopolitique
euh allemand du la fin du 19e siècle. Il
parle des des tribus africaines. Il dit
le droit international
si on veut l'appliquer au aux tribus
ça n'a plus aucun sens. C'est c'est
quelque chose qui concerne uniquement
les gens civilisés. Et d'ailleurs, c'est
l'époque où il y a une convention pour
réduire les armes euh létales et il y a
une une balle qui s'appelle les balles
douomdomm. C'est des balles qui
explosent à l'intérieur du corps et donc
les puissances euh européennes se
réunissent pour la bannir. Donc il ils
bannissent à l'exception de la chasse et
des colonies. Voilà. Et ça c'est
aujourd'hui c'est ça, c'est-à-dire que
le droit international oui, mais on peut
pas l'appliquer quand il s'agit des
Palestiniens ou quand il s'agit de
d'autres d'autres conflits où c'est pas
des Européens ou des Blancs qui sont qui
sont en cause.
Est-ce que je peux te poser une question
? Est-ce que tu vois aussi une autre
instrumentalisation du droit
international pour les faire euh ennuyer
des concurrents commerciaux ? C'est ce
que tu dis voilà le droit international
on va leur apporter la démocratie pour
les petites filles, on va leur apporter
tout ça mais en fin de compte on veut
leur apporter tout ça parce qu'ils
voulaient trader leur pétrole en euros
ou en autre chose que en dollar.
Est-ce que est-ce que tu vois une petite
instrumentalisation du droit
international ?
Bien sûr notamment enfin
double standard tout ce qui va bien.
Oui oui bien sûr. C'estàd que mais c'est
pas forcément c'estàd l'intervention de
le de enfin des États-Unis en
Afghanistan. Bon, les enjeux économiques
sont relativement limités. Les enjeux,
c'est parce que tu connais rien la
géopolitique.
Non, non. Oui.
Les euh après, il y a il va y avoir
l'Irak avec les questions du pétrole et
cetera et cetera. Donc ça ça peut être
instrumentalise
une domination. C'estàd ce que les
Américains ont voulu prouver en
Afghanistan et en et en Irak, c'est
qu'ils étaient les maîtres du monde et
de
Ils ont pris une branlée en Afghanistan,
ils ont pris une branlée en Irak.
Ouais. Et la question c'est que c'estd
au durant le 19e siècle
globalement les puissance européennes
gagnait les guerres coloniales.
Bon
oui
la France a gagné une guerre il y a
combien de temps déjà ?
Non non non mais je veux dire ils ont
conquis l'Afrique euh ils ont euh les
Améri Britanniques ont conquis l'Inde et
cetera et cetera et quand il y avait des
révoltes les écrasait. C'était pas euh
voilà, je pour le proche Orient
après 1914, les Français et les
Britanniques se partagent de proche
Orient. Il y a eu des révoltes en Syrie,
en Irak et mais ça a été ça a été écrasé
et
ils ont découpé les frontières comme ils
voulaient, c'estàdire de manière assez
arbitraire en fonction de le leurs
propres intérêts et cetera. Aujourd'hui,
c'est plus imaginable en partie, je
pense parce que jusqu'à présent, en tous
les cas, il n'y a pas la détermination
en Europe ou en Occident de mener des
guerres. Euh on parlait des guerres zéro
morts. Le problème, c'est que pour mener
une guerre comme en Afghanistan, euh
ça se gagne pas par la technologie, on
l'a vu, c'està dire il y avait pas de
moins de technologique je dirais que les
que les talibans ils ont gagné. Donc
voilà, je on peut pas je crois pas que
les les occidentaux à moins de d'un
changement radical des mentalités et
cetera, puissent s'engager dans une
reconquête du monde. Et
bon courage, euh euh il y a une petite
année, on a reçu un général français
brillantissime,
le général Didier Castre. Ça vous parle
pas ?
Si, ça on l'a reçu pendant 2h30. On a on
a bien discuté parce qu'on avait quelque
chose à discuter et il nous a parlé de
quelque chose qui s'appelle
l'arithmétique de la rébellion. Est-ce
que ça vous parle ? Alors il nous
expliqué. dit voilà moi quand je vais
chercher un terroriste, quand je vais
lui envoyer ma bombe
h
si j'ai mon terroriste, c'est bien mais
si j'ai quatre cinq membres de sa
famille en même temps qu' rien à voir
euh euh les quatre cinq membres de
famille's ont peut-être de la famille et
puis ça va faire des petits et puis euh
dans 10 ans, je vais avoir cinq fois
plus de terroristes.
Donc quand il faut aller bombarder
quelque chose, nous français, on fait
extrêmement gaffe parce que derrière on
va en assumer les conséquences à 10 15
ans. Donc il faut faire attention.
ce qui se passe à Gaza avec le tapis de
bombe à l'américaine du nord jusqu'au
sud puis on laisse descendre on les
laisse descendre pour bien les
concentrer au sud de la frontière
il y a forcément des innocents qui ont
été pris là-dedans qui ont rien à voir
avec le Hamas qui ont rien à voir avec x
mouvement politique qui demandent
simplement à faire manger leurs enfants,
à éduquer leurs enfants, aller faire
leur marcher tranquillement et puis
essayer de partir en vacances quand on
peut partir en vacances.
Bon pour Gaza, c'est compliqué.
Euh à votre avis, à 5 et 10 ans, avec
l'arithmétique de la rébellion qui a été
euh
sous-évalué dans la bande de Gaza, les
répercussions dans le monde arabe et à
Gaza même,
ça va être quoi ? Ça va être une future
légion de djihadisme pour se venger de
ce qui s'est passé. Ça va être une une
haine mondialisée du juif à cause de la
politique du rouleau compresseur du Lou.
Ça va être ça va être quoi votre avis ?
Vous sentez quoi ? Quand je discute avec
mes copains juifs ou mes copains
musulmans,
les juifs commencent à se terrer parce
que ils enlèvent leur nom de leur boîes
aux lettres parce qu'ils ont peur de se
faire ennuyer. Mes potes musulmans, on
marre parce que dès qu'on les regarde,
on les traite d'antisémite alors qu'ils
ont rien demandé à personne.
Vous vous sentez comment mis à part les
dégradations du droit international où
clairement le tier monde vient de
comprendre que ça servait pas à
grandchose sauf pour les intérêts
occidentaux
à court moyen, long terme les
répercussions, l'irradiation de ça, ça
va être quoi ? Ça va être la paix ou ça
va être encore plus de démons encore
plus radicalisés ?
Je pense pas un instant que la paix
puisse sortir de ce tas de ruines à la
fois euh moral et matérielle. C'est il y
a que de l'horreur qui peut sortir de
cette horreur. C'est il y a alors quelle
horreur ? Je ne sais pas mais elle peut
s'appeler en effet haine anti-juive.
Nous n'oublions pas que Jérusalem se
présente enfin est présenté par les
autorités israéliennes comme la capitale
du peuple juif. La capitale unique,
éternelle et indivisible du peuple juif.
Telle est la formule consacrée.
Donc moi, puisque je suis d'origine
juive, ma capitale c'est pas Paris,
c'est Jérusalem. Ou en tout cas en plus
de Paris, c'est là-bas.
Oui. Alors en plus,
disons que dans mon cas, ce serait un
peu plus défendable mais dans bien
d'autres cas, non, ça ne l''est pas du
tout. Israël
c'est l'état du c'est l'état du peuple
juif, le premier ministre est le premier
ministre du peuple juif. Ça va même
d'ailleurs jusqu'à euh ça ça va loin.
Une fois euh Trump alors président
s'adressant à des juifs républicains de
euh Floride. Il y a pas tellement de
gens, il y a pas tellement de juifs
républicains aux États-Unis sont quand
même surtout démocrates. Mais là, il
avait une belle brassée d'extrémistes
devant lui. Et bien, il les il s'est
adressé à eux en parlant de leur premier
ministre Benjamin Netaniau.
Ils c'était des Américains purgus euh
qui étaient là en train d'écouter leur
président leur président à eux et qui se
voient renvoy qui se voyaient renvoyer
euh un un statut d'Israélien. Il y a une
telle intériorisation
de cette idée que Israël, les juifs,
c'est une seule et même chose qui est un
succès de la diplomatie israélienne qui
est un qui a été pensé comme tel.
C'était un un objectif. Et d'ailleurs
Alain rappelait
rappelait le le le tournant du 11
septembre et disons de du nouveau
millénaire avec les attentats. On peut
dire que que ce tournant il est marqué
par le fait que la question
palestinienne disparaît. Israël devient
une des un des un des fronts de la lutte
anti terroriste et donc est à la fois
l'état juif en général qui implique tous
les juifs du monde et l'état occidental,
libéral, démocratique qui se bat au côté
d'autres états du même ordre contre la
barbarie obscurantiste et extrémiste et
cetera et cetera. Donc, mais je bon
pardon, j'ai fait un petit retour en
arrière alors que c'était une marche
avant que tu demandais.
Moi, j'ai j'en ai j'en ai une vision
extrêmement sombre. Je pense que Israël
met en danger les juifs du monde entier,
y compris ceux qui le critiquent parce
que à un certain moment,
on ne fait plus on ne fait plus de on ne
fait plus de quartier. Juste imaginer ce
que c'est.
Attends, attends, attends, laisse-le
terminer. Oui, oui, pardon, excuse-moi.
Moi, je me sens menacé par la politique
euh israélienne, personnellement et je
connais des tas de gens euh dans mon cas
euh
et le le fossé nord-sud, le l'abîme
entre Israël et ses voisins, pas
forcément les États, les États les États
arabes du proche Orient, s'accommode
fort bien de quelques milliers ou
dizaines de milliers de morts
palestiniens. Ils n'en ont pas
grand-chose à faire. Mais les
populations, les sociétés de ces pays et
les États même autoritaires, même
dictatoriaux ne peuvent pas être
totalement en opposition avec leur
société. fatalement pour ça que la
Turquie hospitalise des gens du Hamas
et surtout qu'elle a coupé les relations
commerciales avec Israël avec alors
qu'elle les avait maintenu pendant très
longtemps. Donc c'est c'est tout récent
qu' les a qu' les sontu.
Bref, je vois un avenir de de cendre de
noirceur. Enfin, c'est c'est c'est
épouvantable. C'est épouvantable.
Ain, comment tu vois l'avenir ?
Bah, je le vois pas très bien, juste sur
le l'aspect intérieur français.
Ça parce que tu es vieux.
Oui, peut-être.
G je suis quelqu'un de fondamentalement
optimiste. D'ailleurs, je m'occuperai
pas de la question palestinienne depuis
50 ans si j'avais pas quand même une
dose d'optimisme en moi. Parce que
ça c'est parce que tu es juif.
Ah c'est possible. Oui oui, c'est
mais euh moi j'ai comme j'ai dit d'abord
je suis inquiet sur la France,
c'est-à-dire la position unilatérale du
gouvernement français fait que on crée
un fossé entre les populations notamment
musulmanes. On imagine un instant
qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est-ce que ça
fait d'avoir des soldats
franco-israéliens qui participent à Gaza
et qui vont revenir ici tranquillement
et après on va s'étonner qu'il y a des
incidents. Mais attends, je veux dire
c'est c'est des gens qui ont peut-être
participé à des crimes de guerre, je
veux dire. Bon, donc il y a ce faussé et
peut-être moi ce que je regrette, je
suis pas un nostalgique du gaulisme,
j'ai passé mon enfance à combattre la
politique du général de Gaulle. Mais
personne n'est parfait, hein.
Non, personne n'est parfait. Euh, il fut
un temps où la France, justement, tout
en restant dans le camp occidental et
dans le camp euh à l'époque face au
pacte de Varseville faisait entendre une
autre voix.
C'est-à-dire la France s'est battue. Je
dis euh quand la France a obtenu que
l'Europe dise il faut ouvrir le dialogue
avec l'organisation de libération de la
Palestine en 1980, les Américains
considéraient l'OLP comme une
organisation terroriste et les
Israéliens aussi. Et le premier ministre
de l'époque, Benahim Megin, a dit "Vous
voulez nous faire
discuter avec les héritiers de Hitler."
Donc la France a eu le courage de faire
ça. Elle a eu le courage de se battre
pour le droit à l'autodétermination des
Palestiniens. Bien que ça peut c'est
dire de de Gaulle à à Mitérin à Chirak,
ils étaient pas anti-israélien. Je dis
il m'était pas ni tout en cause le droit
d'Israël existant. Mais ça faisait
entendre une voix différente justement
euh qui refusait le manikéisme. Et
aujourd'hui on est vraiment dans le
manikéisme. Et ça c'est moi je trouve ça
très très effrayant pour l'avenir de de
la de la planète quoi. Et donc c'est
pour ça ce qui joue pour moi la
Palestine, il y a quelque chose qui se
joue et peut-être pour donner de
l'optimisme quand même euh je dis dans
ma génération on a connu trois grandes
mobilisations internationales. C'est qui
ont qui dépassait les conflits locaux.
C'est le Vietnam.
Si ça ?
Et oui,
le Vietnam,
le l'Afrique du Sud et aujourd'hui la
Palestine. Et c'est intéressant de voir
ce qui se passe aux États-Unis parce
qu'aux États-Unis, il y a une
mobilisation sans précédent depuis le
Vietnam mais alors que les les étudiants
américains ils vont pas, c'estàd quand
ils se battaient contre la guerre de du
Vietnam en grande partie c'est parce
qu'ils voulaient pas aller se battre
là-bas qu' ils allaient être obligés.
là, ils le font pour des raisons morales
et politiques. Donc ça, c'est
effectivement quelque chose de euh qui
porte de l'espoir justement de sortir du
manikéisme et euh d'aller vers euh un
enfin un monde plus juste, si on peut
dire.
Comment tuexpliques ça que les jeunes
que ce soit aux États-Unis ou en France
soient beaucoup plus euh euh engagés ?
C'est parce qu'ils sont sur les réseaux
sociaux, ils ont accès à ces vidéos, ils
voient des pauvres gamins aplatis. Je
suis étonné de de voir les gens euh
quand il y a une mobilisation des jeunes
la discréditer, c'est-à-dire d'un côté
de temps en temps, on va dire "Ah, ils
sont toujours sur les réseaux sociaux,
ils s'intéressent à rien et cetera."
quand il y a une cause qui est qui est
une cause morale et politique sur
lesquelles ils se mobilisent, tout de
suite on on les on les accuse. Moi, je
pense que le le enfin je dire les
qualités de la jeunesse en général,
c'est justement cette euh
enfin ce dévouement, ce ce enfin cet
idéalisme, cette utopie et cetera, je
trouve que ça plutôt positif. En plus,
parce que justement euh cette jeunesse
américaine montre que le clivage, il est
pas un clivage euh Occident reste du
monde. Qu' a des gens en Occident qui
sont porteurs aussi de ce de ce discours
universel et qui parlent, il faut les
entendre parler. C'est pas moi j'ai
participé aux mobilisation sur le le
Vietnam, on faisait pas on se mobilise
pas pour le Vietnam au nom du droit
international. se mobiliser au nom de la
lutte de la lutte armée de de choses et
aujourd'hui ils se mobilisent au nom du
droit international et ils utilisent le
droit international et la cour
internationale de justice c'est pour moi
c'est un petit signe d'espoir en plus il
faut rappeler que la cour internationale
de justice qui a pris cette décision
elle a été présidée par une juge
américaine et qui a eu pratiquement
l'unanimité de toutes tous ces juges qui
étaient qui venaient de pays différents.
Là, il y a un tout petit espoir et je
trouve que
il faut se réjouir que la jeunesse soit
euh dans ce courant là.
Alain, tu es pas si vieux que ça dans ta
tête, hein.
On se fait un petit peu de prospective.
Euh, j'aimerais avant avant qu'on parle
euh du fait qu'il y a des journalistes
qui se font tués à Gaza. Il y en a eu
combien là ? 100 140 ? Oui. Euh entre
100 et 140 selon les estimations. Euh
j'aimerais qu'on parle aussi des des euh
des ONG qui sont aussi ciblées.
Euh euh j'aimerais aussi qu'on parle euh
bon commençons par ça et ensuite on va
faire un peu de prospective. Moi, je
parle des journalistes.
Bon, d'abord euh comme je l'ai dit au
début,
la politique israélienne, c'est pas
d'image, pas d'information qui viennent
de Gaza. Donc on c'est pas seulement
c'est on ne permet pas d'abord aux
journalistes étrangers de s'y rendre
mais c'est c'estàdire c'est une volonté
de cacher ce qu'ils font, hein. C'est
pas
tuas tu es journaliste toi. Quand on
t'interdit d'aller dans un coin, tu
rentres par la fenêtre, tu rentres par
la porte, tu rentres par les égouts.
Pour l'instant, je n'ai pas vu beaucoup
de gens qui sont rentrés par la par la
porte
aussi parce que enfin si on n'est pas si
on est journaliste avec un journal, il y
a aucun journal qui va vous autoriser à
aller à Gaza et des années pendant j'en
ai pas vu mais à la limite les le il y
avait des c'estàd les images sont venues
de Gaza mais là on est on est rentré
dans quelque chose de nouveau. C'est
dire enfin pas de nouveau, c'est en gros
quand les journalistes israéliens disent
quelque chose alors qu'ils sont soumis à
la censure et qu'ils partagent
l'idéologie de leur gouvernement, c'est
pas béni. Mais dès que c'est un
journaliste euh palestinien, on va dire
"Ah mais est-ce que c'est c'est des
c'est quelqu'un du Hamas, c'est des
Arabes, c'est pas c'est pas fiable et
cetera et cetera." Mais toutes les
images qu'on a eu, c'est grâce à eux.
C'estàd et on a eu comme a dit la la
l'avocate qui défendait le l'Afrique du
Sud à la cour à la Cour internationale
de justice. C'est la première fois dans
l'histoire qu'on vit un génocide en
direct filmé par ses victimes. C'estd le
Rwanda.
On a mis très longtemps à réaliser les
opinions publiques. Il y avait pas il y
avait pas toutes ces images et cetera.
Là, on a vraiment toutes les jeux dire
tous les jours, on a des images. Alors
bon, on peut dire il y a certaines qui
sont fausses sans doute c'est vrai.
Certaines informations qui sont données
qui sont pas mais la seule manière de
savoir c'est de permettre euh je vais
laisser la parole à à Ren sur les ONG,
mais de permettre à à des observateurs
extérieurs. Il y a des risques. Oui,
mais ça c'est le problème des
journalistes. Ils sont prêts à prendre
des risques et c'est la même chose que
les ONG, elles prennent aussi beaucoup
de risques. Mais il y a une volonté de
faire un un massacre à H clos je crois.
Et pourquoi le Attends, je te donne la
parole après. R et pourquoi il y a pas
eu une une force d'interposition genre
des casques bleus ou des choses comme ça
? parce que les Américains bloquent,
c'est les Américains ont donné le feu
vert aux Israéliens depuis le problème,
c'est que le Conseil de sécurité est
paralysé par les Israéliens, par les
Américains. Donc je veux dire le outre
le fait qu'il aurait été enfin envoyer
des casques bleus sans accord israélien
était difficile parce que ça veut dire
que les casques bleus entrent en
confrontation avec Israël. Mais le véau
américain est ce qui sauve le c'est ce
qui sauve c'est pas seulement l'aide euh
militaire américaine, c'est un une
protection politique et diplomatique qui
est donnée à l'État d'Israël. Donc euh
il y a aucune chance que le les Nations
Unies puissent euh euh
agir de manière concrète pour arrêter
les combats. Alors que
vous savez, on a parlé du droit à la
légitime défense d'Israël.
Vous pouvez me tutoyer alors ? Oui. Oui.
Non non.
Euh
normalement alors c'est prévu l'article
51 je crois de la charte des Z qui
provient qui prévoit le droit à à la
légitime défense. Mais il y a deux
problèmes. Un c'est que Gaza étant un
territoire occupé. Israël ne peut pas
considérer ça comme une agression
extérieure comme si c'était un un pays
extérieur. Et deuxièmement, même s'il y
a un droit
dans d'autres circonstances à la
légitime défense, c'est pas
euh euh
sans main pour une main. C'est pas euh
c'est pas comment dire
une
une carte blanche ou massacre à grande
échelle. C'est le fait que c'est même en
période de légitime des forces, on est
tenu par les lois de la guerre. et que
Israël ne respecte pas que le pas
respecté non plus.
Non non mais bien sûr.
Ren
les ONG sur le terrain, comment ça se
passe ?
Oui, juste une petite remarque sur les
casques bleus. Les casques bleus à
l'origine ont été créés dans le
l'histoire Israëlo-Arabe, hein. Euh
année après année, les postes qu'ils
occupaient pour surveiller la la
stabilité des frontières ont été
déplacés au gré de l'avancée des
frontières israéliennes. Il y a
d'ailleurs un parcours qu'on peut faire
à Jérusalem où on suit les différents
postes et il y a une sorte de d'histoire
inscrite dans la pierre comme ça où on
voit les relicas parce qu'il reste des
drapeaux des Nations Unies sur ces
endroits. Donc vraiment l'impuissance
des casques bleus dans une telle
situation, elle est totale.
On peut pas attendre d'eux quelque chose
qu'ils n'ont pas en poche quoi. Ils ne
peuvent pas apporter la paix, la calmie.
Ils peuvent suivre une paix, la la
conforter, la pardon, la la solidifier
un petit peu lorsqu'elle est déjà en
cours, ils ne peuvent pas la fabriquer.
Toutes les opérations d'imposition de ou
de supposé imposition de la paix ont été
des échecs lamentables. Pas toutes les
opérations de casque bleu, il y en a qui
ont été réussis, mais les opérations
d'imposition de la paix, oui.
Maintenant
pour les ONG, les ONG enfin des ONG euh
sont autorisé à travailler. Médecin SV,
médecin du monde, handicap
international,
euh solidarité, je crois. Bon euh
quelques-unes mais c'est évidemment à
leur risques et périls. Elle travaille
sous disons la coordination supposée ou
en tout cas en échange d'information
avec un organisme militaire israélien
basé à Teléviv qui s'appelle le Kogat
qui est le comité de coordination dans
les dans les territoires administrés.
Le Cogat qui se présente comme une
assistance civile dirigée par un
colonel. Ça c'est un peu comme
l'administration civile d'ailleurs de la
SJ Jordanie qui est dirigée par des
militaires.
Ça c'est la no langue du pouvoir en
général hein. C'est pas spécifique à
Israël.
Mais donc ce Colgat nous donne les non
pas les garanties mais disons quelques
assurance que quand on déclare notre un
déplacement qu'on signale un véhicule
avec plaque d'immatriculation
signalisation très clair drapeaux logo
et cetera à poser sur les voitures,
heure de circulation lieu de de
destination et cetera. enfin tout un
ensemble d'informations relatives au
déplacement, on est théoriquement
inattaquable. Enfin, on a une sorte de
promesse d'immunité
face à l'armée israélienne. La réalité
euh est tout autre. médecin frontière a
eu cinq morts de d'un certain nombre de
de véhicules blessés, deux lieux de de
d'abri euh totalement hors zone de
combat théoriquement qui ont été
attaqués par des missiles. Euh la World
Central Kitchen qui est une une ONG
américaine fondée par un chef cuisinier
qui a ses entrées à la Maison Blanche.
quelqu'un qui a euh disons enfin qui est
proche des cercles du pouvoir y compris
cercle de pouvoir israélien. Vo central
kitchen
a perdu cinq membres 5 ou sept je ne
sais plus qui ont leurs âmes
qui ont été
attaqués dans trois véhicules successifs
donc avec trois missiles distincts donc
des une attaque coordonnée répétée alors
que ils étaient là simplement pour
distribuer c'est son pour distribuer de
la farine des des vivres des aliments de
base. Ils ont peut-être été mal
reconnus, mal identifiés, c'est
peut-être une fause. Non,
non, c'est pas Non, non, c'est pas
possible. C'est c'est vraiment pas
possible. Il il pouvait pas être mal
identifié alors que l'identification,
c'est eux qui l'avaient donné. Ils
avaient donné, ils étaient sur les lieux
qui étaient prévus, qui avaient été
annoncés. Leur véhicules, les les
plaques d'immatrication de leur
véhicules et la signalisation de leur
véhicules avaient été envoyé au Cogat.
Non non, c'est à l'intérieur de l'armée.
Il y a je pense qu' il y a une culture
militaire
en Israël qui provient de ça. Il y a il
y a
ton service militaire toi en Israël ?
Non.
Alain ?
Non. Non.
Il y a il y a une pas de raison. Vous
dirait plus mais
il y a une brutalisation de la société
israélienne dont les techniques, les
méthodes de guerre sont aussi une
expression. Regarde quand trois otages
israéliens avaient réussi, je reviens
aux ONG après, mais ça me semble
important de de rappeler ça, quand trois
otages israéliens avaient réussi à à
s'évader et se présente face à une
patrouille israélienne à à Gaza, il y a
de ça 3 mois, euh se présente face à une
patrouille israélienne
torenue, les mains en l'air en criant
"Je suis juif, je suis israélien." Tirez
pas, la première chose qu'ils ont faite,
c'est les descendre. Ils les ont abattus
comme des chiens tous les trois parce
que il y a il y a pas d'espace entre ami
ou ennemi dans le
Vous avez entendu un truc qui s'appelle
la doctrine animale.
Oui, bien sûr. Bien sûr.
C'est quoi la doctrine animale ?
La doctrine animale, ça c'est un une
doctrine de traitement des otages euh
des otages des prisonniers parce qu'il
s'agit essentiellement de de prisonniers
captur enfin de soldats militaires en
opération euh capturés.
Non non, moi je fais une distinction
entre otages et prisonniers.
Israël détient des otages et des
prisonniers. Le Hamas détient des otages
et des prisonniers. Des deux côtés, il y
a des otages. Disons pour l'essentiel
les les civils, ce sont des otages et
les et les militaires, ce sont des pris
les militaires détenus, ce sont des
prisonniers.
Ça veut dire que tu reconnais le Hamas
comme une force militaire.
Bah de fait, moi je
pas comme un mouvement terroriste.
Non, non, bien sûr, bien sûr. Non, non,
non. Absolument. Moi je je pense qu'il y
a des actes terroristes, mais mouvement
terroriste, ça ne veut rien dire pour
moi. Il y a pas de définition possible,
il y a pas il y a pas de consensus,
c'est un usage purement opportuniste
de d'intérêt politique du moment, c'est
tout. Donc euh
ils ont abattu donc ces alors là en
l'occurrence je pense deux véritables
otages qui ont été tués. Donc Walk
Kitchen s'est trouvé dans une situation
probablement euh analogue par euh ciblé
par un hélico ou un char euh des
plaintes qui ont été euh mises contre
Israël. Euh ça a été déposé quelque
part.
Je sais pas, je ne sais pas. Je ne sais
pas. Logiquement, il devrait y avoir ne
serait-ce que pour obtenir réparation
mais bon compte tenu du fait que le
patron de cette ONG est un proche de Joe
Biden et que
ça c'est des supputations.
Oui oui tout à fait tout à fait.
Comment
il est un proche de Joe Biden ? C'est
pas je te vois venir sur le fait que
que oui peut-être qu'il voudrait
arrondir les angles enfin éviter
tout sujet qui fâche ça. En effet c'est
c'est spéculatif. Je je ne sais je ne
sais pas du tout. Donc, j'en reviens aux
ONG. Elles font euh un travail
intermittent, extrêmement risqué, avec
des déplacements constants. Elle
travaille, là, je parle par exemple pour
médecin sans frontière que je connais
évidemment beaucoup mieux que les autres
travaillent avec d'importantes équipes
palestiniennes. En gros, pour une
vingtaine d'expatriés, on a 300
employés locaux qui se qui vont depuis
chauffeur, ambulanciers jusqu'à
chirurgien, anesthésiste et tout. car il
faut tout de même avec cette propagande
sur Gaza, on peut le perdre de vue, il
faut tout de même se rappeler que à
Gaza,
Gaza c'est une société relativement
moderne. Euh vous avez des gens en
dialyse
en dialyse rénale, vous avez des
maladies chroniques traitées, vous avez
des interventions de chirurgie
cardio-vasculaire ou de chirurgie
neurologique. Enfin, vous avez des gens
extrêmement qualifiés avec des
installations, des scanners, des
laboratoires qui fonctionnent. Enfin, ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas un village perdu
au fin fond de la forêt, même surpeuplé.
C'est une c'est une société qui a un
développement important. Donc, nos
équipes palestiniennes, elles tiennent
un grand rôle là-dedans.
Mais il y a un scanner pour combien de
personnes ? C'est des scanners qui
viennent des États-Unis pour se donner
bonne conscience. pas certainement pas
suffisamment de scanner bien entendu
d'ailleurs il y en a pas suffisamment en
France non plus ou pas suffisamment
jamais se comparer au dernier de la cr
de la classe
ou je veux dire le pas assez c'est aussi
le fait qu'il y en a et qu'il y a des
gens qui s'en servent qui savent les
faire fonctionner
et ainsi de suite. Donc non c'est c'est
important pour arriver à à resituer
aussi le ressentiment des gens sur
place. Bref, nos équipes
font un travail intermittent. Quand je
dis nos équipes, c'est Palestiniens et
expatrié mélangé font un travail
intermittent euh qui parfois qui est
souvent interrompu par des problèmes de
sécurité. Il faut aller se planquer, on
peut pas aller à l'hôpital. Et en plus,
bon, MSF a a l'habitude de fournir à ses
équipes du matériel en quantité, du
matériel jetable, du matériel
consommable, du matériel durable. Donc
on arrive avec nos instruments de
chirurgie, nos nos anesthésiques, mais
c'est vite épuisé. Normalement, il y a
des stocks locaux qui permettent de se
de se renouveler. Heureusement, nous
avions un stock qui était inentamé au 7
octobre et dans lequel nous avons pu
pomper. Mais enfin, ça n'a pas ça n'a
pas suffi. Ça a permis de durer un peu
plus. Donc les interventions sans
anesthésie dont tu parlais tout à
l'heure ou avec une anesthésie
partielle, les antibiotiques
insuffisants qui permettent pas un
traitement préventif des des infections
et cetera, c'est absolument monnaie
courante. Et bon, opérer sans la par
exemple le curar qui provoque une
paralysie des muscles qui permet un
minimum de confort chirurgical. Là vous
sans curar, il y a des contractures,
c'est extrêmement difficile, ça ça
complique encore un peu plus
l'opération. Bref, ce sont des
conditions de travail indécentes. Ce
sont toujours minimalistes avec
puis les conditions pour le patient
aussi.
Je vais te dire toi tu es tout bib,
c'est dur.
Oui,
mais pour le patient
pour le patient c'est affreux. Pour le
patient c'est absolument affreux
naturellement. et encore le patient qui
arrive à se faire soigner parce qu'il y
a tous les patients qui n'arrivent qui
ne sont pas des patients qui sont juste
des blessés ou des malades.
Les médecins de MSF quand ils reviennent
euh en France, ils ont un suivi
psychologique. Le fait d'avoir été
exposé à des plaies de guerre, à des
souffrances sur des jeunes gamins, au
fait qu'ils aient été obligés de
pratiquer des
on propose, on leur propose certains le
prê
chirurgicaux, sans curard, sans nuin,
sans ce que tu veux. C'est proposé, ils
arrivent dans quel état psychologique et
et quand ils essayent de parler de ce
qu'il voit sur place, quel effet ça fait
?
Bah c'est sais quoi. C'est c'est
extrêmement éprouvant et oui un certain
nombre mais le disons la la la la la la
la politique de MSF en la matière est de
proposer sans disposer. C'estàdire euh
il s'agit pas de comment dire de faire
d'étendre une sorte d'aile protectrice
sur nos membres dans le casadre d'une
institution un peu totalisante.
Tout il y a il y a des tas de gens très
compétents en France qui peuvent
s'occuper des des gens qui ont besoin
d'un soutien psychothérapeutique ou
psychologique à leur retour. Il y a des
groupes de paroles mais qui sont pas
très fréquentés.
Donc c'est c'est laissé à l'entière
disposition, à l'entière liberté des des
volontaires de MSF. Mais sur les
humanitaires, je voulais ajouter quelque
chose qui me semble extrêmement
important qui est le problème de l'UNRA.
L'UNRA donc c'est l'Organisation des
Nations Unies chargé du secours aux
réfugiés palestiniens. C'est la seule
organisation qui a une population
spécifique
sous son aile, enfin dans son dans son
mandat.
Les autres ont des thèmes ou des aires
géographiques mais pas une population
spécifique.
L'UNRA est en permanence l'objet
d'attaque, de critique de
fonder ou pas fondé.
Non, on sait maintenant que c'est faux.
C'est pas que fonder ou ne pas fondé.
Quelles étaient quelles étaient les
rumeurs et les critiques qui étaient
envoyées ?
Que 10 % des 10 % des membres du de Luna
étaient membres du RAM. c'est que nombre
d'entre eux 10 % il y avait 13000 euh
travailleurs de l'unera à à Gaza. Je dis
ça c'est c'est important. Une on c'est
quelques dizaines de personnes. Lunera
c'est 13000 personnes rien que à Gaza
c'est 60000 personnes dans les
différents camps parce qu'il travaillent
dans de nombreux camps notamment au
Liban Jordanie en Syrie et cetera. Donc
c'est une organisation extrêmement
importante pour qui enfin le le le le
salut d'une bonne partie de la
population réfugié palestinienne dépend
de la capacité opératoire des capacités
opérationnelles pardon de Lunera. Or
Lunera est sous attaque constante. Ça ne
date pas du de cette période-ci hein.
C'est c'est bien avant parce que l'un
s'occupe des réfugiés palestiniens qui
sont disons le comme l'ont dit des
historiens le péché originel d'Israël.
L'acte fondateur, c'est l'expulsion de
800000 de Palestiniens. Donc ces gens
qui sont chargés de prendre en de de
s'occuper de la descendance de ces
800000 Palestiniens originels,
évidemment, ils sont le comme le une
sorte de mauvaise conscience
vivante face à Israël. Donc, il y a une
volonté de de les éliminer, de les
écarter. La question des réfugiés, du
retour des réfugiés en Israël Palestine
était une question ultra ultra sensible.
Mais là,
ça a été prouvé qu'il y avait rien
d'infiltré de Lun.
Oui. Oui. Oui. Oui. Bah, il commission
Colon.
La comm Colona a fait une mission
d'enquête. Alors, c'est le ministre des
affaires étrangères et puis tous les
pays qui avaient suspendu leur aide ont
repris parce qu'il y avait pas d'autres
solutions. Mais juste une une chose pour
bien comprendre c'estàdire la
spécificité de l'Audra par rapport il y
a le haut commissariat au réfugiés qui
s'occupe des réfugiés partout dans le
monde sauf les Palestiniens. Et quand
vous êtes réfugié
euh sous contrôle de du HR, vous êtes
réfugié et puis votre enfant n'est plus
réfugié. L'UNRA, c'est différent. L'UN
c'est une fois que vous êtes réfugié,
vos enfants et vos petits-enfants sont
réfugiés. Alors les Israéliens disent
"Mais c'est scandaleux ces gens qui sont
nés à l'étranger, ils ont rien à faire.
Pourquoi ils reviendraient en Palestine
?" Ce qui est extraordinaire, c'est que
ça vient d'un état qui dit "Les juifs
dans le monde qui vivent à 3000 km, ils
ont le droit de revenir n'importe
comment."
Ça s'appelle d'ailleurs
le droit retour.
Non, mais il y a un mot particulier,
l'Alia. Ils ont droit à l'allias et
comme j'ai dit, moi si je vais demain en
Israël, je peux obtenir la nationalité
israélienne euh si on est juif mais les
Palestiniens n'auraient pas le droit
alors que ils sont partis maximum il y a
50 ou 60 ans. Donc il y a une chose
absure. C'est vraiment politique le
l'attaque contre Lundra. C'est je pense
un des objectifs essentiels de politique
de d'Israël, c'était de détruire ça.
Mais pour l'instant, ils n'ont pas
réussi parce que il y a personne d'autre
comme Ren l'a dit de pour pour s'occuper
des Palestiniens. pas seulement le la
santé hein, c'est eux qui s'occupent de
toute l'éducation de donc de tous les
soins, de l'aide au je crois aussi de
l'aide au enfin il y a une aide sociale
enfin de c'est un truc indispensable
pour les mais c'est ça les Israéens on
rien à faire ce qu'il ce dont ils ont
peur c'est le symbole c'est-à-dire
qu'aujourd'hui il y a des statistiques
de l'honor je crois qu'on est à 7
millions de réfugiés donc ça reste une
menace même s'il est très potentiel pour
pour Israël. Je voulais rajouter une
petite chose sur les journalistes. Je
peux euh une des choses que
que du mal hein
hein. Non non
enfin euh un une des choses, il y a eu
100 ou 140 Palestiniens journalistes
tués. Euh moi ce qui me frappe c'est que
aucun
journal français occidental n'a utilisé
des journalistes. Nous sommes Orient 21,
le journal dont je m'occupe qui est
c'est pas une masse he c'est vraiment
des quelques personnes. On a depuis 3
mois un correspondant francophone
palestinien qui nous envoie trois
reportages par semaine sur la vie
quotidienne des Palestiniens.
Combien tu le payes et comment tu le
payes ? On a trouvé un moyen pour le
payer et on le paye mieux qu'on paye les
journalistes français.
C'est combien ?
Euh je crois qu'on a écoute je crois que
c'est 600 € par mois
pour trois reportages
pour Non c'est pas trois reportages.
C'est tr
c'est 600 € par reportage.
Non par non. Qu'est-ce que vous êtes
radien Orient 21 ? Orient 21, c'est
gratuit et ça vit de
euh euh ça vit de la souscription de ces
de ces lecteurs.
Tu feras plaisir, tu rajouteras quand
même 100 € hein.
D'accord. D'accord. D'accord.
Mais euh Non, mais c'est très
intéressant parce qu'on a des choses de
la vie quotidienne qu'on ne voit pas. Tu
parlais de comment les gens il a il a
son fils de 4 ans, donc qu'est-ce que
c'est vivre sous les bombardements ? Et
il dit maintenant quand il y a des
bombardements, j'applaudis
et mon fils a pris ça pour un jeu. Et
c'est la manière dont il arrive à à
surmonter son angoisse.
Qu'est-ce que c'est horrible !
C'est horrible. Et ça rejoint ce que
disait Rony. C'est-à-dire que les
Palestiniens, c'est des nombres. Les
Israéliens, ils ont tous des visages,
des familles et cetera. Les
Palestiniens, jamais. Et ça c'est mais
il y a aussi au-delà l'idée de la presse
occidentale, c'est que quand c'est des
Palestiniens qui l'écrivent, on n'est
pas vraiment sûr. Alors que quand c'est
des Israéliens qui le disent, oui, ça on
peut compter. Et on enfin la presse
française utilise beaucoup des des
Israéliens ou des binationaux sans sans
aucun problème.
Quel quel regard tu portes sur le
traitement médiatique français
que j'ai jamais vécu ? Enfin, comme tu
as souligné à plusieurs reprises mon
âge.
Tu étais très très jeune
depuis Moi, j'ai suivi
Fais pas tes 34 ans d'ailleurs.
Ça ça fatigue un peu quand même les
reportages de guerre.
J'ai suivi non mais je suis pas
tellement reportage mais j'ai suivi le
conflit depuis 67 c'estàdire vraiment
j'avais
18 ans donc et j'étais j'étais
conscient. Jamais je n'ai vécu une
période euh même en 67 où les médias
étaient massivement proisraélien.
Vraiment euh il y avait au moins de
Gaulle d'abord qui avaient une position
différente et un parti communiste qui à
l'époque était fort et qui avait une
autre position et donc il y avait un
tout petit peu de débat. Puis petit à
petit, il faut dire bon notamment avec
la première, le siège de Beoute en 82 et
cetera, la presse a commencer à changer
et à donner un traitement plus
équilibré. Et puis depuis une quinzaine
d'années, ça a basculé pour une raison
enfin moi je l'interprète comme ça.
Désormais la presse et les politiques
français, la plupart des politiques ne
voi pas ça comme un problème d'un peuple
qui vit sous occupation. il voit le
Israël Palestine comme un des fronts de
la guerre contre le terrorisme et que
donc ça biaise complètement le et on a
eu pendant des semaines des espèces
d'injonction est-ce que le Hamas c'est
une organisation terroriste ou non ?
comme si c'est comme si c'était quelque
chose qui permettait d'expliquer quoi
que ce soit. Bah dès qu'on commençait à
dire "Vous savez le 6 octobre c'était
pas si bien que ça ce qui se passait de
ça." Vous étiez accusé d'être et ce qui
est nouveau c'est que jamais on a eu
autant d'inculpation de gens pour
apologie contre le terrorisme qui il
faut rappeler est une mesure prise par
sous la présidence de François Hollande
et je veux dire qui permet de de je veux
dire on sait qu'est-ce que c'est
l'apologie de de c'est dire moi qui a
essayé de vous expliquer pourquoi le 7
octobre et quelle était la stratégie
militaire du Hamas euh je peux très bien
être accusé de d'avoir voulu justifier
le le Hamas de justifier les les
massacres. Le terrorisme, c'est vra
c'est pas ce que tu as voulu faire.
C'est pas ce que tu as voulu faire. tu
as essayé d'expliquer, de
recontextualiser les choses.
Oui, c'est simplement de et puis
réellement cette je je suis persuadé que
cette utilisation de la guerre contre le
terrorisme est aujourd'hui quelque chose
de très inquiétant parce que justement
ça dépolitise totalement le problème. Si
comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure, si vous
luttez contre le terrorisme,
c'est-à-dire le mal, il y a pas de
solution politique, il y a il faut
éradiquer le mal. Bonjour les dégâts. Je
sais pas quand quand on est radicale
mais à mon avis c'est pas demain. Et
donc on est dans une guerre sans fin et
je dire malheureusement je dire
aujourd'hui et c'est terrible pour moi
génération qui finalement a vécu a
grandi sans guerre en Europe. Je veux
dire
vous êtes bien fendu la poire quand même
vous les dividend de la paye il y avait
pas le sida.
On a une retraite
c'est bitnick encore. C'est ça. Tuas
tuas en plus ta retraite qu'on paye.
Oui oui là
pardon. Oui, après
tu as pas trop de pathologie chronique,
ça va. Tu ne coûtes pas trop cher. Bon,
ça va alors ?
Non, non, non, mais j'ai j'ai créé 21
mon journal avec une série de
journalistes qui comme moi étaient à la
retraite, qui avaient pas besoin de de
revenus et qui donc pouvaient travailler
bénévolement pour développer un un
journal en ligne, sinon on aurait jamais
pu. Donc, je plains les générations
suivantes qui n'auront pas ce privilège
que nous avons. Ron, tu veux rebondir
sur le traitement médiatique ? Euh sinon
je pose d'autres questions.
Oui oui. Non non non je je je viens non
je je moi je
suis un grand consommateur euh si on
peut dire de d'information venant des
des médias pas seulement disons des des
médias traditionnel mais quand même
notamment de cela. Et je trouve que euh
plusieurs médias écrits font bien leur
travail au premier rang desquels moi je
mets le monde euh et notamment Clotil de
Bravco et Louis Hbert, les deux
correspondants dont j'admire énormément
le travail. C'est je et je pense que
c'est très important à préciser d'abord
parce qu'ils le font dans des conditions
extrêmement dures. Euh
aller à la pêche aux informations, c'est
là-bas, c'est extrêmement difficile.
Sous une pression sociale très très
violente,
sur une surveillance numérique très
violente.
Une Exactement. Donc c'est vraiment je
pense à à souligner et il en et il y en
a d'autres. Mais enfin bon, cela pour
moi il ils le ressortent. Donc disons,
il y a dans la presse écrite et je pour
dire que dans dans l'IB mais même dans
le Figaro que je lis je lis très
rarement donc j'ai moins de j'ai pas
d'idée très très fixe là-dessus mais
quelques titres que j'ai aperçu ou
quelques interviews que j'ai pu glaner
me laisse penser qu'il y a un traitement
disons un peu un traitement à la à la à
la à la golomiterandienne si si l'on
veut c'est-à-dire une certaine
disponibilité à écouter la voix
palestinienne euh un refus d'avoir une
une approche purement unilatérale. Ça
commence par là. Ensuite l'abondance des
détails, euh la description précise de
ce qui se passe, la mise en perspective
historique,
ça vient ailleurs et c'est évidemment
très très ravageur pour la partie
israélienne bien entendu. Et ce qui est
atérent, ce qui est accablant qui qui
donne parfois envie de vomir, ce sont
les plateaux télé des chaînes tout info
qui sont alors il y a il y a ces news à
un bout de
du spike. C'est c'est pharant sur sur
pour toi c'est pharant sur ces news et
c'est important que tu le disesou
mais que c'est ton point de vue et que
Ah bah oui oui. Non moi je suis l'élu de
je suis l'élu de personne. Je ne
représente personne d'autre que moi,
mais le j'ai parfois je suis parfois
pris de nausé en en regardant certains
débats où je vois de véritables appels
plus ou moins directs au meurtre quoi.
C'est ou en tout cas une justifie
fait référence à certains médias où on a
laissé parler les gens où ils appelaient
au meurtre à l'utilisation.
Oui oui. T4 News dont la la se disons la
la cousine de de BFM.
Il y a eu un rappel de l'ARCOM, il y a
eu des procédures engagées ou pas du
tout ? Je crois que for News est pas une
chaîne TNT il me semble. Donc ils
dépendent pas de ils dépendent pas de
leur conne. Donc toutes les toutes les
saletés qu'il qu'il profèrent sont de
leur propre ressort. Mais si
oui oui mais enfin comme ils sont pas
repris vous pouvez voir un type qui dit
faut faut tuer t tous les gazaoui
jusqu'au dernier. Faut pas faut
éterendre par le journaliste en face.
Non, il a il a il a il a les brecours ni
par le journaliste en face, ni par ni
par personne, ni par la justice alors
que on a quand même interdit peut-être à
juste titre, je ne sais pas, moi j'étais
plutôt mélangé, je suis plutôt partisan
de plus trop de liberté plutôt que que
pas assez. Enfin, on a interdit RT
France me semble-t-il quand même pour
moins que ça et c'est différent climat
de guerre machin. Ils ont pas de guerre
là-bas. Si
donc climat de guerre, il me semble que
il y a Algizzira qui a été interdite de
diffusion
en Israël. Les bureaux d'Algzira ont été
fermé. Lunera a attaqué incendier avec
le le maire adjoint de Jérusalem qui est
un type d'extrême droite et tout qui dit
bon c'est pas c'est pas la bonne méthode
mais c'est le bon objectif quoi. C'est
quand même ça. C'est ça qu'il faut
faire. Donc c'est une espèce
d'encouragement. Quel quel a été le
prétexte d'ailleurs pour faire interdire
Algészira ? Ça a été quoi ? C'est
propagande. Oui propagand procamas. Il
il y a un arcom là-bas. Il y avait une
licence qui était euh donnée, pas
donnée. Tu parles de RT France, ils
avaient le censure est officielle. La
censure est officiel en Israël hein. Les
articles qui paraissent sur les
territoires sur la guerre israéloisière
sont soumis d'abord à l'ascension
militaire. Il y a des conférences
régulières qui rassemblent journalistes
et militaires pour convenir de ce qui
peut être dit et de ce qui n'est pas.
Donc on vente en permanence les
merveilles de la démocratie israélienne
où tout peut être dit. En gros, tout
peut être dit sur les Arabes, ça oui, il
y a pas de limite sur il faut qu'il
foutent le camp, il faut les transférer,
c'est des c'est des bêtes, c'est des
animaux, c'est des c'est de la vermine
et tout. Tout ça tout ça euh existe par
contre pour rendre compte des opérations
israéliennes en territoire occupé. Là,
il faut quand même en passer par la
censure.
En France, on a un truc En France, on a
un truc qui Attends, attends, attends.
En France, on a un truc extraordinaire
que tu dois connaître.
C'est l'autocensure du journaliste. Tu
le connais bien celui-là ? Non. He Alin,
tu veux pas parler un peu de ça ? ce ce
côté un peu autocensure du journaliste
et ce petit tu m'autorises à être
vulgaire Alain
du haut de ton grand âge tu m'autorises
ce petit léchage de fesse de la
rédaction pour pas contrarier
et ce petit côté autocensure je me
demande comment c certains journalistes
peuvent peuvent s'appeler journalistes
ça c'est bon c'est c'est un vaste débat
qui dépasse largement la question
palestinienne. Non, mais c'est tu
soulèves un vrai problème mais c'est
encore plus sur la question
palestinienne parce que en gros
c'estàd si tu couvres cette question
tu risques de prendre des coups et euh
je veux dire tu as intérêt à être dans
le discours dominant et le discours
dominant après le 7 octobre pas
forcément celui du monde mais celui des
moi pas seulement de ces news mais pour
moi France France culture encore plus et
ça c'était un un un discours
d'injonction à condamner le Hamas à ne
pas prendre de recul à accuser tous les
gens qui euh bon à ne pas inviter les
gens. Moi, j'ai je j'ai un âge j'ai j'ai
passé l'âge d'avoir un problème avec le
fait d'être invité. Mais bon, je suis
quand même un une des personnes qui a
écrit sur la question palestinienne et
ça je n'ai pas et depuis le 7 octobre,
je n'étais invité ni France interre, ni
France Culture ni je parle même pas des
des chaînes de télé. Moi j'en ai rien à
faire mais
tu peux remercier ma communauté, notre
communauté de nous financer parce queon
peut inviter qui on veut, quand on veut,
tant
Absolument. Je je
financez-nous sur Tipi, on a besoin de
vous surtout en ce moment. Bravo à vous.
Alors donc
et on paye 20 % de TVA. On n pas la
niche fiscale de notre allémi Alain
Grèche de 7500 € par an.
Non, c'est fini ça.
Non, elle est pas finie mais
comme retraité, je ai pas droit.
Mettez-nous mettez-nous un petit tipi,
ça nous permettra de continuer de faire
des des bonnes interviews. On a vraiment
besoin de vous. Il y a quand même c'est
dire un caractère moutonnier de des
journalistes souvent parce qu'ils n'ont
pas le c'est une question ils n'ont pas
le temps c'est dire quand ils se passent
ils ont pas le temps où ils sont passés
vers Montburnet je suis désolé d'être
très vulgaire mais
quand normalement les gens qui écrivent
sur le proche orient surtout les y
compris le Figaro sont raconte enfin je
je suis pas forcément d'accord avec ce
qu'ils disent mais ils connaissent le
sujet le problème c'est que dès que tu
as une crise comme ça tu envoies
n'importe qui.
et euh c'està dire sur place tu il y a
au lieu d'avoir une personne qui va
faire des des article tu vas avoir 15
qui n'ont pas le qui n'ont pas le recul
qui n'ont pas le temps de de et qui
effectivement ont peur parce que c'est
la seule question où tu peux te faire
accuser d'être un antisémite où tu peux
bon donc
collaborer avec les
voilà enfin il y a il y a vraiment donc
il y a et je raconte chaque fois cette
anecdote que m'avait raconté un ami sov
soviétique à la fin de la période Gorb
avait des amis soviétiqu des amis
soviétiques en plus voilà je suis un
type très suspect mais c'est une
délégation de journaliste soviétique qui
est invité aux États-Unis c'est au
moment où vraiment on peut parler à peu
près de tout en urs. Ça a pas duré
longtemps mais
comment il s'appelle ce mec le
journaliste soviétique le vieux Tu
parles du gros vieux là ?
Non.
Bon vas-y continue.
Non. Et donc, ils vont faire le tour des
rédactions Los Angeles Time, euh New
York Times, Washington Post et cetera.
Et puis ils reviennent euh à Washington,
je crois, rencontrer le syndicat
national des journalistes. Il leur dit
"Alors, qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé ?"
Et il y a un journaliste soviétique qui
dit "Mais c'est extraordinaire chez
vous, vous n'avez pas de sens sûr et
tout le monde pense pareil."
Et j'ai trouvé que ça ça ça reflétait
quelque chose quoi. C'està-dire c'est
alors heureusement il y a il y a le
monde, il y a il y a des journalistes,
il y a les réseaux sociaux. Moi je pense
que beaucoup de la parole critique sur
la guerre de contre Gaza a été possible
grâce aux réseaux sociaux. C'est pas
étonnant. C'estàd moi, je pense que une
des raisons pour les que les Américains
ont de bloquer TikTok, c'est que TikTok
ça a été massivement palestinien. Mais
il y a d'autres trucs avec
Non non, il y a il y a il y a d'autres
trucs mais je sais plus quel c'est un
sénateur américain qui a qui a reconnu.
Il a dit oui, c'est effectivement la
dont ils ont couvert le le le conflit
c'est c'estes problématiques. Alors que
Facebook a a pris des mesures de censure
en disant on n'utilise pas le terme
génocide, on génocide. On peut dire il y
a pas de génocide mais c'est un débat.
la Cour internationale de justice a dit
quelque chose. Donc voilà donc c'est il
y a possibilité c'estd on n'est pas un
pays totalitaire donc on a la j'ai
possibilité de parler ou
il y a tes risques et péril ça fait pas
l'autocensure comme tout le monde pas
j'ai plus rien à perdre mais
effectivement
tu es sûr que tu as plus rien à perdre
oui je crois ouais
alors on va t'engager
non je déconne pas on va t'engager et on
va te transformer en reporteur de guerre
non à mon âge tu es tu es un peu dur
avec moi.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que bah écoute, j'ai pas 20 ans
pour aller d'abord, j'ai jamais été
vraiment un reporteur. Moi, je sais plus
toujours été plutôt analiste.
Est-ce que tu es un journaliste qui a
plus rien à perdre ou qui a pas froid
aux yeux ? Parce que là, on est en train
de faire des levés de pognon auprès d'
gauche à droite pour faire du reporter
du reporter de guerre. Est-ce que tu as
un un journaliste qui n'a pas peur de la
mort à nous envoyer ?
Écoute, je vais réfléchir. Je suis pas
sûr. J'ai envie d'envoyer quelqu'un à la
mort. et d'avoir la responsabilité s'il
lui arrive quelque chose.
Personne.
Non, comme ça non, je Mais nous on
cherche à monter une équipe de tête
brûlée.
Ouais.
Mais de vraies tête brûlée.
Des mecs sans aucune limite.
Ouais.
On cherche des gens comme ça. Donc
tuésites pas à nous faire remonter des
noms mais on veut des vraies têtes
brûlées.
Ouais. Ouais.
Pas des
mecs qui ont vraiment pas peur.
Ouais. Mais vous les assurez quand même.
Non, onassure rien. On prend pas
d'avocat, on prend pas de négociateur.
On va pour aller au caspip.
Ouais, ça je
Non,
bah à mon avis, il faut prendre déjà
entre 20 et 30 ans. C'est plus tellement
les gens que je fréquente maintenant.
C'est vrai. Bon, question internet.
Merci messieurs pour vos explications.
J'apprends que la Cour internationale de
justice s'annonce la tenue d'audience
jeudi et vendredi à la demande de
l'Afrique du Sud qui saisit la
juridiction pour demander à Israël le
retrait des de ses troupes à Rafa.
Pourriez-vous nous expliquer pourquoi
c'est l'Afrique du Sud qui semble la
plus active au niveau international afin
de mettre les gouvernants israéliens
face à leur responsabilité relevant du
droit international ? Bah, il y a
plusieurs raisons. D'abord, c'est que
euh l'Afrique du Sud a toujours eu enfin
l'Afrique du Sud post appartide a
toujours été très solidaire des
Palestiniens. Et euh Mandela a une
phrase célèbre qui dit euh "On on ne
sera jamais totalement libre tant que la
Palestine ne sera pas libre."
Euh c'est d'autant plus important qu'il
faut rappeler que en gros de la création
de l'État d'Israël à la fin de la
période d'apartide, il y a eu une
alliance stratégique entre Israël et
l'Afrique du Sud. Donc il y a forcément,
je dirais, une certaine forme de
ressentiment à l'égard de cette
politique. Et ce qui était positif dans
cette prise de position, c'est que
tu parles à un moment où ils ont
développé l'arme nucléaire.
Ils ont développé, ils ont permis, ils
étaient au seuil. les l'Afrique du Sud
était au seuil du nucléaire, mais ils
ont développé aussi, mais ça ça a été
des armes bactériologiques, des armes
génétique. Enfin, vraiment, il y a eu
une collaboration incroyable, je veux
dire, de de c'est c'est d'autant plus
intéressant aussi, ça nous rappelle le
ça nous ramène à l'antisémitisme.
les gens qui ont pris le pouvoir, le
parti qui prend le pouvoir en 48 en
Afrique du Sud, c'est le Parti national
qui est l'héritier d'un parti qui
était pour que l'Afrique du Sud entre au
côté entre en guerre du côté de
l'Allemagne nazi et qu' avait des
sympathies nazi.
Et euh donc il y a quelque chose d'assez
étonnant dans cette alliance. Et il y a
un professeur israélien qui a écrit sur
la politique extérieure Israël. Il dit
"Comment se fait-il que ce parti pro
enfin antisémite profondément euh a
quand même fait une alliance avec Israël
?" Et il dit, c'est très simple parce
que ils ne considérait pas du tout les
Israéliens comme des Juifs, mais comme
des colons, comme les Africains du Sud
Blancidéraient et qui avaient
effectivement une collaboration très
importante. Ils ont mené des guerres
ensemble, enfin des opérations ensemble
en en Angola dans les colonies
portugaises et cetera et cetera. Donc il
y a eu cette donc tout ça a créé les
conditions pour que l'Afrique du Sud se
intervienne. Et ce qui est ce qui est
important je trouve parce qu'il il y a
eu aussi d'autres pays comme le
Nicaragua et cetera, c'est que l'Afrique
du Sud c'est un pays avec des
institutions démocratiques. Euh c'est
pas c'est pas si la Russie l'avait fait,
ça aurait eu moins de poids quoi. Donc
là il y avait quand même quelque chose.
Si la Russie avait protégé Gaza comme le
leurs enclaves, ça serait pas pareil,
hein. Il faut dire que deux puissances
nucléaires qui s'affrontent, ça devient
compliqué très rapidement. Compliqué.
Oui. Oui. Mais euh et bon,
il y a le président colombien qui au
sommet de Davos a moqué Emmanuel Macron
en disant la devise, liberté, égalité,
fraternité, elle est partie de la de la
France à l'Afrique du Sud. Et je pense
qu'il y avait quelque chose de de de
vrai quoi. C'està-dire que voilà un pays
qui euh malgré tous ses défauts comme
tous les pays a pris en compte le droit
international et c'est c'est fait le
porte-parole de la défense du droit
international.
Oui, nous on a Emmanuel Macron.
Et oui,
on fait un peu de prospective avec des
vieux. On aime bien, c'est notre petit
truc. Le soir, on se réunit avec des
vieux. Bien parce que on ne risque rien
parce que au moment où je voudra voir
vérifier
si nos perspectives ont été bonne sera
plus là. Bon, on va faire parler Ironi
en premier parce que c'est le plus
jeune, il risque d'être là encore. Donc,
on se retrouve avec Israël, on se
retrouve avec la Palestine,
il y a un réchauffement climatique,
il y a des problèmes d'accessibilité aux
ressources, il y a des problèmes
d'accessibilité à l'eau, il y a des
mouvements migratoires terribles qui
sont en train de se préparer avec le le
réchauffement climatique,
des troubles économiques et
d'instabilité monétaire devant nous. Euh
comment Israël va survivre euh au milieu
de tout ça ? Alors, Israël avec les
Palestiniens dedans ou les Palestiniens
avec les Israéliens dedans,
vous sentez pas que ça se tend un petit
peu ou vous sentez pas qu'Israël est en
train de de s'élargir un petit peu
territorialement pour pouvoir encaisser
les 20 prochaines années à venir au
détriment des Palestiniens peut-être
parce que l'accessibilité aux
ressources, la production alimentaire,
le réchauffement climatique, les
pénuries énergétiques, comment ça se
passe ? Vous voyez le le destin de la
région comment ?
On l'a dit tout à l'heure, Israël veut
s'étendre territorialement, maîtriser
l'intégralité de la Palestine
historique. Ça c'est plus du tout un
mystère. Ce qui reste à discuter, à
vérifier, c'est jusqu'où ils vont aller
jusqu'au bout. Est-ce qu'ils vont
s'arrêter en chemin ? Est-ce qu'il vont
aller en Irak ?
Ça euh non. Ça non, ça vraiment je je le
crois non. Je pense que le Je pense que
le Jourdain Oui oui oui. Disons je me je
m'avance en disant que le Jourdain et la
limite raisonne. Sinon effectivement la
Palestine biblique c'est de de d'une île
à Lefrat. Donc oui mais là je crois que
c'est vraiment on en est plus là
heureusement.
Mais moi ce que je je crois même en
faisant abstraction des fléaux ou des
des perspectives
angoissante que tu évoquais phénomène
massif de de déplacement de population,
réchauffement climatique extrême et
cetera.
Israël est dans une très mauvaise
posture. D'abord le littoral israélien
qui comporte un certain nombre d'usines
de dessement. Je lisais ça dans un RS il
y a pas il y a pas longtemps euh va
reculer significativement et donc mettre
en en difficulté les l'approvisionnement
en e peut-être d'ailleurs le fait que on
se précipite sur toutes les nap
fréatiques du du coin pour les se les
approprier que ce soit en Si Jordanie ou
à Gaza
puis que le le le cours du Jourdin est
régulé en faveur les plateaux aussi
des Israéliens et le plateau du Golan
effectivement. Donc bon la la ressource
en eau est très est très importante mais
je me sens je me sens pas suffisamment
compétent du point de vue disons
géographique géophysique pour arriver à
à à en dire autre chose que c'est un
facteur qui compte et qui conditionne
pour partie l'avenir d'Israël. Mais je
pense qu'il y a quelque chose qui
surplombe cela qui est en gros le refuge
d'Israël dans le mythe de de Sanson. Euh
Sanson, c'est celui qui euh se suicide
pour euh pour euh
pour tuer ses ennemis pour tuer ses tuer
ses ennemis en en poussant et son était
russe,
c'est ça.
Israël est engagé dans une politique
suicidaire et je pense que ça euh
enfin ça c'est la réalité la plus la la
plus forte. Le problème étant parce que
moi je ne suis pas contre le suicide en
principe, le problème c'est qu'ils
emmènent avec eux des gens qui n'ont pas
fait ce choix et que c'est l'ensemble de
de la région en tout cas Israël
Palestine et peut-être autour un peu
aussi qui va être concerné par cette
perspective apocalyptique. Les
apocalyptiques sont au pouvoir soit par
croyance
fondamentale comme Benengvir et Smotrich
qui sont vraiment des apocalyptiques,
des messianiques soutenus par leurs
homologues évangéliques qui voient le
jugement dernier se arriver. Bon, on
voit des gens de mon âge, des pasteurs,
des prêcheurs qui se déclarent
convaincus que ils verront l'arrivée du
Messie. Donc l'apocalypse, le jugement
dernier, le règne du Christ, tout ça
c'est pour demain quoi que c'est que
c'est là. Donc un certain nombre de gens
ils croient. D'autres s'arrangent pour
que ça leur euh ça ça s'aille dans leur
intérêt comme enfin dans leur intérêt
supposé comme euh Netaniau et euh et les
différents ministres qui sont euh euh
autour de lui ou dans le cabinet de
guerre comme Benny Gansz euh ou comme
Israakzog le le président de la
République. des personnalités décrites
dans la presse française comme modéré,
centriste, centre droit, centre gauche
qui dit enfin qui qui sont totalement
qui adhèrent totalement au but de guerre
israélien avec y compris avec
l'incertitude de ces buts de guerre,
mais en tout cas à la brutalité de la
guerre menée par les Israéliens
et au fait de laisser aucun rép au
Palestiniens. Tout cela me fait penser
qu'il y a une espèce de dynamique
autodestructrice
qui est à l'œuvre qui va entraîner sans
doute un grand nombre de départs
d'Israéliens
hors hors d'Israël. Il me semble que
avant, ça reste à vérifier, mais je
crois avoir euh lu en en septembre
dernier ou en octobre à l'époque des
grandes manifes contre la réforme de la
justice, donc contre Netaniaou et pour
la protection de la Cour suprême. Cour
suprême qui entre parenthèses n'est pas
un parangon de démocratie comme l'a
raconté Alain tout à l'heure. important
garder l'esprit parce que l'idée l'idée
qu'on se fait de la démocratie en
Israël, c'est quand même d'abord et
avant tout la démocratie pour les juifs.
C'est Israël est un état juif et
démocratique, disait le député
communiste Ahmed Tibi. Oui, état
démocratique pour les Juifs et juif pour
les Arabes. C'est comme ça qu'il de
cette formule bien ramassée et très
habile qu'il
qu'il résumait de la situation. Et donc
je pense je je me souviens d'avoir lu
dans un R, le quotidien israélien, une
le résultat d'un sondage selon lequel 30
un petit tiers 30 % des Israéliens
estimaient que leur avenir ne se situait
plus en Israël et que ils souhaitait
partir en Europe, aux États-Unis, en
Australie, enfin dans les lieux de de
d'immigration, d'expatriation
habituelle. en en Israël alors qu'il y
avait il y avait pas euh la guerre.
Cette guerre
d'une brutalité extrême comme on l'a
dit, elle a des effets en retour de
brutalisation de la Quand on voit quand
on voit ces ces ces jeunes gens en train
de se faire des des selfies rigolards
sur fond de ruine, sur fond de décombre,
moi en tout cas je ne peux pas imaginer
un instant qu'il rentre chez eux, qu'il
se défassent de qu'il se défondent de
leur uniforme et qu'il reprennent une
vie euh ordinaire. Sinon, ça devient des
cogneurs, des bruts, des on peut pas se
conduire en inhumain
comme ça une partie de la enfin de la
journée ou de son de son existence et
rentrer chez soi.
Ils sont pas tous comme ça.
Oui, beaucoup. Il y en a quand même
beaucoup. Ils font la guerre. Cette
guerre, elle se fait avec des hommes,
avec des gens qui tirent sur des
immeubles dans lesquels ils savent qu'il
y a des dizaines ou des centaines de
civils qui tirent sur des écoles qui qui
minent des universités. Tu sais que la
pratiquement la plupart des universités
ont été détruites et quand elles étaient
pas détruites, elles ont été minées par
des unités du génie qui venaient qui
venait terminer le boulot. Arrête ou je
ne sais plus, je vis tellement de choses
dans le domaine que je peux pas être je
suis pas à même de mais c'est une
notoriété publique. C'est pas du tout
des calomnies des saletés que je
répandrai sural. C'est c'est la la
technique de guerre quand on dit rendre
Gaza invivable. C'est au pied de la
lettre qu'il faut prendre question.
Que pense Alain éronique de la théorie
militaire d'Aya qui consiste à faire
tellement de dégâts que ça dissuaderait
l'ennemi supposé de refaire une
opération similaire.
Oui oui c'est mais juste pourquoi est-ce
qu'on détruit jusqu'au cimetière ? Je
laisse je connais Darriam je laisser à
la réponse étudi l'histoire américaine
nord-américaine ? Tu as étudié
l'histoire nord-américaine ?
Euh non pas spécifiquement non pourquoi
ta question c'est pourquoi on détruit
les cimetières ? Oui, parce que je dire
les cibières c'est pas des c'est pas des
abris militaires, c'est pas des QG,
c'est pas des centres de commande mais
le cimetière c'est des lieux où
l'histoire d'une société se se joue et
donc détruire le cimetière c'est
détruire aussi l'histoire de cette
société. Donc Gaza ne doit plus avoir
rien de palestinien,
ni son habitation, enfin ni sa
population, ni son habitat, ni sa
culture, ni rien.
Oui. C'est l'idée que
sur la prospective avec Israël en de
démocratie au milieu de tous ces
barbares.
Non, c'était pas ça la question, c'était
euh
théorie militaire d'Aria,
c'est-à-dire euh il faut les battre
assez fort pour qu'il ne recommence pas.
C'est une théorie qui est, je cite dans
dans le livre plusieurs
comment il s'appelle le livre
euh
Palestine, un peuple qui ne veut pas
mourir.
Fais voir la couverture qui est juste à
tes pieds.
Tu vas faire travailler un peu le
caméraman qui fait que de s'endormir.
Les éditions, les éditions, c'est
J'arrive pas.
Les liens qui libèrent. Les
liens qui libèrent.
C'est joli comme titre d'édition.
Et euh
combien ça coûte ?
18 €.
Tu prends combien dessus ?
Vas-y, continue.
Euh
l'idée
à plusieurs reprises, les les Israéliens
ont dit "On va taper fort comme ça ils
ne recommenceront plus." Et c'est l'idée
que on peut bâtir une sécurité sur la
force et sur l'écrasement de l'autre.
Alors toutes les les l'histoire du monde
montre que c'est pas vrai. C'est-à-dire
on peut alors ce qu'on peut faire comme
je disais tout à l'heure sur le le
colonialisme, on peut éliminer tous les
euh tous les autochtones.
Donc tu as étudié le le droit le
l'histoire américaine
avec les ind les réserves, de la langue,
les couvertures à la petite virole. Donc
il y a tout ça euh c'est possible mais
euh là ils ils ne peuvent pas faire ça.
Ils ne peuvent pas le réclam enfin ils
peuvent pas s'en réclamer. Ils ils
essayent d'obtenir l'expulsion mais
c'est dur parce que c'est c'est une
population qui a l'expérience la
population palestinienne qui s'accroche
à la terre. Donc euh le problème c'est
qu'il faut renoncer à une mentalité qui
est la mentalité de la force
simplement. Alors comme pour donner un
un point positif quand même, enfin pour
donner un peu de lueur d'espoir,
c'est possible aussi le 7 octobre a été
un terrible choc pour la société
israélienne,
pour les les crimes qui ont été commis,
mais aussi parce que c'est la première
fois depuis
48 et la création de l'État d'Israël,
enfin au 49, c'estàd au moment du CC le
feu où Israël est attaqué sur son propre
territoire
et ça bouscule toutes les théories
On a créé Israël pour être un un lieu
sûr, un refuge pour les pour les juifs
du monde et je pense que ça peut
ébranler les gens. Et on a Henri avait
envoyé quelqu'un qui a fait un long
reportage très intéressant sur
euh sur Israël, la société israélienne
et cetera. Et le titre c'est est-ce
c'est posé par les par les Est-ce que
est-ce qu'il y a un avenir pour Israël ?
C'est il y a vraiment la prise de
conscience. Enfin, il peut y avoir une
prise de conscience que c'est pas
vivable. En plus, avec jamais Israël n'a
été aussi isolé au niveau de le de de
l'opinion internationale. C'est tout le
crédit qu'ils avaient comme état refuge,
l'héritier de la de du génocide et
cetera est en train de de disparaître.
Et bon, ça peut créer les conditions
d'une prise de conscience que cette voie
euh militaire est une voie qui est qui
est bouchée, qu'il faut trouver autre
chose. Bon, ça c'est la
c'est quand même c'est quand même
difficile parce que le la cho a existé,
il y a eu des millions de morts. Là
aujourd'hui, on voit que il y a des tags
antisémites sur les mémoriaux. Mais
enfin, il faut pas mettre tout au même
niveau. Je veux dire, c'est pas il y a
des tags antisémites sans doute, mais ça
veut pas dire qu'on est à la veille de
d'un génocide en France ou d'envoyer les
populations la population juive dans des
camps. Je veux dire, il faut être quand
même,
je veux dire,
les juifs sont aujourd'hui en sécurité
quand même aux États-Unis. Ils sont plus
en sécurité en Europe et aux États-Unis
qu'en Israël. Ça ça c'est vrai. C'est
aussi un des échecs extraordinaire du du
du sionisme. Donc euh alors le problème
c'est que on voit bien à quel point le
génocide est est utilisé au au risque de
le de le dévaloriser. C'està dire on
entend des gens dire mais finalement
c'est plus comme Israël s'en sert pour
défendre sa politique qui est
inacceptable. Il y a des gens qui disent
"Oui, mais finalement, est-ce que
c'était vraiment un génocide ?" Mais
euh, je veux dire, c'est quand même une
voix qui est bouchée. Alors, c'est si on
veut laisser un peu d'espoir, c'est
encore une fois le fait de dire que sur
le territoire historique de la
Palestine, il y a autant de juifs
israéliens que de Palestiniens, qu'il y
a pas de solution euh militaire et que
donc l'espoir c'est effectivement une
prise de conscience des sociétés. Mais
aussi c'est pour c'est aussi ce que
disait tout à l'heure, il faut des
pressions internationales et les
pressions internationales, elles doit
être contrairement à ce qu'on a fait
jusqu'à présent sur la partie la plus
forte c'estàdire Israël pas sur les
Palestiniens pour trouver des formes
d'accommandement de vivre ensemble. Je
ne sais pas sous quelle forme c'est les
Palestiniens et les Israéliens qui
décideront deux États, un état
confédéral et cetera et ça mais où il y
ait un principe de base, c'est
l'égalité.
Est-ce que Israël a toujours autant peur
du boycotte de ces produits exportés ?
Moi je pense pas que c'est du boycotte.
Il y a tout un mouvement qui s'élo
Oui. Non, il y a le mouvement BDS,
boycott des investissements en sanction
qui donne des résultats. Notamment euh
il y a eu quelques éléments et les dans
les universités américaines, c'est ce
qui réclame, c'est que les les
universités américaines disposent de
sommes colossales qui sont investisies
qu'ils se désinvestissent de d'un
certain nombre de
ce qu'ils ont fait clarement là. Oui.
Donc il y a des choses qui se
qui se font, mais il y a un autre
élément qui est qui est important
aujourd'hui, c'est le c'est en fait que
les le boycott culturel, c'est-à-dire
que Israël est tellement euh devenu un
sujet polémique que ça devient de plus
en plus difficile aux artistes
israéliens, au aux écrivains et cetera
de venir en France. Ça devrait être
l'inverse.
Ça devrait être l'inverse.
Oui, mais c'est pas le cas parce que je
veux dire quand même pas une
malheureusement c'est on dit souvent les
euh bon c'est ce qu'on a dit sur les les
gens de Kibout qui ont été tués le camp
de la paix et cetera. Le camp de la paix
c'est un c'est un concept très vague
parce que euh
globalement il n'y a pas de force
politique aujourd'hui importante. Je je
mets à part les les
députés. Il y a pas de force politique
importante qui réclament deux états.
C'estàd c'est pas seulement Netaniaou.
C'est-à-dire c'est G, il est pas mieux.
Je veux dire, on a eu un gouvernement où
il a on a oublié ça, il a perdu le
pouvoir pendant 1 an. Ça a été
exactement la même politique.
Donc euh voilà, c'est euh il faut
trouver euh bon là aussi, je dirais la
communauté internationale en laissant
faire Israël rend un mauvais service à à
Israël. Je veux dire et au et aux
Israéliens.
Question internet
de profane. Actuellement le chef du
gouvernement israélien est issu du li un
parti conservateur parfois classé à
l'extrême droite entre parenthèses.
Est-ce que ce terme est approprié ?
Fermez la parenthèse. Je ne comprends
pas cette orientation politique au
regard de l'histoire du peuple juif. Ce
cela me semble antinomique. Pouvez-vous
m'éclairer ? Merci d'avance.
Je te laisse ou
Oui.
Et pendant ce tempslà, Alain va préparer
ses trois bouquins à conseiller. Tuas
pas fait tes devoirs toi,
tu es journaliste.
La réponse,
tu fais tout dernier moment.
La réponse à la question et oui le le
licou et l'héritier du Rout qui était
décrit par
des grandes personnalités Anna Rent
Gerschom Albert Einstein
comme
proche des partis nazis et fascistes des
Oui oui ils utilisaient le mot après la
guerre. Oui oui absolument. Oui oui il y
a aucun
aucun doute là-dessus. Je lisais encore
hier soir un texte à ce sujet. Donc euh
leur leur origine, elle est là. Il faut
aussi savoir que euh d'ailleurs Charles
Derlin, le le journaliste et séiste
Charles Derlin avait fait une belle
enquête là-dessus sur les accointances
d'une partie de euh disons de d'élite
sociales juives avec euh l'extrême
droite. Il y a eu des croix de feu, il y
a eu Charles, il y a eu des soutiens de
Charles Morini,
la pluie à Mussolini,
la pluie la puie à Mussolini qui était
bien connu disons le le les ancêtres du
du Lou.
On défilait en chemise noire en hommage
les jeunesses du Bard qui étaient le
disons les les les les fascistes
sionistes défilé en chemise noire ou en
chemise brune, je ne me souviens plus
précisément.
comme ça. Donc il y a une longue
tradition
de juifs d'extrême droite notamment du
côté sioniste.
Cette tradition, elle est cachée par une
autre tradition quand même plus
sympathique, en tout cas à mes yeux, qui
est la longue tradition majoritaire
de l'engagement juif en en en direction
d'une politique universaliste
euh disons de de justice et de liberté
pour le le dire le dire vite. D'où le
judéo bolchévisme. D'ailleurs, bolchevis
n'a pas été vraiment un instrument de
liberté, mais non, mais l'idéal
communiste était un idéal émancipateur,
universaliste.
Non, mais on part toujours sur des bons
slogans mais en général ça termine
toujours sucette. Oui, d'accord. Mais
quand même, c'est c'est important. Tu es
toujours parvenu, hein,
quand on quand on s'engage en politique,
savoir si on on s'engage pour écraser de
la vermine
Youin,
euh
boule et
pas comme ça.
Non, non, mais il faut utiliser les mots
qui ont été utilisés. Bah oui, de de
l'époque. Donc s'eng c'est c'est quand
des gens qui s'engageaient dans des
miles d'extrême droite, c'est bien de
ça. C'est pour écraser la vermine.
C'est de ver toujours déshumanisé
l'ennemi en comparant
et des gens qui s'engageaient euh disons
en direction du communiste. Je sais que
je suis pas communiste, c'est pas du
tout la question mais qui s'engage en
dans dans cette perspective là
révolutionnaire disons le socialisme
révolutionnaire pour le dire de façon
plus précise.
Le flambimou
et bien si tu veux euh c'était c'était
quand même dans une perspective
généreuse.
Ain arrête de te marrer.
Donc donc ça fait je pense une
différence et bien dans l'ensemble les
jeunesses juives y compris d'ailleurs
pour une partie des jeunessionistes
utopistes qui qui ont cru que il y avait
là-bas un désert qui attendait d'être
mis en valeur que le retour à la
patrioge quelque chose.
Oui oui
pour se reconstruire
voilà euh transformer le négève en en en
un verger et cetera. Il y avait des des
idéaux qui qui n'étaient pas
sanguinaires, qui n'étaient pas
meurtriers. Mais disons cette utopie ou
ce rêve sioniste émancipateur a tourné
au cauchemar assez vite. Là c'est le
cauchemar démultiplié. il a tourné assez
vite. Donc ne ne pensons pas que parce
que les juifs ont été euh victimes d'un
d'un génocide par les les nazis, par
donc un monstre politique, cela immunise
contre des tentations qui
s'apparentent
à ça, tentation destructrices, raciste.
Tant qu'il y a pas eu d'enquête, tant
qu'il y a pas eu tout ça, c'est
compliqué d'employer euh
d'employer quoi ? Tu allait dire
génocide.
Ben, je vois que tu préamptes.
Je suis
Ah oui oui. L'esprit de censure est
partout. Décidément, d'abord si je veux
parler de de génocide, je n'hésiteraiis
pas à le faire. Je ne vais pas
m'autoensurer. Je pense qu'il y a un
risque effectif de génocide que la Cour
internationale de justice
a fait un travail
important et courageux. Euh
en employant ce mot, ils auraient pu
parler de crime contre l'humanité, crime
de guerre. Ils ont choisi ce mot et ne
croyons pas que c'est parce qu'on a été
soi-même victime majeure d'un d'une
monstruosité
politique à un moment de son histoire,
on soit euh immunisé. Il y a pour disons
une mémoire comme ça, elle se partage en
deux. Il y a la partie de la mémoire qui
mais pas chez la même personne. En tout
cas, il y a cette partie de la mémoire
qui voit les un idéal émancipateur et
égalitaire comme le seul à même de
combattre cette ces ces ces idéologies
suprémacistes violentes, hein, pour
rassembler tout cela. Et puis il y a
ceux qui disent "Mais on nous a laissé
crever tout seul, on sait qu'on a pas
d'amis, on il y a que nous pour nous
défendre. Donc dès que il y a un sourcil
foncé, on tire dans le tas." Grosso
modo, donc la paranoïa euh
étatique, militaire, policière d'un état
qui s'estime assiéger. Comme ça a été
rappelé, les Arabes sont les descendants
d'Hitler selon la
disons le le discours sioniste dominant
et surtout le discours israélien
dominant. Donc on est entouré d'Hitler.
Et Baraak, dernier premier ministre
supposément travailliste ayant été à la
tête de l'État israélien parler d'Israël
comme d'une villa dans la jungle. Donc
un lieu de civilisation entouré de bêtes
féroces avec lesquels évidemment on
discute pas. On discute pas avec un
scorpion, un serpent,
un jaguar qui veut vous vous égorger.
Donc
on a là tout un on a là un programme
politique clair. Il ajoutait d'ailleurs
dans la même interview que les Arabes ne
savent pas discerner entre la vérité et
le mensonge. La preuve c'est il la
tenait du directeur adjoint de du FBI
qu'il avait avec qui il avait discuté la
veille. C'est quand il était premier
ministre ça. Il avait lors d'un voyage
aux États-Unis donc il avait rencontré
un patron du FBI qui lui avait dit selon
Barak que on ne peut pas passer le
désateur de mensonge aux Arabes parce
qu'ils savent pas la différence entre
une blague de c'est une blague de merde.
C'est c'est une fausse blague.
Enfin c'est par c'est c'est claque. Non
non, c'est une interview d'un premier
ministre par un historien de premier
planu
paru dans l'une des revues l'un des
magazines les plus importants
la New York Review of Book. Tu connais
la qualité des journalistes ?
Non non. Un un premier ministre part
journaliste.
Tu es en train de me dire que déjà le
FBI qui fait passer un détecteur de
mensonge et qui dit c'est une vieille
blague.
C'est un
c'est pas une blague du tout. Oui, mais
ça par Non, mais ce qu'il faut
c'est ce ce moment-là de notre
conversation est intéressant parce qu'il
permet de prendre la mesure de
l'énormité
à peine croyable des propos qui sont par
exemple au lendemain,
ça reste des gros bouffes mais même à ce
niveau-là hein. Mais
c'est ça où tu il faut il faut arrêter
de les de leur les mettre sur un
piédestal. Ben c'est pas moi qui met sur
la en l'occurrence c'est c'est toi qui
n'arrive pas à penser que c'est autre
chose qu'une blague. Ça n'est pas une
blague. C'est un propos sérieux qui a
une traduction politique qui est qui a
une existence matérielle dans la société
israélienne. Non non c'est pas du tout
une blague. la même façon que quand les
des généticiens,
pas encore israéliens mais activistes
sionistes allaient rencontrer au
lendemain de la guerre des généticiens
d'un d'un institut d'un grand institut
de recherche allemand, l'institut
William Kaiser ou un truc comme ça.
qu'il a dit ça
en 45 46 pour aller leur donc c'était
des nazis hein, c'était des généticiens
qui travaillaient pour le système nazi à
qui ces généticiens juifs allaient euh
demander ce qu'ils avaient trouvé en
matière de gène juif parce que l'idée
sioniste fondamentale qui les sionistes
ne sont pas nécessairement des religieux
d'ailleurs même les religieux étaient
antisionistes avant de de se convertir
pour une partie d'entre eux
c'est sourcé ce que tu me dis là
oui bien sûr bien sûr
mais c'est sourcé
Oh là là là, je j'ai pas la mémoire
suffisante pour sortir le truc, mais il
suffit de le il y a il y a eu euh euh
toute une
il y a eu de nombreuses études sur les
études les études de les recherches
génétiques euh nazif
et il y a des des études sur la la santé
publique et les recherches de santé
publiqu et euh ces ces rencontres qui
ont été officielles hein, c'était pas
des trucs cachés, on n'en faisait pas
grand bruit Mais ça a été ça a été
officiel. Elles avaient pour but de
localiser le gêne juif parce qu' savent
pas définir les juifs. C'est ça aussi le
problème. Pas comment on définit un juif
?
Il faut comme a dit Schlomoand,
si on n'est pas religieux, on est une
ethnie. Donc les juifs la sont pour une
minorité des religieux, pour une
majorité des gens qui n'ont pas de
pratique religieuse et probablement pas
de véritable cro les éthiopiens, ils
sont bien considérés en Israël. Non, ils
sont il y a beaucoup d'ailleurs j'ai
remarqué, je j'ai pas pu vérifier que
dans les photos des soldats morts, il y
avait beaucoup de juifs éthiopien. À mon
avis, c'est enfin ils servent de
de Sheraken. Non non non, il y a il y a
un racisme très fort contre
Oui. Non, je je voulais dire je voulais
juste dire que il y a moi c'est c'est
chez le l'historien Schlomoossand que
j'ai j'ai puisé cette image. C'est il
parle de peuple race pour parler des des
juifs dans la conception
euh euh c'estàdire la construction d'un
peuple qui est uni biologiquement par
des puisque de toute façon il y a ni
culture ni langue ni pratique sociales
qui unissent l'ensemble des juifs qui
sont dispersés dans le monde entier qui
parlent des tas de langues différentes
qui sont loin les uns des autres. Par
contre, si c'est une race, au sens
biologique du terme, c'est là que des
des des comment dire des choses assez
peu ragoutante reviennent à l'esprit
quoi. La la notion biologique de race,
elle est quand même très comment dire
très lourde, très chargée euh
historiquement.
Mais bon, les victimes de la choix sont
par définition innocentes et donc d'une
certaine manière les Israéliens peuvent
tous permettre dans ce dans ce domaine
là. De toute façon, si on les écoute, on
les on narrive pas à les entendre parce
que c'est énorme.
Alain, est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Euh bah
déjà le premier livre qui a à tes pieds,
comment ça s'appelle ?
Ben excusez-moi mes livres mais là tu
m'as tu m'as dit il faut
tu m'as dit il faut pas faire de tu vois
j'ai été très discret je voulais pas
faire de publicité et
tu zoomes un peu là-dessus
et ça ne sera pas un des trois livres
que je conseillerai
tu négocies
euh
donc trois livres
alors le premier qui est qui est la
suite de ça il y a un orientaliste
français qui s'appelle Maxime Rinçon qui
était juif aussi qui a écrit des livres
remarquables sur l'histoire et il a un
petit bouquin qui est encore disponible
qui s'appelle peuple juif ou problème
juif et qui essaie justement de
d'éclairer un peu qu'est-ce que c'est
les juifs, les les débats, est-ce qu'ils
ont été toujours persécutés, d'où
viennent les persécutions ? Est-ce que
c'est des persécutions éternelles et
cetera ? Ça, je crois que c'est
très bien. Le deuxième
livre qui pour moi a été très important,
c'est l'orientalisme d'Edouard Saï qui
est un intellectuel
un intellectuel américano
palestinien euh qui s'appelle comment le
comment l'Occident a inventé l'Orient je
crois où c'est
c'est comment en fait les recherches
orientalistes du 19e et du 20e siècle
ont créé une image de de l'Orient qui
était une image déformé et qui un Orient
imaginaire mais qui justifiait le
racisme qui qui justifiait les
discrimination et puis euh quand même
comme je sais que les jeunes générations
ne lisent plus ça, je conseillerai Marx
le manifeste du Parti communiste parce
que c'est un un texte je crois majeur
qui parle justement qui est intéressant
parce qu'il parle de la mondialisation
euh et bon c'est et de qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que signifie la mondialisation
du capitalisme ? Et on a l'impression
des fois de lire des choses qui sont
d'une grande actualité et moi je
regrette, c'est évidemment ma
génération, j'ai grandi avec Marx donc
je regrette un peu que les nouvelles
générations aient un peu passé ses
travaux par perte et fracas.
Ragan, est-ce que tu as trois bouquins à
conseiller notre communauté ?
Ben oui, puisque c'était la règle du
jeu, j'y ai j'y réfléchis. Ça m'a fait
un peu paniquer parce que je j'aurais du
mal à xper comme ça des choses mais bon.
Alors le Vidal 2004 non
donc oui oui, j'en ai j'en ai trouvé
trois deux qui ont un rapport direct
avec le le sujet. Donc le premier c'est
de du journaliste Sylvain Celiste
donc journaliste et et essayiste, grand
connaisseur de la société
israélienne
et membre du comité de MO 21 publicité.
et qui a écrit d'excellents livres dont
le dernier s'appelle l'État d'Israël
contre les Juifs,
dont le titre est déjà une sorte de
manifeste.
Euh malheureusement, ce livre a été mis
en librairie 15 jours avant le début du
Covid et il a été d'une certaine manière
piétiné par le Covid. C'est dommage
parce que c'est un livre qui se lit très
bien. C'est un livre de journaliste
documenté, c'est extrêmement informé
mais avec une écriture fluide qu'on
qu'on suit très bien et qui explique
pourquoi en gros Israël met en danger
pourquoi et comment
Israël met en danger les juifs mais avec
beaucoup de d'enquêtes, beaucoup de
choses vécues
en Israël. Le deuxième livre que je
j'aurais un conseiller est un peu plus
ancien. Il vient d'un architecte, il a
été écrit par un architecte urbaniste
d'origine israélienne mais qui est
maintenant britannique, qui c'est qui
vit qui est prof d'urbanisme
à Londres, qui s'appelle Eal Weitman
et qui s'appelle une occupation civile
et qui est le le qui est en fait le le
catalogue d'une exposition
de d'architecture d'un d'un concours de
de concours d'architecture
qui qui a tenu dans il y a il y a déjà
une vingtaine d'années de cela et qui
était tu as un développement extrêmement
analytique et critique de plutôt une
étude très analytique et critique de
l'architecture spécifique des colonies
de l'architecture et de l'urbanisation
spécifique. C'estd la façon dont on
organise le contrôle d'une population
à laquelle on ne se mélange pas. Il y a
un autre bouquin qui traite de ça, c'est
la militarisation de l'espace urbain.
Oui. Oui. Ben c'est de Yal Weisemman
toujours parce que
paraî très bien être de lui. Oui. Oui.
De toute façon, la la dimension
militaire est très présente. Et donc une
occupation civile, c'est un livre qui se
lit par chapitre indépendant et qui est
absolument
passionnant.
Et puis l'autre, c'est un des derniers
romans que j'ai lu qui m'a littéralement
fasciné, qui qui m'a envoûté qui
s'appelle de Bruno Le,
l'homme qui aimait les chiens de
Leonardo Padoura et qui est notamment
l'histoire de je dis notamment parce que
c'est un livre très toufu, très très
documenté mais notamment l'histoire de
Ramon Mercader, l'homme qui a assassiné
Trotski, ce qui nous met qui nous plonge
dans l'histoire des de l'entraînement
des services spéciaux soviétiques à la
grande époque.
Il nous plonge dans la guerre d'Espagne
et aussi au Mexique où la l'aventure de
Trolski s'est s'est terminé sous les
coups de piolet de enfin les coups de
picaglas de Ramon Mercader. C'est un
polar
fantastique
et et on apprend beaucoup en histoire et
pas seulement pas seulement le plaisir
de la lecture mais aussi le plaisir de
l'apprentissage quoi.
Ronnie, est-ce que tu as un conseil pour
les jeunes générations ?
Euh ça c'est vraiment le genre de choses
auxquelles je ne suis pas très
prédisposé. Moi les les conseils.
OK. Comment tu dis "Je t'aime" en hébreu
?
Je parle pas l'hébreux. Tu essayis de
dire "Je t'aime en comment tu dis je
t'aime" en arabe ?
Ah
donc pas de conseil aux jeunes
générations. Toi tu es bien un
anarchiste toi.
Oui, je viens de là d'ailleurs. Je viens
je viens du Oui oui, je viens de la
Fédération anarchiste avant d'avoir
connu d'autres engagements militants.
Mais il y avait celui-là. Oui. Oui. Oui.
Oui. Donc non, parce que toute
qui tu cons Oui, c'est ça. Non, c'est ça
exactement. bien un vrai anarchiste
et c'est une c'est une mise en scène de
soi-même que je trouve souvent
très c'est c'est ta réponse c'est très
respectable
ce sera une bonne réponse. Alain, est-ce
que tu as un conseil pour les jeunes
générations ? Ben moi, je ne suis pas un
anarchiste et dans la culture et
absolument pas l'anarchisme,
je dirais oui de s'engager. Ce que il y
a aujourd'hui des
c'est que l'avenir du monde dépend aussi
des gens qui et des jeunes. ce qu'on a
dit un peu sur la mobilisation autour
dans les universités américaines montre
que il y a une voix qu'il faut pas il
faut pas sombrer dans
dans l'acceptation de tout, dans le
pessimisme et cetera. Alors, les formes
dans lesquelles ils s'engagent, c'est
les jeunes qui décident, ça peut pas
être évidemment celle dans lesquelles
nos générations se sont engagées avec
avec beaucoup d'erreurs et cetera, mais
avec une volonté de ne pas laisser les
ne pas laisser les choses en l'état, de
de faire que qu'il y ait un peu plus de
justice, qui a qu'on s'attaque au vrais
problèmes, enfin au vrai, il y en a
plein de d'inégalité, de réchauffement
climatique et cetera et que voilà et
qu'il faut trouver les les les formes de
cet engagement. À chaque génération, ça
a été différent mais le plus qu'il faut
pas sombrer dans le comment je dire dans
le pessimisme et l'individualisme et le
et bon le fait de vivre bien enfin en
dehors du monde quoi. Il faut se plonger
dans le monde et essayer autant que se
faire ce peu de le transformer. Nous on
pensait qu'on pouvait le transformer
totalement et rapidement. On s'est
trompé. Mais
tu peux demander pardon d'ailleurs au
nom de ta génération.
Voilà.
Ren Alain, merci.
Merci à toi. Tu vois ?
[Musique]